Õpetaja: Nii päeva päeva teine video.
Õpetaja: Jõudsime siis selleni, et. Ee, meil on selline olukord. Võin pärast selle pildi kuskile Slaki ka panna.
Õpetaja: Võibolla praegu Niukene Kiire shot siis, kui keegi tahab pildi kujul vaadata, Tegingi selle kohe. Ära. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: Panen selle siia generali alla,
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: okei, aga tulevad prinditult kujul. Ka. Meil tegelikult Rohkem huvitab I asja, et joonised rohkem kui kui me hakkame toimetama,
Õpetaja: ehk siis Login View. Näete siin. Ee, selles kohas,
Õpetaja: kus ta kutsub sinna, kutsub välja vastatajale.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me tahame teha niimoodi, et ee, siin selles komponendis oleks Võimekus niiöelda
Õpetaja: kinni püüda. Ja siis siin Templeite osas ka Kuvada infot.
Õpetaja: Props tuleb meile appi.
Õpetaja: Tuleme siia sellesse eksport Default sektsiooni.
Õpetaja: Lööme selle nimi alla. Entre Robs Rops.
Õpetaja: Mis ma. Mis ma järgmisena kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Selle osa. Võiksite ikka teada, mis? Nüüd kohe järgmisena kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Props, siis Selles mõttes.
Õpetaja: Ei, oo,
Õpetaja: jah, Skoop. Kui saab asju olla palju. Noh, kui ma kirjutan siia, kuidas ta saab aru Vaata millal, vaata,
Õpetaja: loogiliselt surud.
Õpetaja: Sest et neid võib olla palju.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd see on täpselt samasugune asi nagu databloks oma olemus, et selles mõttes ma korra teen, ärge Seda tehke, onju? Ee, seda pole vaja Kirjutada. Siia saab luua muutujaid.
Õpetaja: Data Bloki, onju? Me ei saa käe voolan
Õpetaja: ja mingi otse mingi Väärtus ka oli. Nii Datablokis
Õpetaja: Props on nüüd täpi Pealt Samasugune asi, et siia saab sildikesi luua.
Õpetaja: Nii, korra selle ma siit Ee, veel Ära Ei, kustuta vaid Kommenteerin lihtsalt välja, et teda siin ei oleks.
Õpetaja: No mis võiks olla siin? Selle ee, sildikese nimi,
Õpetaja: kus hakkab täitma seda sõnumit siin.
Õpetaja: Meil on lihtsalt sildil vaja nimi välja mõelda.
Õpetaja: Mis võiks panna.
Õpetaja: Te saate aru? Vaata et see, on, see on koht, Kus me nagu defineerime, et siia sisse on? Võimalik, See tuleb üks sildikene ja see koht, kus me seda välja kutsume. Me saame põhimõtteliselt siis anda kaasa mingi sisu. Meil on lihtsalt sildile vaja mingit nime.
Õpetaja: Mis nimi võiks olla? Eesmärgiga? Et see sildikene hakkab siis siin, siin me sellele sildile ja sisule viitama.
Õpetaja: Ja asjad näiteks Message.
Õpetaja: See mõte on see, et sildike alati lihtsalt ka enne, nagu kirjeldab et mis Tüüpi info siin või? Mis info siin sees on? Nagu mitte tüüpi, vaid Mis info oma olemuselt siin on?
Õpetaja: Aga kui me, vaatasime seda et data blokis meil message Kaks korda ei saa. Olla. Ma panen korra. Ma panen korra niimoodi, mis? Isegi ei sobi siia
Õpetaja: siia ei saa panna nüüd seda. Vaata, et ee, et meil on siin. Ee, väike väärtus on tühistriing.
Õpetaja: Miks me ei saa siia panna vaikeväärtusena tühistreening Või üldse mingisugune väärtus.
Õpetaja: Miks me ei saa panna siia Propsi sildi taha mingisugust ise kirjutatud objekti koht? Aga kuna
Õpetaja: pärast saatmine ei ole Sealtpoolt tuli midagi paremat, mis? Hea sellepärast, et see sisu ei olegi. Siin Koodifailis. Ühelgi viisil kirjas. See tuleb kuskilt ülevalt.
Õpetaja: Kosk voolab sisse,
Õpetaja: Aga midagi siia peab panema, Siis siia pannakse. Nüüd on järsku ee, nagu Kaire. Vaata, et me määrame ära siia tüübi. No mis? Tüüpi infot siia saab, tulla,
Õpetaja: kui meil on plaanis seda siia panna. Niiöelda mingi sellisel kujul tekst.
Õpetaja: Kuidas on tekst Ee programmeerimises String nüüd suure tähega String,
Õpetaja: et me ei saa panna sellele messegile mingisugust väärtust, nagu me tahame, saame väike väärtuse panna, juhul kui ülevalt midagi Ei, tule. Aga see on teine teema.
Õpetaja: Aga me saame ära ja peame ära defineerima tüübi.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: saate aru. Data blokis on ainukene koht, kus andmed saavad muutuda. Kas vaikeväärtusega kuskilt Ee, interaktiivse data elemendist kuskilt ee programmiliselt ja script. Iga Vahet pole, Databloki muutuja saab endale, uut sisu saada Nii palju, kui tahab.
Õpetaja: Props ei saa kusagil siin failis endale ühel ega teisel viisil mingit uut sisu.
Õpetaja: Seda Props ei saa näiteks input Boxiga kasutada. Kui mina tulen siia korraks, teen Imp
Õpetaja: Ee tekst. Noh, midagi taolist. Teen ühe input kastikese,
Õpetaja: Kustutan ülejäänud asjad ära, Seda ärge Tehke kaasa.
Õpetaja: Ei ole okei teha niukest asja.
Õpetaja: No, saaks teha ka. Aga siis pead seda koodi väga spetsiifiliselt tegema. Aga.
Õpetaja: Aga ei tohi Põhimõtteliselt sidu. No mis juba joonib alla. Mis sa hädaldad?
Õpetaja: Unexpected Mutation of message Propk Ee programmeerimises on ka Niuksed väljendid, Kaks väljendit. Mute
Õpetaja: on see, et on mingisugune ee sildikene, mille taga objekt võib muutuda, et on disainitud. Nemad
Õpetaja: mingisugused klassid ja objektid on disainitud niimoodi, et et sa saad Tegelikult, ee, sa selle objekti sisu ei saa muuta. Sa saad teha küll uue objekti ja kandid, öelda, et nagu pane sinna külge, Aga tegelikult
Õpetaja: tegelt ei saa. Vaata, et point on see. Vaata, et ta ei tohi muutuda. Siin Te seda äraldate, Ta ütleb et kuule, et
Õpetaja: see vee mudel saab sul muuta selle message I sisu. Aga see on Props
Õpetaja: ropsi sisu tulema Ise seda saab Kuvada, Seda saab kasutada
Õpetaja: kuskil siin jalas kliki sees kasutada, et vaatad mingeid tingimusi, otsustada toimetada midagi, Aga ainukene, asi mida ei tohi teha, on See, et ta ei tohi muutuda.
Õpetaja: Ta tuleb ülevalt alla. See tehnoloogia on niimoodi disainitav.
Õpetaja: Samamoodi, kui ma korraks teen siia hästi kiirelt see on elluvaatmise koht. Ma juba võtan selle input I ära. Vaatame, mis siis juhtub.
Õpetaja: Vanasti seda kusjuures ei olnudki Ee, kui ma teen siia Metsats bloki.
Õpetaja: See on skovi.
Õpetaja: Teen siia mingi meetodi. Lihtsalt ee, do something.
Õpetaja: Ja siin selle something u sees. Ma ütlen this punkt message võrdub. Annan sulle uue sisu.
Õpetaja: Noh, keel läheb paigast ära. Varsti juba vist. Endal läheb keel paigast ära.
Õpetaja: Jälle ta joonis selle alla Mis ma Siis nii halba tegin
Õpetaja: kuvaamiseks.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin on nii lühikeselt on Ära öeldud, kui vähegi saab. Vaata, ee, kõik, mis on vajab selle Propsi kohta teada. Millal
Õpetaja: siis, kui on vaja andmeid Childile anda?
Õpetaja: Ühesuunaline.
Õpetaja: Sa kuidagi tahab. Ta. Ta ei pea tingimata kuvama koodi tasandil või seal mingeid otsustusi olla. Mis iganes, Vaata, et vahet pole, kuidas sa võid teda kasutada ka ainult lugemise eesmärgil
Õpetaja: muutuda. Ta ei tohi sellepärast Sellepärast, et seal tekib kaine nagu ringsõltuvus, võib tekkida.
Õpetaja: Iga kord kui see selle objekti sisu muutub. Siis Ee, programm üritab rendeldada ja joonistada koodi uuesti
Õpetaja: Aga kui ta ongi, et ta ülevalt tuleb sisse all, ta muutub. Siis ta mõtleb, et oota, aga nüüd tuleb uus ring Ja uuesti pean renderdama.
Õpetaja: Ja. Või uued. No näiteks, kui see oleks lihtsalt number üks ja igal igal ringil, näiteks tuleb pluss üks juurde. Vaata, Siis ta jääbki lihtsalt nagu ringiratast kõikuda.
Õpetaja: Aga see ei olegi mõeldud Ta on. Ta on reageeriv. See on. Vaata reakt. Vaata, see Props on mõeldud reageerima. Reageerima ta. Ta ise jälgib seda. Kas see sisu muutub või mitte, aga siin, selles failis lihtsalt nagu siin failis. Ühel või teisel viisil Ta ei tohi muutuda.
Õpetaja: See peab olema sama, okei?
Õpetaja: Kosk voolab ülevalt alla Vastupidi, ta ei tee seda.
Õpetaja: Noh, kustutan Ee, need asjad siit ära. Pole neid vaja.
Õpetaja: Näete nüüd siin Kuidas saab siin seda message it kasutada?
Õpetaja: Nagu Jürt on message
Õpetaja: siis, kui tulla. Lehele on siin. See message on nii?
Õpetaja: Aa, oota, üks asi ka. Vaadake nüüd seda.
Õpetaja: Noh, okei, ee, see see selleks, vaata, okei, Okei, lähme nagu samm tagasi veel. Jah, aga ma tahtsin seda ka näidata. Kui ma selle Alert Danger I siin niimoodi see avan, näed, Siis Ta näitab ka Propsi
Õpetaja: Login Views. Ta näitab data bloki.
Õpetaja: Need on erinevad failid, aga siin on suhe. Siin on kosk, mis läheb alla.
Õpetaja: Davai Ee, Kuna praegu mingit sisu niikuinii ülevalt ei tule, siis läheme korra. Läheme korra ülesse. Lähme siia. Ma Võin niimoodi ka panna? Noh, neid saab tirida. Vaata, ma korra näitan, et neid aknaid saab Tirida
Õpetaja: oli siin. Kõrval. Ma saan tõsta selle siia kõrvale Ma saan Tõsta selle alla.
Õpetaja: Praegu saaks panna niimoodi Login View on parend. Alert Danger on niiöelda alamkomponent eraldi File
Õpetaja: Siia Propsi on võimalik midagi kaasa anda.
Õpetaja: Kuidas seal kohas, kus seda asja üritakse välja kutsuda? Kui meetoditel on ju ka meetodid? Defineerimine. On imeline koodilõik Kuskilt viitab tema nimele, See on väljakutsumine. See on samamoodi. See on visuaalne pool. Ainult kuva mulle see. Komponent seal, siin, selles kohas, siin, selle kolumni sees, enne seda messaget.
Õpetaja: Nii, kui me nüüd tuleme siia tag I sisse siis nüüd. On Tal tekkinud üks uus võimekus
Õpetaja: panna ka kontrol tühik ja panna panna siin tühike panna kontroll tühike.
Õpetaja: Siis ta pakub ee auto complietiga, mida ta näeb. Teisisõnu ma tean, et seal on Props message, Kui ma kirjutan siia m tähe ära,
Õpetaja: siis ta pakub message.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on. Niimoodi, Vaata, et nüüd siin on nagu nimeline viitamine, et siin Selles Propsis. Mul võib olla neid Props E. Nii palju, kui tahan.
Õpetaja: Eri nimega peaksid olema. Nende järjekord on ülikama.
Õpetaja: Vahet pole,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd See väljakutsumise kohal peab olema võimalik aru saada. Vaata, et ma soovin nüüd alla. Ee, lapse niiöelda sinna Propsi sisse mingisugust sisu panna, siis Sa pead valima. Vaata, et põhimõtteliselt. Mis Propsile? No, praegult on mingi triviaalne näide Mingi message. Üks, kaks, kolm
Õpetaja: on ju. Ee, aga päriselus On Siis sellist erinevaid asju, et millele sa tahad mingit väärtust anda?
Õpetaja: Ehk siis see siin, kui ma panen M tähe on alles see osa, et. Hei,
Õpetaja: saada Allerganger Is on properti nimega Message. Ütleme, kui ma. Ma ei tea lapsest mitte midagi.
Õpetaja: Laps on kinni praegu,
Õpetaja: et Ma praegult tean, et ma üritan alla saata, et. Ee, et seal on. Kui ma klikin siia peale klikin korra, satun siia peale, tegi lahti,
Õpetaja: Panen kinni, vajutan Control Kliki ka peale. Näed, on omavahel seotud mõistes vähemalt ja. Noh. Tegelikult, on ka onju
Õpetaja: nüüd siin selle koha juures ma saangi panna siis juurde, Nagu et mida? Ma tahan sinna alla saata. Ma prooviks niimoodi Lihtsalt prooviks. Lihtsalt Ee, tere, tere, Props. Tere, Child.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: kuna praegult seda Child elemendist kuskil ei ole kasutatud veel. Vähemalt mitte nõuete kohaselt. Ma saan vaadata selle tööriistaga.
Õpetaja: Kas on Niimoodi, et. Ee, siin Child. Tere, Child on siin. Ee, kuvatakse. Näed, Views
Õpetaja: Pole midagi hüppaiseri peale praegu. Ta ütleb, et Tere, Child
Õpetaja: kui Ma vaatan seda alert. Angel It. Kas siin on mingi Terechild Propuse juures? Ei ole,
Õpetaja: vaid see voolab siit sellest kohast alla.
Õpetaja: Ma kirjutan seda.
Õpetaja: Aa, tulen. Vaatan seda siit. Siis muutus,
Õpetaja: kui ma siin sedasi mudin. Vaata, lähen login. Viewe
Õpetaja: Ee. Okei, ta praegu ei voola alla Kuskilt muutujast.
Õpetaja: Siin on nagu mitu asja praegu? Vaata, et ta alla jõuab.
Õpetaja: See. Tere, Child. Aa Jõuab. Sinna alla või? Tere, Child,
Õpetaja: aga Praegu sellega ei tehta mitte midagi.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et see siin ei viita Propsile message, vaid see on lihtsalt siin Text. Message
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina küsin, Kus me oleme praegu? Siin, Tag ides. Kas Me oleme tagide vahel või tag I sees
Õpetaja: vahel?
Õpetaja: Nüüd, et anda nagu märku. Vaata, Voele, Vaata, et mina ei taha Stringi message kirjutada Siia vaid mina tahan viidata sellele Propsile Message, täpselt nagu tatablokigagi, käitub samamoodi. Ma tahan sildikesele viidata, siis kellegil on meeles, kuidas ma saan sellele sildikesele viidata
Õpetaja: Tagide vahel ja topelt loogilised sulud.
Õpetaja: Teete neid kaks tükki, kui panna, ta pakub midagi, kui panna M. Täht ja ta pakub midagi,
Õpetaja: et see ongi teie vihje. Vaata, et kui te lihtsalt hakkate kuskile kirjutama, viitama mingile sildile.
Õpetaja: Ja nagu ei pakub,
Õpetaja: siis on see, et. Oot, oot, oot, ta ei saa aru. Ta Mõtleb, et sa kirjutad ringi praegu, Siis annab talle mõista, et. Oot, oot, ei, ei, mina mõtlen ikka.
Õpetaja: Mul läks see keel jälle kõigest ära näpisin Nuppe, onju? Mina mõtlen Ikkagi, et ole hea.
Õpetaja: Anna mulle mingisugune sildikene siia. Ma ei taha seda teksti message kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma paneksin siia lihtsalt ee, sümbolid juurde,
Õpetaja: Ta Siis ka ei muutuks. Ära vaata, ta saab aru. Ma võin kirjutada teksti siia ette, näiteks.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma kirjutan siiani. Hei, hei, ei, Hei, tühik.
Õpetaja: Midagi teeb siis mida iganes ja siis tuleb niimoodi. Hei, hei, tere, Child. See osa tuli mul sealt tekstina.
Õpetaja: See osa tuli Message props ist.
Õpetaja: On arusaadav.
Õpetaja: Väga hea, Okei, no nüüd me näeme. Vaata, et Terechild voolab kenasti siit ee sellest barendist siia. Propsi
Õpetaja: Tere, Child on nii?
Õpetaja: No nüüd, nüüd tuleb veel viimane asi, mida nagu on vaja meeles hoida nende, just nagu nende sildi viitamistega,
Õpetaja: Muidu meil On Ju tag I Sees ei pea midagi lisama.
Õpetaja: Kui on tag ide. Vahel pead lisama. Topelt. Ee, loogilised sulud. Kui on skripti sees, Siis pead ütlema. Noh, siiamaani nagu kolm asja meile sõidab. Aga nüüd on üks probleem veel.
Õpetaja: Minul on siin. Tere, Child, Onju kirjas ei
Õpetaja: ei pea olema user näinud. Miks, mis mul sinna
Õpetaja: paneme, User. No kui isegi kui ma panen username, Meil on olemas Username, meil pole, Mis meil on meil olemas? Lihtsalt username. Ei, pole. Vaata, mina panen kõik kinni.
Õpetaja: Request. Vaata, on ju. Oletame, et ma tahaks seda Username sinna. Vaata, mis on nagu täiesti vale siin kontekstis. Aga lihtsalt printsiibis,
Õpetaja: Mis ma siia peaksin kirjutama?
Õpetaja: Login midagi ei paku.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlesin teile. Vaata, et kui oled.
Õpetaja: Kui oled Aa tagide sees tag I sees, siis võid lihtsalt kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Noh, üritad lihtsalt kirjutada, aga see oli see, Kui oli mingi voe funktsionaalsus V If või mudel
Õpetaja: siin täiesti Okei, Ongi see, et ma saaksin kirjutada. Tere,
Õpetaja: tere, tere, see on minu Vaba Valim Ma võin saada siia lihtsalt tekst sisse kirjutada, mingi väärtuse ja see voolab sinna alla.
Õpetaja: Aga võibolla ma tahan seda ka saada Hoopis kuskilt muutujast.
Õpetaja: Kuidas tema siis teab? Vaata, Point on see, et Kus on meil praegu see sõnum, mida me tahame Alerti saata?
Õpetaja: No, Ta istub ju meil selle Selle sildi sees, on nii?
Õpetaja: Noh, et siis siia me tahame kirjutada message,
Õpetaja: aga vaata kurjamit. Tema mõtleb, et Ma tahan teksti saata.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on jälle vaja Voele märku anda,
Õpetaja: et siin kontekstis. Me tahame, ee, sinna alla. Message ile niiöelda kaasa anda Mingisugust.
Õpetaja: Ee, seda niiöelda muutujat.
Õpetaja: Aga tema ennem seda ei tea. Kui me teda aitame.
Õpetaja: Ja siin olukorras on selline sümbol, nagu koolon.
Õpetaja: Poolon annab märku. Vaata, et. Hei,
Õpetaja: see sisend, mis nüüd tuleb, ei ole enam tekst, vaid see on mingi sildike.
Õpetaja: I know its sucks,
Õpetaja: nagu Mingi lihtsalt, ee. Selle sildikese nimi. Ee, siis on topelt loogiliste sulgude vahel. Siis kuskil tuleb koolon panna. Kuskil tuleb disk panna.
Õpetaja: Jah, on on keeruline. Vaata, onju Veits läheb aega,
Õpetaja: Aga iga Jumala kord. Vähemalt te peaksite saama aru, et midagi on valesti. Sellisel juhul, kui te Näiteks
Õpetaja: kirjutate mingisuguste asjade. Midagi ei paku eriti. Kui see on roheline tekst,
Õpetaja: siis tavaliselt see tähendab siit ringi. Vaadake, kus vahel ma olen Siin ka majandusringide vahel, on ju?
Õpetaja: Kui te kirjutate mingit teksti ja ta on roheline sinna, siis see viitab sellele, et see on lihtsalt tekst.
Õpetaja: Kui sina mõtled midagi muud siis on see koht, kus tuletavad meelde, et ma pean kooloni ette panema. Ma ei taha sulle teksti sinna alla anda. Ma tahan anda selle mis on messegis,
Õpetaja: kui praegu. Message I Algseis. Kui ta nüüd ära refresh Ib on tühjus, on Nii kaste näitab? Sisu pole,
Õpetaja: kui ma proovin nüüd siin mingi.
Õpetaja: Vaata mul juba. Aa, mul on. Tundub, et mul on kasutaja nimel ka Mingi sisendaja refresh iga sisse pandud, et kui ma lähen oma datablokki,
Õpetaja: Aga peaks ikka Refresh I. Tegema. Vaatama, kus sa selle sisu saad?
Õpetaja: Ah, muidugi, ma panin ise peitu selle. Ma tegin mingi. Aa, et, ee, kui mina tulen. Ee,
Õpetaja: panen siia. Ainult nüüd juhtub nii, et Kui ma login käivitub, siis message saab uue sisu. On ju nii? Ifi pärast. Vaata, üks nendest on tühi,
Õpetaja: saab Wifi ga uue sisu Ja see voolab alla Voolas.
Õpetaja: See, see. Ee, punane. On Meil selles selles. Vaata
Õpetaja: selle Me nüüd. Peame ära kustutama. Aga me veel ei Kustuta, sest ma tahan näidata. Me tegime praegu kõike siin väga pikalt.
Õpetaja: Teeme lühemalt
Õpetaja: Nii, Me oleme nagu poolel teel, aga nüüd on jälle see asi. Vaata, et. Ee, seda. Ee, seda niiöelda. Tv I
Õpetaja: näidatakse kogu aeg, kui ma teen Refresh Id on tühi, Mis meil siin tuleb teha
Õpetaja: korra. Teeme ühe asja Kommenteerime korra välja selle alumise koodise sellest. Ee,
Õpetaja: see koht siin. No me juba näeme. Vaata, et kui Message ei ole tühi. Siis kuva on ju korra. Kommenteerime selle välja, et jääks ainult see roheline.
Õpetaja: Ta lihtsalt segab. Vaata, muidu me tahame teha, et see on reaktiivne komponent.
Õpetaja: Kui messengi annad, siis teda näidatakse kogu selle loogika. Vot see on ka mõnus. Me ei pea tegema V If I nagu sadasse kohta, kus me tahame näha vaid selle kuvamine on meil selles mõttes tehtud niimoodi kavalalt, et kui
Õpetaja: tuleme, siia, Ütleme kui V If.
Õpetaja: Kui message ei ole tühi, siis seda tiibi näidatakse.
Õpetaja: Ee, võibolla isegi on see sama V If koos oma sulgeda Ja karvadega veel parem panna selle samasse Timmi.
Õpetaja: Muidugi, Kui seda Tv I ei näidata, siis templeid. Ee renderdub niimoodi, et polegi ühtegi vahel Okei, las ta siis jääb siia. Kus ta on praegu, et savitõnaga
Õpetaja: nüüd siin on? See on sukses, aga me tahame, et ta ei Oleks roheline vaid
Õpetaja: punane. Siis selle disaini. Paneme lihtsalt ära.
Õpetaja: Nüüd oma task. I mõttes. Oleme siis põhimõtteliselt saavutanud selle, et meil on, on Meil komponent,
Õpetaja: mis võtab sisse propsina. Message.
Õpetaja: Kui seal on sisu, siis näidatakse seda komponenti. Kui ei ole, siis mitte
Õpetaja: kui mugav. On nüüd Igal pool mujal edaspidi tulevikus seda taaskasutada.
Õpetaja: Ee, läheme kuskile kohta, kuhu iganes, kuhu iganes. Kuskil on vaja mingit alert, Danger, It kirjutad
Õpetaja: A, D ja nool alla tab. Paned selle kinni, tuled, ütled, et. Ee. Mul on mingisugune message. Saad selle sisust message ja ongi kõik. Kujutage ette. Praegu ei pea uuesti progema. Nagu. Mis on see visuaal?
Õpetaja: Kuidas ta käitub? Mida ta? Teeb?
Õpetaja: See on nagu nii triviaalne näide, Ta on kõigest üks mingi niukene. Ee, üsna nagu, ee, väikse sisendiga komponent. Aga kujutame ette, et meil on hoopis mingi. Ee. Näiteks Card olete ikka näinud. Näiteks ostate mingeid tooteid.
Õpetaja: Aa, valite Aa, mingi kategooria. Ja siis tuleb ette. Näiteks Vaata terve leht. Nagu mingisuguseid asju, Mingit ee asja, mida sa saad osta. Seal juures on näiteks pilt.
Õpetaja: Võibolla seal. Mingi väike nimi ja hind juures. Võibolla mingi märk, mis näitab saadavust Või ikoon või mida iganes, Seda kutsutakse kaardiks. Vaata, see sama kaart on nagu mitmeid kordi, onju?
Õpetaja: Noh, kui sul näiteks ongi mingi niukene asi kuskil nagu komponendi olemas. See tähendab seda Vaata, võibolla on päris mitmeid kohti, kus tegelikult kuskil veebilehel Näed? Tegelikult seda disainielemendina seda sama asja uuesti.
Õpetaja: No siis ongi see, et sul on Lihtsalt, et viska andmed sisse,
Õpetaja: Viska lihtsalt andmed sisse ja tema kuvab täpselt seda sama asja.
Õpetaja: Siis Ee, vastavate andmetega. Paned sinna pildi ka. Sa paned sinna mingi hinna ka. Sa paned sinna mingi. Ma ei tea, toote nime kaasa toote koodi või mis Iganes.
Õpetaja: Ee, likvidatsioon.
Õpetaja: Aga vaata. No mõtleme. Näed, sinu praktika oli, et paneks selle lihtsalt siia neif
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, Töö mõte oli see.
Õpetaja: Aga kas nüüd vastab tõele? Vaata, et nüüd iga Jumala kord,
Õpetaja: kui sina soovid seda komponenti kasutada. Nüüd sa alustad nullist. Vaata,
Õpetaja: kui lähenemine on selline, siis sa teed niimoodi iga kord uuesti seda. Alert Danger.
Õpetaja: Ee, Mm, message.
Õpetaja: Võrdub, message. Noh, ja nüüd Iga kord sa pead tegema seda asja. Uuesti.
Õpetaja: V. If.
Õpetaja: Sa teed seda sama Kontrolli sa kirjutad igakord. Sa kirjutad koodi juurde, kui on See lahendus, mis mul on mitu korda vee If I tuleb.
Õpetaja: Ja sellest ma saan aru, et mul oli pigem nagu, see, et kuidas neil on mõtet selle alamkomponenti alamkomponendi mõte lihtsalt olla ka,
Õpetaja: ma arvan.
Õpetaja: Ja tahan koodi ülejäänud.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: mõlemat. Pidi See on nagu natuke niuke Arhitektuuriline otsus. Vaata, et kuidas me nagu teeme. Nagu seda asja. Noh, tähtis oleks siis loomulikult seda teha nagu ühte samapidi. Vaata, onju
Õpetaja: Jah, Siin võiks leida poolte vastuargumente.
Õpetaja: Üks eeldab ühe. Ühes on abstraktsioon.
Õpetaja: Vaata, see on nagu see. Vaata, üks on üks. On rohkem võetav kohe Selles kohas, kus välja kutsud ee, teine ja eeldab seda, et sa pead siis võibolla potentsiaalselt rohkem nagu kirjutama ja rohkem on koodi, onju
Õpetaja: Teise Niiöelda, noh pluss ja miinused. Vaata, siin ei pruugi tingimata olla, et kui sina tahaks näiteks mingit oma projekti teha, niimoodi, vaata siis Keelaks, kui keegi seda. Ja näiteks samamoodi kui tiim, nagu võtab, et tahame. Ma nagu näitan kohti. Vaata veel, kus tegelikult, ee, idee saaks teha. Vaata niukest attraktsiooni, mida ei ole mõistlik teha see. Tuleb hiljem kui, meil. On natuke rohkem layout i
Õpetaja: ee Et, nad on valikute kohad. Mina olen samamoodi teinud. Ma tegin näiteks ühe grupiga. Tegin niimoodi, kus tegime natukene. Võibolla liiga palju abstraktsiooni, et igasugused ka komponentidesse kaasa et meil on mingi leiab.
Õpetaja: Ja ma ei tahtnud seda, et mul on mingi pealehel väga, palju nagu Layout I nagu neid filme Vaata, Noh, komponendi eraldi ja nad on seal sees.
Õpetaja: Aga see on väga halb lahenemine sellepärast, et siis tekib transportsioon on see, et sa pead nüüd oma mõtkuna. Kõik asjad on erinevates failides. Sa pead oma peas selle pildiga aina kokku panema. Vaata, et kuidas, on. See on väga Habras ka. Vaata, et kui asjad on nagu nii nagu tugevalt seotud, siis võib juhtuda seda, et mingid asjad on kainad teatud kontekstis kaitud,
Õpetaja: et ühest kohast kasutad ühtepidi Teis teistpidi. Vaata ja nad enam Ei, Matchi, vaata,
Õpetaja: et ee. On kohad, kus saab nagu üsna tugevalt argumenteerida, Vaata, et mis peaks olema siis selles peamises. Niiöelda, ee, faili Nii öelda.
Õpetaja: Ee. Ja mis peaks olema nagu Child Is
Õpetaja: ja siis ongi, Ma ütlen ka, et ee. See on nagu valikute küsimus. Ma ei viitsi enam nende iffide ja asjadega kunagi tegeleda siis ta on seal selles komponendis sees.
Õpetaja: Ja ma joon selle teadmise. Kes see nii on?
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, nüüd see. Ma võin korra ära kommit ida, kui keegi tahab järgi tulla.
Õpetaja: Selle alumise võib tegelikult nüüd ära kustutada. Sellepärast, et meil on toimiv. Asi, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ma teen Comiti ära, aga ma Teen selle. Ee, oota. Ma vaatan, kas siin veel midagi on. Mis võiks olla? Ma ei tea, käib ka. Täida kõik väljad, Teen Refresh I
Õpetaja: Ee, Proovin korra ruttu üle. Mõlemad väljad ja Fresh, üks Vali Refresh, teine väli.
Õpetaja: Refresh Ja kõik on täidetud.
Õpetaja: Ei tule midagi, hetkel Onju, Mis on okei? Ma ei ole jõudnud seda funktsionaalsust veel teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, koodi mõttes Ma võibolla ka korra lihtsalt klõbistan oma, et mõlemas I love optimising. Ma teen nüüd Comiti, Kes tahab, võib selles mõttes järgi tulla.
Õpetaja: Aga mina siis samal ajal hakkan nagu näitama ja demonstreerima Seda, et see. See ei ole kaastamise koht. Sellel ei ole seda väärtust praegult,
Õpetaja: et. Ee, kuidas oleks saanud veel teha ja kuidas tulevikus tahakski teha Tegelikult tulevikus. Ee, teeks natukene teistpidi.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult siin. Need divid on ka nagu, Okei, see on see, et kui seda ei näita, Sest ta jääb tühi templeid, mis natukene nagu rikub reegleid.
Õpetaja: Ee, sellega nii. Ja, naa.
Õpetaja: See oleks asi, mida saaks arutada, Push ja tegemata Aa, ta push Ib veel või? Mine mine
Õpetaja: no muutusi. Ma saan juba teha. Lihtsalt tahaks teile öelda, kes tahab üldse järgi tulla, Davai. Nüüd saab.
Õpetaja: Ma. Nüüd hakkan natukene kustutama. Mis ma teen, on see, et ma võtan selle sama Dv, mis on siin.
Õpetaja: Võtan ja ma Tulen sellesse, login View Sse ja asendan selle allergi väljakutsega,
Õpetaja: et oleks nii nagu ta alguses oli niimoodi
Õpetaja: ja ma tulen, kustutan ära, Ee, siis ka siit ülevalt, et komponente meil ei olegi ühtegi kasutatud. Ja importi pole See on põhimõtteliselt algseis, on. Nii Kujutame ette, et Ma Kirjutasin siin mingisuguse disaini juba välja.
Õpetaja: Okei, On kasutada muutujaid, kui tahad nende sees, aga mitte kunagi. Ee ät, Click ja mingisuguste meetodite väljakutsumisi,
Õpetaja: Siis oled juba liiga kaugele läinud. Me jõuame selleni. Ma räägin mingi hetk. Põhimõtteliselt te võite täielikult disaini valmis teha ja siis mõelda, et Okei, ma teen selle erinevateks komponentideks. Sa võid isegi siduda siin mingisugused data bloki muutujad
Õpetaja: juba ette. Ära.
Õpetaja: Ma saaksin selle sama lahenduseni, et Siin O, et sellest tahaks teha eraldi komponent ja Alert Angel, ma kustutan selle ära. Näed, põmm. Mine sina ka.
Õpetaja: Kõik tsau
Õpetaja: Mingit viga, Midagi ei tulnud ta ei. Hoiatan sealt mingit referentsi. Sellele Viitele enam ei ole. Ma kustutasin kõik read ära. Algseis on selline, et me Tegime mingisuguse visuaali valmis. Ta töötab loomulikult, onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd mina tahan siis teha. Eraldi komponenti on see, et nüüd peab hästi ettevaatlikult valima, mida Sa selekteerid. Ee, sa ei saa teha. Näiteks, ma ei tea, niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Sa ei saa teha. Näiteks Ee, niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Vaid see peab olema ikka Mingi divisdivi. Nüüd ütleme siis ja ütlen. Ee, parem klõps.
Õpetaja: Refactor ja Extract View komponent. Sama asi nagu me ennem tegime. Meetodi,
Õpetaja: võta olemasolev Koodi. Lõik ja tee, sest eraldi meetod. Ja vaadake Lisa siia asemele välja, et üldse
Õpetaja: kui me teeme lihtsalt selle ee, visuaalse html i osaga. Teeme sama asja, et hei, kujutage ette, siin võib ka kümme rida teksti olla nagu siin. Võib olla palju palju nii öelda html I Millest sa tahad teha? Eraldi klotsi? Näiteks mingi tabel.
Õpetaja: Tabeli html on ju päris pikk. Vaata, bla, bla, bla, onju? Tahad sa siis eraldi seda teha. Selekteerid vastavad asjad, onju?
Õpetaja: Ja panen ainukene asi, mis ma natukene pean mõtlema. Vaata on see, et see asi läheb nüüd seal uues komponendis templeid. Ee, niiöelda nende tagide vahele
Õpetaja: Template tag. Iga oli tegelikult meil üks Nõue oli,
Õpetaja: Mis nõue oli template tag iga. Tal peaks olema ainult üks child,
Õpetaja: et kui sa võtad nagu mingid read, vaata nagu, ee. Noh, mis ma sealt kiirelt võtaks?
Õpetaja: No see Button. Näiteks
Õpetaja: kui ma võtaks praegult need read ja ekstraktiks nad niiöelda uueks komponendiks, siis see selekteeritud osa läheb siia uuest komponendis template vahele. Mitu oleks siis seal?
Õpetaja: Noh, liiga palju on ju
Õpetaja: et natukene tasub mõelda, ette See oli mu mõte. Vaata, kui hakkad midagi tegema, et Mõtled ka, et kui ta läheb uude kohta, et kuidas ta siis seal jääks? Davai, ma võtan selle osa. Panen parem klõps, panen. Ma Teen korra kommit. I ka.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma tegin komitee. Ei teinud komitee.
Õpetaja: Okei, tegin küll need muudatusi, et saab roll Back Ida on ju,
Õpetaja: Ja, ja, okei, vot ma korra teen roll back in. Kõik need,
Õpetaja: mis maalg sees on.
Õpetaja: Jah, on, ei teinud, Ai on. Ikka siia, Tahan tagasi tulla. Ah, Kui loll Control set. Äkki Aitab.
Õpetaja: Okei, tagasi. Aga midagi oli veel kustutatud Oli fail. See on ju Nii
Õpetaja: Mina Tahtsin näidata, et kui ma võtan lihtsalt selle osa, kui mugavalt ja odavalt saab seda komponent ise teha, et kõik propsid asjad teeb sellepärast et nüüd ei arvesta. Vaata sellega, et kui see läheb kuhugi teise faili, mis siis peab toimuma? Ta on uus komponent, ah? Okei, uus Komponent
Õpetaja: annab mulle võimaluse valida nime. Aa, kuna seda siin kutsutakse välja, tuleb lisada alla. Siia, Mida siia ülesse import.
Õpetaja: Siia tuleb import lisada. Ja siia tuleb lisada komponents bloki sisse, et me kasutame seda siin. Tehniliselt Ainult niimoodi saab seda kasutada. Ta Teeb nüüd kõik selle minu Eest ise. Ära.
Õpetaja: Parem klõps.
Õpetaja: Ee, Extract New Component.
Õpetaja: Refaktor Struct New Component Seisan siin peal ja paku mulle nime. Juba näeme. Kool on Message message
Õpetaja: alla tuleb, Noh, et kui me siin kasutame muud message siis ta eeldab seda, et ma teen sinna Propsi ka message nagu Ta ei oska mingit muud nime välja mõelda.
Õpetaja: Siin on message olemas. Kui seda tahad kaasa anda, tuleb koolon panna ja viidata sellele seisan Siin peal kirjutan Alert
Õpetaja: Danger.
Õpetaja: Näete, lentrit?
Õpetaja: Tuli. Uus komponent.
Õpetaja: Tuli templite sisse. See V If.
Õpetaja: No Natuke lühemad Meil oli seal Vaata need Divid ümber ka veel, onju?
Õpetaja: Mis ta oli?
Õpetaja: Ma nagu veits peaks seda konsulteerima, et kas seal on mõistlik neid hoida või tegelikult Pole vahet ja ei ole mõtet hoida Neid ma mäletate üldine printsiip. Kui ei ole vaja,
Õpetaja: siis ei ole, vaja on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Ja kui Me lähme nüüd siia alla ja vaatame, mis nagu toimub, onju?
Õpetaja: Kui ma tulen siia alla, siis ee. Vabandust, Alla ülesse. On see suund Sassis Import on tulnud.
Õpetaja: Komponents tuli väga. Lihtsalt saab tegelikult neid komponente teha.
Õpetaja: No mina. Las ta siis olla nii nagu oli,
Õpetaja: aga loomulikult Ma tahtsin seda praegu käsitsi ja niimoodi sammude kaupa läbi teha. Et teil on teadmine.
Õpetaja: Ee, et kuidas nad umbes siis niiöelda omavahel töötavad Need asjad on kaks faili.
Õpetaja: Nii, Davai, vaatame edasi. Ee, lähme siis. Ee järgmise taaski osa juurde.
Õpetaja: Ee, voogi sisse vajutamisel kontrollitakse Kõik väljad on täidetud loo selle jaoks eraldi komponent. Aa, üks asi, mida me ammu tahtsime teha. No see on nüüd. Võibolla korra vaatame kõigepealt
Õpetaja: Mäletate Seda, et mis siis, kui ma tahan refaktureerida seda Message It,
Õpetaja: Sest et nüüd on ju ka tegelikult siis see sama
Õpetaja: niiöelda, kus on Täpi pealt samasugune muutaja, on ju nii? Propsi kujul.
Õpetaja: Kui mina tulen praegu siia peale, panen Shift F kuus
Õpetaja: ja jätan Skopi Project Files Ja ütlen, et selle asja nimi on hoopis mitte message, vaid error message.
Õpetaja: Siis vaatame kuidas ta, nüüd siis seda teeb. Praegu on. Hea teha, kui Mitt on just tehtud. Kui Ee teeb mingeid muudatused, saan ülikiirelt vaadata.
Õpetaja: Võibolla siit saab ka vaadata, juba kus ta siis tegema hakkab.
Õpetaja: Ta näeb seda ka. Ta vist ta teeb selle. Ainult No vaatame, kus teeb refaktor.
Õpetaja: No siin. Ta tegi igal pool ära Selles Ma üldse ei kahtle mujale ta ei vaadanud. Tundub, et on tegelikult natukene paremaks läinud aja jooksul.
Õpetaja: Ma võin. Ee, Ma sööksin oma mütsi ära, kui ta ei oleks teinud seda. Vanasti tegi alati nii, et
Õpetaja: ei pea muretsema. Sellepärast
Õpetaja: vanasti ta seda tegi. Ee, peaks olema endised Message.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd see on natukene. See on nüüd nagu maitse asi. Vaata, et kas ta võiks ka tegelikult võikski siin olla error Message
Õpetaja: vabalt.
Õpetaja: Ee, et selles mõttes nagu. Ja ma. Isegi Ma ütleks, et ka, siin võiks tegelikult, teha, et las ta siis olla
Õpetaja: tuleme siia.
Õpetaja: Mis nuppu aitate siin peal, Keyboard. Teil refaktureerida mingit nime
Õpetaja: Shift F. Kuus. Selle õppige selgeks sellepärast, et see saab olema nii tavapärane Kogu aeg oodate ainult
Õpetaja: muutis mõlemad ära. Või?
Õpetaja: Ahaa, okei, aga tegelikult see ei olnud soovitav käitumine selles mõttes, et
Õpetaja: siis siis tegelikult ikkagi Tasub alati minna sellest. Coob Ist valida. Aa,
Õpetaja: see ei ole soovitav käitumine. See on nii ohtlik.
Õpetaja: Et Noh, siis ta ongi lihtlabaselt üle Projekti Vaata, muutis. Ära vaata, onju? Ee, siis seal on isegi vaata Ja teha. See sama liigutus uuesti. Vaata, onju? Varem või hiljem tulete Niikuinii
Õpetaja: tulete mulle, järgi kui te tulete. Ee, siin. Ma muudan ka ikkagi. Ära vaata mulle. Isegi tundub, et on mõnusam, et siis on See Muutuja ka. Siin. Vaata, Aa, ja üks asi, mida ma nüüd tahtsin. Ee, teile näidata.
Õpetaja: Ee, vaadake, siin on, teadlikult üks ee, konkreetne valik.
Õpetaja: See siin, on Props. Ja siin on Camel Case, nii nagu alati.
Õpetaja: Aa, lähme nüüd. Vaatame. Kuidas See asi nüüd jäi. Vaata, kas Ta jäi päris selliselt või mitte,
Õpetaja: Kui me lähen nüüd sinna kohta, kus seda kutsutakse välja ja viidatakse sellele Propsile, kas seal on endiselt Või seal on kebab. Case, Ma ei tea, kuidas teeb.
Õpetaja: Ta tegi niimoodi, et siin on ka. Ee, nagu Camel Case but its not Correct.
Õpetaja: See töötab tehniliselt.
Õpetaja: Näed. Vajutan siia peale. Kukun siia peale.
Õpetaja: Mina olen. Ma panen jälle Childis I alla. Mina olen parentes. Mina viitan siin kohas. Vaata, kus seda välja kutsutakse. Viidatakse Propsile error message. Kui ma klikin siia peale kukun siia. On Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd see siin korraga Võib ära lihtsalt kustutada
Õpetaja: see ei ole hea lahendus. Kui me paneme kooloni ja vaatame, mida intellige meile pakub. Millist varianti ta praegu pakub meile. Ee, nendest. Case idest.
Õpetaja: Vaata, see on see Sama mõte. On see, et väga suur tõenäosus on, et kui me räägime mingisugusest infost, Me räägime siltidest. Kuidas me kutsume siin mingit infot, ja kuidas? Me kutsume mingit infot? On Täpselt samasugused. Sama muutuja nimega
Õpetaja: Nüüd mõte on See, et kuidas sa visuaalselt väga kiirelt aru panna. Tab ja võrdusmärk ja error message.
Õpetaja: No värvid. Esiteks mängivad siin ka rolli. Vaata, onju, et üks on valge, Teine on lilla. Lilla Viitab Tatarblokile, On ju?
Õpetaja: Aga näete, nad on meelega teinud niimoodi, et kui sa kutsud välja Mingid komponentid. Mis Sest et seal komponent is on ma klikin selle sama peale, kuhu ma kukun Siia alla. On ju
Õpetaja: Kuhu ma kukun siia alla,
Õpetaja: et see on lihtsalt mõeldud seda, et see tõmbab silme eest kirjuks. Kui sul on nagu et sa justkui muidu vaataksid, et Ma annan iseendale uue väärtuse, et ühele, et sa viitad sellele samale sildile kaks korda. Sa oled teinud sellise lahenduse, et, ee, et sa Saad kasutada siin väljakutsumisel
Õpetaja: selle Propsi nime Niiöelda viitamise teha See on eelistatud variant,
Õpetaja: sest et nüüd on sul niimoodi error message mis on sul sidekriipsudega eraldatud ja error message, mis on Caval Case is Sest need on kaks erinevat silti. Üks viitab Child i sildile, teine viitab Selle ee, parenti sildile
Õpetaja: kumb Lilla Kas lill on lilla? On silt või sild
Õpetaja: selles sõltuvus suhtes, mis mul praegu on?
Õpetaja: Noh, kes veel Parent on nendest kahest.
Õpetaja: Kuidas kumb nendest klass? Kumb nendest failidest on pärand?
Õpetaja: Siin selles kontekstis.
Õpetaja: Login, Login ju kutsub Välja Alerthanger Id mitte Vastupidi, vaata, kui sa tuled. Vaatad Alert Angelist. Kas siin on ühtegi viidet kuskil loginile? Noh, paned selle kinni niimoodi
Õpetaja: Palun öelge mulle, kus Ta viitab siin kellelegi. See on see orglaps Ju
Õpetaja: Me ei tea, kes tema pärand on. Tema barent võib olla, kes iganes
Õpetaja: tema pärand on Antud juhul See Login View.
Õpetaja: Kui ma küsiksin praegult siin. Vaata, et kumb on nagu kumma sildikene
Õpetaja: lilla nagu millele lilla viitab, kas Ta viitab sellele siin või ta viitab sellele. Siin
Õpetaja: Lilla viitab ikka siin selle data blokile ja see viitab Child I Props i Bloki Vä.
Õpetaja: Hea küll, saame seda asja veel Ee, piisavalt teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, see asi nüüd. Selles mõttes on korras.
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: kui kõik vajalikud väljad on täidetud, Siis saadetakse Back endile. Http, sõnum, Post Abos Request Bodiga. Username String Password String Näidissõnumist on meil siin
Õpetaja: Okei, läheb põnevaks
Õpetaja: okei
Õpetaja: alustame Siis ee. Tähtsatest asjadest.
Õpetaja: Noh, tegelikult küsime. Ee, küsimus.
Õpetaja: Materjal.
Õpetaja: Parem skill. Loovusõppematerjal Ee teematerjal teemal.
Õpetaja: Et mis asi tee interaktiivne. Materjal
Õpetaja: ee ma Panen Md ja Html.
Õpetaja: Te natukene interaktiivne seisukohal, et tee võiks see skill I ümber teha. Juba ma hakkan Mõtlema. Vaikselt.
Õpetaja: Ee Dmd ja Html Interaktiivne mm.
Õpetaja: Muidugi, sel sõnajärjekorral. Tema jaoks on vaja interaktiivne
Õpetaja: materjal. Kas keegi neid asju ka proovib? Järgi või või veel ei Proovi, Ei, proovi teemal.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis asi asi on, Html?
Õpetaja: Sõnum tähendab, mis saate meil Http?
Õpetaja: Ee, Ee, Noh, Davai
Õpetaja: meile. Ee. Hästi, Palj. Hästi, Korraks ma ühe teema Ikkagi võtan siit ise Googlest. Vana vanakooli värk. On Htt
Õpetaja: Staatus.
Õpetaja: Coach, Kui me saadame Aa mingisuguse sõnumi
Õpetaja: sõnumi, see on protokoll, see on. Ütleme siis konkreetne. Tehnoloogiline protokoll. Kuidas Ee, niiöelda süsteemid omavahel suhtlevad?
Õpetaja: Kokku lepitud keel võib olla lihtsalt, öelda
Õpetaja: ee, htp Ee, sõnumid. Kui nad vastavad, siis nad alati annavad ka status koodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis teine süsteem talle vastab?
Õpetaja: Ja need ei ole nagu mingi Metsikult palju. Aga need on need slotid. On olemas et mingid on täidetud. Mitte kõik. Vist on sajast kuni saja. Üheksakümne üheksani on niuksed Informatiivsed.
Õpetaja: Kõik, mis alg. No mõtleme Kõik, mis algavad. Sajaga niimoodi on lihtsam rääkida. Kõik, mis algavad sajaga. On mingisugused informatiivsed responsid, kõik mis on kahesajaga. See peamine asi on Sõnumid, mis tähistavad seda, et kõik läks hästi.
Õpetaja: Ee, mingid ümbersuunamised on kolmesajaga. Neid väga ei näe vahel Harva nüüd, nelisaja. Nüüd on see, et kliendipoolsed vead.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis kui sul on siin
Õpetaja: ee, niiöelda rakke rakendus. Rakenduse poolsed nagu
Õpetaja: rakendaduse poolsed Aa, niiöelda Programmeeritud vead ka, onju niiöelda Võibolla nagu teile, nagu öelda.
Õpetaja: Ja kui mingi asjad on ülimalt uks, siis on, ee juba kui Juba see kukub maha. Siis juba tulevad mingid viiesajaga algavad asjad.
Õpetaja: Ee error. Viissada kindlasti Olete näinud. Error Nelisada neli,
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes server ei ole maas, vaid lihtsalt seda, mida sina küsisid. Mul pole anda nagu midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui nüüd niimoodi klikkida ka siis on need Erinevad. See kakssada on kõige geneeri geneerilisem. Lihtsalt, et kõik läks hästi.
Õpetaja: Räägitakse ka, et kett sõnumil, sõnumil
Õpetaja: ja ja kõik läks hästi. Kõik Läks hästi, aga mingi konkreetse tegevusega. Kui me lisame mingeid asju, siis ta ütleb lisatud,
Õpetaja: kui me üritame kuskile. Ee,
Õpetaja: jah, et see on Nagu mingi niuke vastus, mis on kättesaadav, toimetatakse Midagi on accepted. Meie lähevad kõik kahesajaga. Kui on. Hästi Me ei hakka neid varieeruvusi tegema Ja neljasajaga on juba mingisugused konkreetsemad asjad, mida me ikkagi nagu tahame. Nagu kasutada
Õpetaja: Nüüd need koodid on eelnevalt defineeritud, neid ei saa juurde teha ei Saa teha. Viis või viis. Näiteks nagu mõelda välja.
Õpetaja: Kuigi viis või viis saaks olla, kuna viiesajaga on olemas. Aga neid ei saa ise teha. Need on selle standardi Htp standardi poolt. Nagu kirja pandud mingid. Suured vennad. Mõtlesid välja, mis on
Õpetaja: ee neljasajaga on, mõned Mida me kasutame?
Õpetaja: Aa, nelisada. Kolm for Bidden, nelisada neli. Aa, not found
Õpetaja: on notarest võiks olla ka. Kui oleks see päris logimine näiteks
Õpetaja: Ja siin on siis see põhimõtteliselt töötab niimoodi, et kui sa disainid mingit teenust, vaata, siis sa saad ka enne nende seast valida, mis Kõige lähemalt sobib.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on loomulikult ka Niukene kood. Nagu nelisada kaheksateist.
Õpetaja: Jah, server keeldub Ee kohvi keetmast ee teepotiga.
Õpetaja: Ma olen väga Saate uurida, miks Niukene on nagu niukses protokollis üle maailma olemas.
Õpetaja: Ee, midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Ee, Vaatame, mis ta nüüd tegi. Meile
Õpetaja: kaks faili tegi. Meid huvitab rohkem see Vaatame veel
Õpetaja: Http. Sõnum kiri Browser serveri vahel. Iga kord, kui Browser laadib lehe või voerakendus küsib, andmeid ee Mõlemal juhul Vaata, onju saadetakse kokkuleppelise vormiga Http standardil vormiga. Kiri
Õpetaja: klient saadab päringu. Server vastab vastusega. Mõlemal on sama ehitusvahet pole Kummaga tähitud. Kirja Analoogia päised, ümbrik keha kirja sisu.
Õpetaja: Mhmh sõnumi ehitus. Meil on siis
Õpetaja: kolm osa algusrida. Päised. Valikuline keha,
Õpetaja: valgus rida, mida tahetakse. Mis juhtus, Ee, see nüüd on siis kett ja kaldkriips Midagi päised. Ee, saad panna mingisugust. Ee, lisainfot Natukene sisse. Veel, mis? Ei ole kohe nii Nähtav Body. Me räägime, Jason.
Õpetaja: Ee, katse. Katsu katsuta ise. Katsuta, Katsu katseta. Katsuta on vend.
Õpetaja: Ee, bla, bla, bla. Ta räägib seda, et on Siis erinevad meetodid. Get, näita mulle
Õpetaja: post. Siin on uus asi. Put asendab täielikult
Õpetaja: Muuda Osaliselt Delight. Kustuta. Need on peamised, mida kasutatakse, Mingid on veel mõned üksikud, mingid asjad, mingi head. Ja ma ei tea, mis iganes keegi ei kasuta sinuga levinumad
Õpetaja: katsetada. Vaata, et, ee, Ma ei tea, no praegult ketiga.
Õpetaja: Enne Seda ei saa. Niikuinii Ma ei viitsi.
Õpetaja: Status, koodid, kõik õnnestus loodi uus ressurss. Ta toob ka Nüüd mingid peamised. Ta vaatab ka, muidugi Mis siin veits on? Ee, hästi, lisasin midagi. Halb. Ee, halb päring Vigane päring.
Õpetaja: Selles mõttes, et Ta saab aru, et sa tahtsid mingit päringut saata. Ta saab aru, et mul on isegi nagu keegi, kes, ee, seda nagu kuulab,
Õpetaja: aga sa Ei, sa ei edastanud seda päringut. Nõuete kohaselt
Õpetaja: ehk siis midagi. On seal sellest päringust natukene nihu.
Õpetaja: Serveris läks midagi katki. Näiteks programmi viga, Back Endish. Noh, tavaliselt siis näemegi. See pole kliendi süü. See, kes küsib midagi. Ma ei küsi valesti. Siin on see, et kliend ei söö.
Õpetaja: Küsisid valesti. Siin on, seda, et tuksis.
Õpetaja: Ee, meie kasutame niukest tehnoloogiat taustal. Brauserisse on kirjutatud. Ee, Niukene programm. Ee Browser is On olemas Browser is on olemas siukene programm. Nagu
Õpetaja: tuhandeid.
Õpetaja: See ongi siis see programm, mille abil niiöelda ee on võimalik. Ee, Browser il nii öelda, Teha päringuid.
Õpetaja: Niiöelda sinu rakenduse seest.
Õpetaja: Aa, meie kasutame aktsias.
Õpetaja: Aktsias on siis Ee. Aktsias on siis niimoodi, et on selle sama Peale veel eraldi programm, mis on niiöelda peale ehitatud.
Õpetaja: Ee, miks aktsias? Noh, üks ee, inimene mingi aeg tagasi kommenteeris, et miks seda nagu kasutada, et see vahe on nagu see, et kui sa kasutad seda aktsias endal selles enda rakenduses,
Õpetaja: siis kui keegi niiöelda tuleb sinu lehele Ja ta veel varasemalt Seda aktsiast ei ole alla laetud lauser. Siis ta peab kiirelt nagu laadima väikse asja alla. Vaata, et tal on,
Õpetaja: See Ei, tule serveri poolt. See on Client I poolt kaalid.
Õpetaja: Aa, see on mingisugune mõte, tovere, et. Noh, kui sa oled mingi paaril saidel käinud. Ilmselt kuskil tissub.
Õpetaja: Ee, midagi ta väga ei muuda. Aktsiasega lihtsalt on selle päringu programmeerimine ja koodi kirjutamine. Ee, selles mõttes natukene. Minu meelest algaja sõbralikum. Esiteks, ta oskab taustal toimetada sihukese asjaga. Nagu, Ee, ta oskab jasonid linnulennnud teha java skripti objektiks ja vastupidi,
Õpetaja: see On nagu päris hea.
Õpetaja: Ee, ei pea sellega üldse ise tegelema ega programma. Teiseks ta õudsalt. Ee, hästi, Ee, teeb Seda järgib seda struktuuri,
Õpetaja: et kui mina saadan sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Vend, kui kõik on hästi.
Õpetaja: Kui on halvasti, et tuleb mingi viga, siis on nagu Catch blog
Õpetaja: vaata Mina Saadan sõnumi nüüd. On Ee, kooliblokk.
Õpetaja: Mis Siis hakkab juhtuma juhtuma? Saan programmeerida kohe sinna.
Õpetaja: F. Sada sõnum. Kui kõik läheb hästi.
Õpetaja: Järgmine blokk on Cash Blokk ehk? Tal on automaatselt seal ära manageeritud. See vihasüsteem ka. Kõik staatused, mis tulevad Ee, kahesajaga ja nii edasi. See käivitub, Ehk läks hästi.
Õpetaja: Kakssada, kakssada, üks, kakssada, kolm, Midagi Vahet pole. Ja need teised. Ka Kui tuleb mingisugune viga, Ehk nelisada või viissada Vahet, pole nendest. Siis minnakse Sinna Catch bloki, kus püütakse viga kinni ja hakatakse tegema veoaolukorra. Ja
Õpetaja: seda progedas on väga mõinna teha.
Õpetaja: Sada sõnum, Tee midagi, on hästi,
Õpetaja: Tee midagi ka üles midagi halvasti. Hakkame vaatama.
Õpetaja: Mõlemal juhul hakkame vaatama. Väga mõnus, Ta on alge, sõbralik, meeldiv mugav Ee, veits toimetatakse seal ära nagu mina. Isegi ma ei viitsiks tegeleda ka Üheski hobiprojektis ega arendatavas projektis, et minu meelest see on nagu See on nii mõnus. Pluss
Õpetaja: pluss on veel ka üks asi ka. Kuna ta on selle peale ehitatud, siis voes on võimalik igasugust ee pealkuulajat panna, et näiteks, et iga sõnumi juures ee sõnumid lendavad, vaadatakse
Õpetaja: Ee, seal näiteks seda, et kas sa oled sisse logitud autoriseeritud ee Saad automaatselt panna vahele, et kui sul on mingi.
Õpetaja: Sul on Niukene võti, mis kehtib järgmised viisteist minutit, et sa oled sisse autenditud vaata. Viieteist minuti pärast pead uue küsima. Sul on väga mugav progeda. Tegelikult taustal neid asju. Vaata, et kui su võti aegub siis ta
Õpetaja: küsib uue võtme. Vaata nii öelda et ma olen endiselt Elus.
Õpetaja: Ee. Niuksed. Asjad on seal.
Õpetaja: Ee, mulle meeldib see selles mõttes ee aktsias, ta teeb seda veits para lihtsamaks.
Õpetaja: Siin räägitakse ka Jasonitest. See on see kuidas. Saata see niiöelda? Kaasa mingeid sõnumid, aga See ei pea, olema Jason.
Õpetaja: Jason ei ole ainukene kirjaviis, et Jason on võrdlemisi uus võrreldes teiste formaatidega. Vanasti enamus nagu sõnumid, mis süsteemide vahel käisid olid, Xml Mis on ka nagu Html Tagg Idega. Siit algab mingi asi. Siit lõppeb mingi asi. Ee, Jason on mingi triljon korda paremini laetav
Õpetaja: Kors, Noh, sellest ei räägi praegu. Mis siin kirjas on? Ka Kokkuvõte,
Õpetaja: sõnum kokkuleppuse vormiga. Kirik kliendi ja serveri vahel. Päring meetod, teepäised valikuline vastus, Bla, bla, bla, status. Rohkem midagi. Põhiasjad andis meile kätte.
Õpetaja: Lisan need ka siia juurde. Pärast saate kodus vaadata.
Õpetaja: Kes tahab, Mis veel. Ee, Lähme siis tagasi
Õpetaja: aktsias. Ee, näitan ka. See on see projektile juurde pandud, et kui me vaatame, näete seda rida siin. Dependentsial
Õpetaja: ta on juurde lisatud. Ta ei tule vaikimisi kaasa.
Õpetaja: Nii, aga nüüd läheme siis meie oma koodi. Nad võivad kinni panna meie ärased kinni.
Õpetaja: Ee, lähme Siis sinna, kuhu me pooleli jäime. Me jäime pooleli Selle loo kinni Ehitamisega login reset. Message
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: If all Fill save input. Proovime sisse logida. Saadame Pacile sõnumi,
Õpetaja: Kui kõik väljad ei olnud täidetud. Error message saab täida kõik väljad. Siiamaani klapib, onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd see koht, siin
Õpetaja: mis ma ütlesin, Mis oli see tehnoloogia? Aa, mille abil saab saata sõnumeid, mille oleme valinud, et projektis Seda kasutame
Õpetaja: aksios. Siis kirjutame sõna Aksios.
Õpetaja: Ma ei soovita seda lõpuni kirjutada. Vaadake Kind of Rida. Mina ei tea. Kaks või kolm, kui sa validad Tabiga seda, mis juhtub Aa, okei, See on üle projekti ja ikka tuli tuli, onju? Siia, number reale Kolm
Õpetaja: Import peab ka olema.
Õpetaja: Kui sa kirjutad selle sõna välja, siis ei toimu midagi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd lähme vaatame korra. Taskis. Öeldakse, et. Ee. Mida me peame tegema?
Õpetaja: Ee, see oli parem. Taaskis Öeldakse, et Tuleb saata sõnum, postsõnum,
Õpetaja: Api, Log in koos Request Body. Ga
Õpetaja: Okei, mina panen siia punkti
Õpetaja: ja scrollin natukene alla
Õpetaja: Siit jääb midagi. Silma Mis meid huvitab
Õpetaja: just. Mis see M seal juures tähendab?
Õpetaja: Meetod, et on tegevus. Me käivitame mingisugust. Ee, tegevust.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin on igast muud asja, mis ta praegu näitab ka. Aga siit vaatest Ma ei tahaks näidata,
Õpetaja: kas kellegil tuli helehallit midagi siia sisse või mitte mingid vihjed, See. On see hea ongi. Kui ei tule. Kui sa kutsud välja mingisugust meetodit
Õpetaja: ja siis sa saad väga vahelda. Ütleme jaavast nagu suht Kiirelt viskab ette sulle korraks, et kas ta ootab midagi sisse? Sisendina ka või mitte, Ma räägin parameetritest.
Õpetaja: Noh, arv.
Õpetaja: Okei, sul midagi näitab, Vaata, see on nüüd,
Õpetaja: kuidas seda ei näita. Ja ma tegelikult niikuinii alati ise teen vaid kui te vajutate. Control B nagu parameeter.
Õpetaja: Noh, Kas näiteks midagi taolist? Aga lihtsalt helehallit on ju
Õpetaja: Aa. Niimoodi jäigi, on ju? Okei, Ee, ühesõnaga käsitsi. Mina tavaliselt niimoodi vaatan seda
Õpetaja: ee See Siis põhimõtteliselt annab vihje. Vaata, kui sa soovid seda meetodit kasutada, siis arvesta. Sellega, Vaata kuidas on see meetod programmeeritud. Vaata et ta ootab mingeid sisendeid.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui mina küsin, et. Ee, mis te pakute? Mitut sisendit ta ootab?
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, mitut sisendit ta ootab?
Õpetaja: Ühte, on Kindlasti vale Vastus.
Õpetaja: Kolmkümmend,
Õpetaja: no kolme ühte. Ee ja nii edasi. Ma nüüd õpetan teile ühe lihtsa triki. Vaata, vahet pole, kus tehnoloogias toimetate tavaliselt. Ee, niiöelda asjade eraldamine Selles. Võtmes nagu toimub alati Koma abil.
Õpetaja: Kui te loete kokku, komad, siis te saate aru,
Õpetaja: mit ühe Peab juurde veel lisama. Vaata aga, te saate komadega vaadata ja eraldada, et mitu muutujat siin on? Mitu muutujat. Kas nüüd saate aru, mitu On sul kolm? On ju, Sest komadega eraldatakse. See on niuke lihtne asi.
Õpetaja: Ja üldse ka, kui te programmeerite ja toimetajate ja seda käsitle Teete. Ee, loodetavasti. Ee, siis ongi hea. Kui te tegelete mingisuguste uute meetodite asjadega Mingid ee raamistikud, või Mingisugused mis iganes, iga kord Kui Te kutsute mingi meetodi välja, Siis nagu. Võtke korraks nagu võimalused vaadata, et mis ma nagu siia üldse panema pean, onju?
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Ee, see on Nüüd siis siin on siis mõned asjad veel.
Õpetaja: See on niimoodi tehtud, et. Ee, ee,
Õpetaja: mis on nagu põhimõtteliselt enne tüüpi, on siis Selle sildikese nimi.
Õpetaja: Mis see sildi nimed meil siin on? Öelge mulle, mul on,
Õpetaja: sest ülejäänud asjad näitavad tüüpi. Aa, tüüp on ka tähtis Selles mõttes, et kui me teame, et see Url peab olema string, siis kuidas ma praegu siin seda sisendit saaks anda? Siis ma peaks kirjutama,
Õpetaja: kui ma kirjutan String vä. Aga ma pean siia kirjutama Mingi urli väärtuse ju. Urli väärtus. Kindlasti String. Ei, ole
Õpetaja: Ta tahab praegu siin seda rada. Vaata, mis on meie rada, mis? Peame kirjutama sinna
Õpetaja: appi. Login, onju? Tuleb Kirjutada Seda urlida ootab. See ongi Url,
Õpetaja: aga Nüüd on siis kirjas. Vaata, et. Okei, Ma kirjutan siis ja kaldkriipsu appi, Aga midagi nagu ei sobi,
Õpetaja: sellepärast et tema ootab siia sisse Mida ta ootab siia sisse?
Õpetaja: Ta ootab siia sisse. Stringi.
Õpetaja: No anname tallest ringi. Siis mis ma kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Kõla komad.
Õpetaja: Vot sellepärast peab vaatama et Mida ta nagu ootab? Ta ju paneb mingeid vihjeid siin ka, Aga meie tahame siis kaardkriips abi.
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: te peate kahte asja vaatama, Mida Ta tahab ideeliselt praegu, et mis? See, mis see info või mis asi see on, Vaata, onju. Ja. Aga siis mis tüüp
Õpetaja: Data Any.
Õpetaja: Noh, sõna otseses mõttes ongi, nagu et võib panna mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Aga
Õpetaja: siin on nagu üks asi veel on võrreldes selle urliga ja Tataga siin midagi torkab silma. Natuke teistmoodi. Mis te siin näete? Midagi,
Õpetaja: mis sa. Nagu mingi küsimärk? Et mis see küsimärk võiks tähendada,
Õpetaja: ma Kohe ütlen niikuinii teile, aga pakkuge midagi. Et mis? Mis see küsimärk võiks tähenda? Ta nagu näitab, siin, et.
Õpetaja: No Urlil ei ole, seda On ju Tatar? See on konflikil, Nagu on ka see küsimärk,
Õpetaja: neil kahel on, Aga ühel ei ole. Mida sa võiks justkui viidata, täpselt, et pole kohustuslikud.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et kui ma teen esiteks mingisugust päringut. Ee, lisan asju. Ma võin ka Urli kaudu saata. Infot, mis ma korjan teiselt poolt. Üles.
Õpetaja: Esiteks, see võib ka kett sõnum olla. Vaata, mida iganes Data purli sees võib olla täiesti vabalt. Ma lisan mingi suud, Näiteks, mul on ainult kaks välja regamisel. Näiteks, et ongi ainult kasutaja nimi. See on ka post tegevus. Tegelikult lisamine
Õpetaja: kusjuures loginn on üks väheseid asju. Vaata, mis tegelikult otseselt midagi ei lisa. Vaata aga tehakse postiga veits Niukene hall ala,
Õpetaja: et postiga tegelikult peaks midagi süsteemi lisama peaks tulema uus kanne. Mis kanne sul tulevikus sisse Lihtsalt login. Tuleb mingi kannet.
Õpetaja: See on täiesti teine teema. Okei, see selleks on lihtsalt Kõrvale kaldumine. See. See tähendab, seda, et me võime selle asjaga mitte panna. Aga nüüd on väikene konks. Vaata, kuidas ma. Kuidas ma nüüd näitan. Oletame, et mul ei ole nagu, ee, mitte midagi kaasa panna. Meil ei ole see. Meil on midagi kaasa panna.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma saaksin? Noh, ma ei saa lihtsalt minna komaga ja minna järgmise juurde. Ta ütleb, et Kuule, niimoodi ei saa,
Õpetaja: kui ma ei taha mitte midagi panna. Kuidas seda programmeerimisest tahab?
Õpetaja: No nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd, konfig on selline osa, kus saab igasugust staffi kaasa panna, mis läheb põhimõtteliselt headerina kaasa, aga Mitte ainult Aa, siin on ka veel üks asi. Vaata, et. Ee, kas ta. Kui me. Vaatame näiteks seda.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui me vaataksime näiteks Ee, seda neid data tüüpest ringi. Ja
Õpetaja: ma korra panen. Ee, uuesti niimoodi. Control B.
Õpetaja: No vaatame. Siin on String Any
Õpetaja: aga konfigil on Peale seda koolonit. Vaata, kus tuleb tüüp Ei ole, lihtsalt eni. Siin on mingisugune staff veel.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, millele see võiks viidata?
Õpetaja: Access Request Config.
Õpetaja: Mida, mida see võiks tähendada? On Teil mingit mõtet?
Õpetaja: Aa, mis sealt üldse midagi?
Õpetaja: Ja, okei, on nagu lähemal. Ee, see see, Ma nüüd selgitan. Ära vaata data sisse. Tegelikult põhimõtteliselt sobib String
Õpetaja: ee int Ee, puuleon või mingi objekt ja avaobjekt.
Õpetaja: No me saame teha Student ja First Name last, onju? See on ju mingi objekt. Nüüd konfig on nüüd see, et ta tegelikult ootab sisse objekti,
Õpetaja: aga ta ootab sisse objekti, mis vastab täpselt konflikt klassile ja Mallile.
Õpetaja: Selles Request Config is on mingid kindlad väljad, mis sellel objektil käib?
Õpetaja: Ta põhimõtteliselt ütleb, et sa võid anda mulle objekti,
Õpetaja: aga see objekti sees saavad ja võivad ja. Noh, võibolla peavad olema mingid konkreetsed väljad, mida me tahame anda.
Õpetaja: Ja seda seda asja me kasutame. Näiteks siis, kui meil on mingisugused sõnumiparameetrid, mis lähevad lisaks kaasa. Hiljem räägime, et praegu ei Ole see teema,
Õpetaja: mis on meil praegu teema on siiski see data.
Õpetaja: No mis öeldakse meile, et mis peab sinna kaasa minema,
Õpetaja: Öeldakse, et peab Niukene Niisugune objekt peab minema sinna kaasa. Niuke Jason peab minema sõnumile kaasa. Tahan sellest
Õpetaja: välja minna, et oleks värviline tekst
Õpetaja: See sõnum ootab, et meil läheks mingi siukene objekt Või Jason kaasa.
Õpetaja: Kas meil on olemas kuskil Niukene objekt. Näiteks
Õpetaja: login. Request Vaatame.
Õpetaja: On siin username Ja Siis see ongi see data,
Õpetaja: mida me tahame selle sõnumiga kaasa panna.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma siis viitan nüüd sellele asjale. Siin?
Õpetaja: Hei, ja Aga Mõte oli õige, aga lihtsalt see formaalne kirjaviis on see, et ärge unustage ära
Õpetaja: siin kogu aeg selles Jaovascript i osas.
Õpetaja: Me peame seda sisse ette panema, sest et tema ei tea. Mul võib siin ka olla. Näiteks lett Login
Õpetaja: Request
Õpetaja: ise midagi käsitsi. Siin programmeerin ja panen kokku. Mul võib olla selline muutuja, kui ma tahan. Ja siis ongi küsimus. Nagu, et. Ee, mida sa.
Õpetaja: No ma panen selle väärtuse ka, Panen ta, et on veel objekt. Ka. Veel onju?
Õpetaja: Kordagi ei kasuta. Võtan selle Disc eest ära.
Õpetaja: On mõlemad valged.
Õpetaja: See on minu õigus Ja meil on vaba voli. Vaata aga, siin on kogu aeg see asi nagu seal üleval. Poolgi on see, et me peame poed juhendama, Mida me mõtleme nendes olukordades, kus võib tekkida nagu segadus. Vaata, onju? Või noh, kaheti mõtlemine.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ei ole siin enam midagi mõelda, las mul olla seal Real Ee üksteist Niukene muuta nagu request. Aga mina mõtlen ikka Databloki Request I.
Õpetaja: See dish peab kogu aeg olema
Õpetaja: Meile meeldivad.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin Java scriptis Mind Me ei tohi armastada.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see, asi, et tegelikult ju tuli veel siin parameetritest, aga see järgmine osa peale koma.
Õpetaja: Konfig on valikuline.
Õpetaja: Oh, panen Midagi uut ka. Palju või Ei,
Õpetaja: Ta oskab nagu siin ära näidata. Vaata, et mis, nagu sinna kaasa läheb. Näete seda siin usernane? See on täiesti midagi uut. Varem. Pole Kunagi öeldud.
Õpetaja: Ee, Nüüd me ei pea, kui see siin lõpus See on nüüd see jao Jaoskripti läbu maa. Vaata, on ju, et me ei pea sellele viimasele asjale panema, on all,
Õpetaja: et noh, et See See oli valikuline. Kui ta on lihtsalt puudu, siis ta ongi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma korra teen selle sama ee asja uuesti. Aga kui meil Oleks just vastupidine olukord, et meil data T ei lähe. Aga on mingi konflik, mida me tahame edastada. Siis ei ole valikut,
Õpetaja: et ei saa teha nagu siia, Nagu mingisugust asja, mis? Me mõtleme, et on konfige objekt. Sellepärast praegu ta läheb data alla. Siis on meil sundseis, Vaata, et see keskmist. Me peame määrama nulliga.
Õpetaja: Saate mõttest aru, et tagumine saab puudu olla ja ära jääda, Aga niimoodi ei saa järjest asju kirjutada, et tema saaks aru, et keskmist ma kaasa ei anna.
Õpetaja: Nii see asi on siin. Nagu. Kujutage ette If Lause
Õpetaja: nüüd. Temale Järgneb võimalikud variandid, mis nüüd, nagu meetoditega on võimalik välja kutsuda. Kui te panete siia punkti,
Õpetaja: Ta pakub mingisuguseid meetodeid, Kui keskenduda nendele ikoonidele, Siis mis mind võiks siin huvitada?
Õpetaja: Kaks tükki, mis võiksid huvitada
Õpetaja: need mõlemad punased Venn ja Catš.
Õpetaja: Kuidas see asi nüüd töötab, on see, et
Õpetaja: kui tuleb vastus ja mingil kujul vastus tuleb. Isegi kui vastust ei tule, nagu tuleb ette. Ei tulnud Vastust on ikkagi objekt. See Asi genereerib objekti Objekti Sees on meetod,
Õpetaja: vend.
Õpetaja: Nii, Ja tegelikult on ka. Kohe Võib oota panna punkt Catch.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi, et kui Objekt tuleb, siis on juba ära programmeeritud, et kui tuleb vastus kogu vastus koos sulgejate ja karvadega,
Õpetaja: siis see kood saab nüüd ise otsustada, Et kumma ta nendest käivitab?
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: ee, nüüd, et see tuleb igast lademetest koodi ja asju Vaata, et see asi ei hakkaks minema liiga paremale poole siis, kui meil on Niukene. Seda kutsutakse
Õpetaja: ketistamine. Vaata, onju, et järjest tuleb. Siin on see nagu See on see sama asi, Mäletate, kui me tegime nagu. Ja siis. Tuli punkt välju. Vaata onju, et paneme Pane veel. Midagi otsa.
Õpetaja: Ee, et siin oleks asju parem teha, siis tasub neid üldse lükata nende punktide koha pealt üksteise alla.
Õpetaja: Tavaliselt, kui niiöelda sellist Ee niiöelda, viiakse horisontaalist vertikaali Vaata, siis tehaksegi neid punktide kohad ja enne punkti. Ta tehniliselt töötab ka selliselt, kui ma teeks niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Aga see ei Ole, tava. Vaata, taane on ka vale,
Õpetaja: et tehakse enne punkti. Tehniliselt nad on kõik endiselt ühes Jorus tehniliselt.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Kuidas see asi käivitub, on siis niimoodi, et see asi Saadab sõnumi, ootab, ootab, ootab. Ja esimest korda, millest ma räägin. Nüüd on asünkroonsus
Õpetaja: aa Sünkroonsus.
Õpetaja: Kui sõnum läheb teele, siis kood ei jää nüüd seisma, et oodata,
Õpetaja: millal vastus tuleb, Et siis edasi liikuda
Õpetaja: Koos ülejäänud kood tegelikult sõidab edasi.
Õpetaja: Nad panevad edasi ülejäänud kood, kui sa mind koodi veel, on, siis see käivituja. Läheb Edasi
Õpetaja: See sõnumi saatmine on mõeldud niimoodi, et, ee, kui mina teen kooli, siis minule antakse kohe vastu promiss.
Õpetaja: Mina teen kõne. Mina tõmban traati. Tahan kellegile helistada. Siis See süsteem annab nagu mulle ee lubaduse. Mina annan sulle lubaduse et mingisuguse vastuse sa minult saad.
Õpetaja: Sina Ole kuuldajal,
Õpetaja: et kui vastus, nagu lõplikal. Tule kujul tuleb või ma sulle annan vastuse, siis sa Saad edasi toimetada.
Õpetaja: Vaadake, mõte on see, et. Ee, kui te vaatate Apollo kino punkt E, e onju? Kui palju seal on mingeid pilte asju teksti Sisu, mis iganes Need ei tooda niiöelda ühe päringuga,
Õpetaja: vaid pigem nagu mingi stiilis saja päringuga kaine.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja siis seal on Nagu selles mõttes, niimoodi, et kui me nüüd iga sõnumi puhul ootaksime, ära seda, kui kuni eelmine sõnum on saanud vastuse, siis põhimõtteliselt millisekundite asemel me juba hakkame siis saama. Mingi Kümnetes sekundites võib olla kui, keeruline see on ja. Kui kaua läheb
Õpetaja: läheks väga kaua aega kui, Iga kord peab ühe sõnumi ära ootama temaga toimetama. Siis saad alles järgmise sõnumi saata. Kas see mõte on teile selge?
Õpetaja: No sünkroonsus on See, et nagu selles mõttes, et sa saadad ta teele Ee, programmiliselt. Me ei pea midagi siin väga mõtlema. No, mõnes kohas on mõned nüansid, kus tuleb natukene mõelda,
Õpetaja: aga. Aga printsiibis? Nagu vähemalt. Mis puudutab siis seda kasutajakogemust, Siis on väga mugav, nagu, et kõik asjad, mis on vaja, nagu saada Need saadakse. Kui info tuleb, vaata siis meie, Browser või meie niiöelda programm niiöelda toimetab sellega lihtsalt ise edasi iseseisvalt,
Õpetaja: Ta Siis käivitab ma korra kõige tagant.
Õpetaja: See on loogiline, See on nagu objekt peaks tegema Või peale
Õpetaja: taustal toimubki file, aga mitte lihtsalt koodis. Seda meie ei pea tegema. Aga kui kasutada seda sisse ehitatud, Vaata, et see kirjaviis oleks hästi natuke. Teine Seal me peaksime tegema kogu aeg. Vaata,
Õpetaja: String. Iks, Vaata ja vastupidi. Kui tuleb vastus tagasi siis tee see jaoobjektiks. Vaata, onju, Siin on selles see ma ütlen, Kogu see aktsias on tegelikult selle peale nagu lisakihna ehitatud, et ta teeb seda meie eest,
Õpetaja: mis teeb selle mõnusaks, meil on lihtsalt, ee, Lihtne nüüd, teada, et ee,
Õpetaja: ee, siin on. Siin on üks või teine. Siin on selles mõttes If Else. Selles mõttes see on If
Õpetaja: Else. Ainult üks nendest saab käivitada nad on teineteist. Välistavad. Mõlemad meetodid Ei saa käivitada.
Õpetaja: Veel on üks variant, mida saaks kasutada. No kui ma punkti panen. Ta võiks juba pakkuda seda ise. Ma ei paku.
Õpetaja: Paine oli
Õpetaja: siia. On võimalik. Selles meetodis. On võimalik siis ära niiöelda progeda ja defineerida. Nagu see, et käivitub. See
Õpetaja: tehakse kõik kogu töö ära
Õpetaja: ja otsa peale. Kui see see asi saab läbi, pannakse purakanaga Need tegevused, mis on või vastupidi. Ee, käivitub See Catchblok. Tehakse kõik tegevused ära
Õpetaja: ja veel otsa käivitub see ka
Õpetaja: klassikaline näide, näiteks mida Võime teha ka. Ei, pea on Spinner. Näiteks
Õpetaja: Mm. Kui sa saadad mingi sõnumi, vaata onju, siis taustal läheb natukene aega, kui mingi sõnum teeb ja toimetab midagi. Kasutab, muutub närviliseks ja klõpsib seda sama nuppu. Võibolla uuesti üldse. Halb variant. Kui ta saab seda nuppu klõpsida uuesti, Äkki ta ei pea sama.
Õpetaja: Võiksime meie ka teha ühe spinneri. Siis on seda final It ka võimalik kasutada. Ja siin ongi see ka. Vaata, et ärge unustage ära. Kui te teete oma kohalikus masinas arengus,
Õpetaja: proovite seal mingisugust asju. Siis kõik on nii ülihea ja efektiivne ja Kõik käib nipsust ja nii edasi, onju?
Õpetaja: Kui teie nagu rakendus asub kuskil kuradi serveris ja teine kasutaja on kuskil Austraalias,
Õpetaja: siis asjad ei lähe enam nagu nii. Nipsus. Vaata, on ju, et, ee. Minu arvutis töötab kõik kenasti Siin ei päde. Vaata sellepärast, et sa peadki progema nagu neid asju niimoodi, Et arvestama, et. Noh, et kellegi teise arvutisse, sa võid teha mida iganes oma koodiga, aga tal ongi Delay on ju.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis ongi nagu, see, et, ee. Meie võiksime ka. Ee, Kasutada Spinnerit. Noh, kuhu me läheme? Selline visuaalne Mingi Spinner,
Õpetaja: Oleme Boots Trap, lähme. Sinna. No mis, ma otsin siit Jah,
Õpetaja: näete seda. No, igast variantidest. No seda on kõik näinud. Everyday Bufferings. Vaata, siin on Erinevad värvid.
Õpetaja: Võite ka neid ritta panna, kui tahate.
Õpetaja: Noh, tähendab, no miks üldse piirduda nendega? Vaata,
Õpetaja: noh, ei, lae vist oli.
Õpetaja: Võtab aega Vä.
Õpetaja: No natuke hakkab. Üheksakümnendate stiilis asi minema. Kuskilt tuleb. See on päris hea patarei.
Õpetaja: No, need variandid on ka päris head. Neid variante olete näinud või?
Õpetaja: Kohal?
Õpetaja: Siin proov.
Õpetaja: Te ei näe midagi vä. Minu lehelt ikka näete.
Õpetaja: Tere, vaatame Elronit. Vaadake, mis toimub.
Õpetaja: Sa,
Õpetaja: ee, see Oligi reklaamid, et te saate mida iganes panna, et siin. Midagi. Ah? Ei, laegi ära vaata. Näete, Elronil, mis toimub?
Õpetaja: Oota, Kuidas Refresh I
Õpetaja: Noh, et siin on nagu teada, et tuleb nagu mingi info. Vaata, kui ainult annab, et see on Niukene Päris hea disain, Vaata, onju, Aga mis on ta taustal Ta on tegelikult selles mõttes Spinner Lauder, vaata, mõte on sama. Vaata, et see, sõnum läheb teele, aga läheb aega, et vastus saada. Vist
Õpetaja: see on kuidagi fokuseerunud. No, ta on lihtsalt ilus. Vaata, et. Noh, kui sul Sul võib olla terve ekraan ka praegu, et hall ja lihtsalt üks spinner jooks teeb sama välja. Vaata, et, noh,
Õpetaja: vist läheb aega. Vaata, onju? Aga see mõte on nagu Sama et ei tule nii kiirelt, Noh, isegi. Kiirelt tuleb nagu informatsioon, tegelikult. Noh, arvestades tegelt polegi ainult tekste mingi asjad mingi mõttetu tilulilu. Teeme meiega oma spinneri. No mitte mingi niukse spinneri. See on nagu too Much.
Õpetaja: Ee, teeme midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Loading
Õpetaja: ja jah, mõtlengi kohe, Kuidas seda kõige lihtsam mingi Teeme
Õpetaja: Naistel korra. Võibolla
Õpetaja: ma ei viitsi mõelda nagu. Ee, ma Vaatan korra seda konstruktsiooni Kuidas seda kõige lihtsam on selle, Sest et see on Cs. Ss. Vaata, mina ütlen, et kasutaks midagi sellist
Õpetaja: nupu sees. Vaata, ei saa klikkida. Ka
Õpetaja: See oleks Nagu kõige parem nagu siin näitas. Vaata, logid. Sisse
Õpetaja: ta näitab sulle. Vaata, et logid, logid ja samal ajal teist korda vajutada ei saa,
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidas ee. Seda konstruktsiooni? Sest et siin sa pead. Nagu Me peame neid asju, tegema, mida me näeme siin, voe Mõistes
Õpetaja: need. Näited on? Vaata, nagu üleüldiselt. Nagu need üleüldiselt Css näited, on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, muutujat on selleks vaja Seda ma tean peast juba.
Õpetaja: Ee, aga ma ei mäleta hästi seda, et. Kuidas seda kontrollida. Kas teha veef Iga seda
Õpetaja: ma ei tea kuidagi teistmoodi.
Õpetaja: Jah, kaks patonit. Ühesõnaga, seda ma Arvasin rohkem. Ma ei vaja ka
Õpetaja: Davai. Ühesõnaga, mis meil on, vaja, on Meil Kõigepealt on see sama nupp, mis meil on juba olemas, siin loo kinnis. Kus see nupp on? Meil otsinud? Ülesse
Õpetaja: sinna all on ju login. Click.
Õpetaja: Teeme sellest. Tublika oli
Õpetaja: ja meie plaan on nüüd seda teha. Vaata, et ee. Üks nendest on spinneri nupp.
Õpetaja: Teine nendest on päris nupp.
Õpetaja: Nagu selles mõttes. Mida saab klikkida.
Õpetaja: Ee, Üritame jaotavas vormis teha.
Õpetaja: Siin näites konkreetselt oli show. Spinner oli muuta. Jällegi on see. Vaata, et meil on see sama igivana küsimus. Me tahame midagi niiöelda Mingit käitumist.
Õpetaja: Ee, selles kuvatavas asjas. Me saame seda ainult teha läbi data bloki
Õpetaja: See asi ei ole kuhugi läinud, et meil On vaja datablokis mingisugust tüüpi muutujat, mis alguses on vaikimises mingi väärtusega.
Õpetaja: No kõige parem oleks nii, nagu seal oli,
Õpetaja: tema on tüüpi kui Me lehele saabume. Mis võiks olla tema väike väärtus,
Õpetaja: False, et me Ei, soovi juba spin Ib nagu vaata, onju? Noh, kui seal lehel Laetakse mingeid asju me saame, Tead, võibolla seal lehte hakatakse järkjärgult näitama nii nagu, ee, see isegi siis sa programmiliselt otsustaks, vaata on ju, et ei paneks, et ta on kohe. Näita Spinnerit. Võibolla info tuleb Ülikiirelt. Ei jõuagi seda näha.
Õpetaja: Nii tema väike väärtus võiks olla, siis False
Õpetaja: Show. Spinner, näita Spinnerit. Ära näita
Õpetaja: nüüd. Kui me tuleme oma koodi, siis me peame otsustama. Ära vaata, et me teeme V Else, Vaata, me saame mõlemat pidi teha, Aga et. Kas. Kas see nupp on niiöelda? Mida siis, Mis on Spinneriga ja saab klikkida
Õpetaja: ja see on ilma. Ee, ilma Spinnerita Tähendab, vabandust, see on Spinneriga ja seda ei saa klikkida. See on Spinneriga. Seda saab
Õpetaja: klikkida. Lihtsalt hakkame tegema Ee,
Õpetaja: kliki võime ära võtta. Ma mõtlen, korra Teeme niimoodi, et ee, tahaks jätta et ta on nega, et ta ei oleks eitav, selles mõttes on ikkagi ainult üks valik.
Õpetaja: Jose Spinner on True Siis näitama. Sellest saab olema see. Saab olema Spinneri nupp.
Õpetaja: Nii ma panen nüüd juurde. Ka Vaata, kuidas siin seda saab. Seda Spinnerit.
Õpetaja: Spinner. Border. Spänn.
Õpetaja: See on. See nupp on ju loading. Uga on see. Vist
Õpetaja: ee. See vist on copy Based koht. Ma ütleks ee. Sellepärast, et. Ee. Ta on nii mitmekihiline.
Õpetaja: Siin on mingid välted ja asjad. Me peame seda veits vaatama veel. Kuidas onju Nii, võtame selle.
Õpetaja: See on. See on see näide.
Õpetaja: Ee, No siis on otsustatud. Vaata See on Spinner. Paneme selle siia ülesse.
Õpetaja: Nii hetkel, kui me nüüd läheme, vaatame oma rakendust. Siis me peaksimegi nägema loodingut ja logi sisse. Vaata, seda nuppu on Kaks korda
Õpetaja: peaks Nii olema, on nii?
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd me peame siis W If iga tegema. Ära ta näiteks ainult ühte.
Õpetaja: Ee, selle korraga, et kui on show Spinner.
Õpetaja: Oi, kui nüüd tuleb see räige sõna. Kuidas, Mis te kirjutaksite Eesti keeles Loading asemel
Õpetaja: la laadima laen Ai Kogu aeg paneb.
Õpetaja: Ee, laadin.
Õpetaja: Laadin alla. Ei, pane isegi laadin.
Õpetaja: Ja see tundub nagu alati nagu laen laenu alla,
Õpetaja: aga sisse logimine on üldse. Mis? Ta võiks öelda, et
Õpetaja: kui on logi sisse ja ta hakkab tegutsema, siis ta. Mida te üldse laev on ju, et Ei olegi vaja, vaid siin. Kontekstis on vaja mõelda, et kui ma vajutan seda,
Õpetaja: login sisse või login. Punkt, punkt näiteks.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma pakun, Et see vist võikski olla kõige parem, et ma paneks siia.
Õpetaja: Login sisse, login sisse.
Õpetaja: Mulle isiklikult ei, meeldi, et nad elavad mitte kaelas üksteisel. Seega ma ei viitsi seal spänniga siin tegeleda. Las ta olla
Õpetaja: Nüüd on Siis see. Vaata, et me peame nüüd siis manipuleerima
Õpetaja: selle sama nii öelda Show Spinneriga. Vaata, et kumba, millal näidatakse. Ja siin peab olema teineteist välistav. Vaata, et me ei saa, et meil on Kaks nuppu korraga. Me peame tegema selle konstruktsiooni. V, If ja V Else
Õpetaja: Ee peavad olema järjestikum.
Õpetaja: No seda on ainult. Spinnerit on ainult vaja siis näidata, kui show Spinner On True vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Ahah, nii.
Õpetaja: Wave. If, Mis ma nüüd kirjutan siia nii
Õpetaja: edasi. Mis ta on?
Õpetaja: Ohoo,
Õpetaja: Oi, ma ootasin. See oli täielik träpp. Vaata ka, nagu, et ma ootasin meelega nagu et paneme hunnik võrdusmärke ja siis paneme siia True.
Õpetaja: Kui see on true.
Õpetaja: Kui on true, siis näita seda, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd teeme ruttu mõtteharjutuse. Vaata, et varem või hiljem, nagu oli vaja seda teha. Ma teen seda Javascripti blokis. Ma korra kaaperdan selle login meetodi. Teeme If Lause If
Õpetaja: Ee. Ma panen selle muutuja ee Kohaliku muutuja Led Show Spinner.
Õpetaja: Pane ta väärtuseks keelaks paigast ära.
Õpetaja: Nii panen ta väärtuseks. True, et mul on lihtsalt see koodiharjutus. Lihtne,
Õpetaja: me Mängime selle asja läbi. Ee, Kui show. Spinner võrdub, võrdub truu.
Õpetaja: Siis näiteks ütleme, et ta tagastaks
Õpetaja: return True. Vaatab. Ta peab midagi tagastama. Return True.
Õpetaja: Nii Elsega. Siis tuleks Else Return Ib. Mida ta return Ib siis? Mis oleks nagu loogiline Poolse.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd mängime seda olukorda Nagu läbi, on ju? Okei, siin ma panen, on. Kui ma. Kui see on truu,
Õpetaja: siis asi rehkendub. Milleks, et, noh, kui truu võrdub truu, siis ta võrdub truu, on nii
Õpetaja: okei. Ja sellisel juhul siis me return ime. Truu on õigus.
Õpetaja: Retöönitakse seda.
Õpetaja: Okei, kui nüüd Show Spinner on Falls.
Õpetaja: Kas False võrdub true? See rehkendub, milleks Poolsex
Õpetaja: Ja siis retööritakse? Nagu selle näite puhul on nii?
Õpetaja: Ehk siis vahet pole Mis iganes ongi selle showspinneri väärtus või vaband. Selle muuta väärtus true Sellises kontekstis Ifes,
Õpetaja: siis ta täpselt ongi. Ta ju alati rekendab truuks.
Õpetaja: See ongi teie puule on väärtus, mille jaoks seda võrrelda? Selle truu. Ja vaata või truuga Täpselt,
Õpetaja: kas vastab tõele praegult, et ee, niiöelda Kui Show Spinner on truu, siis sulgude sisu rehkendub. Truuks
Õpetaja: on järelikult ta tagastab True, onju? Kui see on False
Õpetaja: show. Spinneri väärtus on, Milleks ta rehkendub?
Õpetaja: Baltics Järelikult returnitakse False, milleks võrrelda poole on väärtust. See on
Õpetaja: Cold Reviewst. Tulevad mingid kihisevad naeru vaad
Õpetaja: Aa Sel Vennal On veel veits aega,
Õpetaja: kui see soovite. Ja teine asi on see näiteks ka. Vaata, et, ee,
Õpetaja: kui ma tahan saada siin mingisugust väärtust
Õpetaja: Ma ei hakka. Näiteks. Ma tahan sellele showsprinnerile mingisugust väärtust. Ka Ma panen siia nime Valmis on ju.
Õpetaja: Ja ma teen näiteks mingi konstruktsiooni, et nad ei enam, vaid panevad väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Kohe teen siia.
Õpetaja: Ee, paneme ised alt.
Õpetaja: Me paneme. Tema saab olema. Meil, ee,
Õpetaja: teda veel ei kasutata. Ma teen ühe leti veel. Led H.
Õpetaja: Ma panen siia mingi väärtuse ka.
Õpetaja: No paneme. Ee, paneme. Paneme viisteist
Õpetaja: Cia If Lausesse Ma Teen siis siukse asja, et minu eesmärk on aru saada. Vaata, kas kasutaja on.
Õpetaja: Kas kasutaja on Adalt või mitte, Seal saab olema plaan. Näiteks
Õpetaja: nii. Mina teen seda, et kui Age on suurem või võrdne kui
Õpetaja: kaheksateist, siis ma tahan öelda, et saab uue väärtuse ja on True on nii?
Õpetaja: Klapib, onju?
Õpetaja: Kui ta ei ole, siis iset alt on False
Õpetaja: selline asi, nagu praegult võiks töötada. Idee järgi on ju Nii
Õpetaja: minu küsimus on see. Vaata, kui ma näen ka mingit niukest asja, siis ma mõtlen, nagu
Õpetaja: mõtleme nüüd seda. Vaata, on ju et, Ee,
Õpetaja: milleks praegult sa siin rehkendud? Milleks praegult selle H. Viieteistkümne klassi rehkendub?
Õpetaja: Poolse?
Õpetaja: See konstruktsioon rehkendub False iks, on nii see asi siin rehkendub False iks,
Õpetaja: Siis see tähendab, et sellesse esimesse koodiplokki ei tulda, minnakse ja talt saab väärtuse, on nii.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis see sama väärtus tuleb siia, on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui ma panen nüüd selle näiteks kakskümmend, siis ta rehkendub truuks, on nii?
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et see rehkend. See. See sisu siin rehkendub truuks. Järelikult mõlemad. Need on jälle samad,
Õpetaja: kui mina. Näen niukest asja, et seda ilmselt alti, otsustatakse kuidagi. Niimoodi siis Mul tõusevad lihtsalt karvad turri.
Õpetaja: Miks sa siis kohe selle asemel, et seda niimoodi keeruliselt otsustada? Kui see asi otsustabki ära tema True ja Falls väärtuse, siis miks mitte see panna kohe siia teisele poole siia väärtuseks?
Õpetaja: Kogu see jura.
Õpetaja: Kustutame ära sellepärast, et see asi. Noh, ma ei saanud siit ära võtta.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et see sama ongi. See see rehkend. See ei ole. Enam Number
Õpetaja: siin on number. Siin on võrrand, Mida programm rehkendab? Mida sa seal ifi sees jamad kui eesmärk on? Saada
Õpetaja: see väärtus Sest nii me teeme ka. Meil on meetodid, näiteks Mis returnivad?
Õpetaja: Mingeid võrrandeid.
Õpetaja: Teil on juba üks selline. Kus on siukene asi?
Õpetaja: Vaatage seda Allfeels Have correct import.
Õpetaja: No ma tulen siia korra, Mis Tulen, see on? Siin all on ju niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Meil on allfeels. Tagastab väärtust. Siin ei ole. Mingeid If lauseid ja asju vaata vaid See sama asi
Õpetaja: rehkendub alguses ühe poolega truuks või False iks vaadatakse. Kas teine pool on truu? Kui mõlemad kokku on Truu ja Truu sees. See asi rehkendub truuks, on ju nii?
Õpetaja: Täppi Pead saama all. Fields.
Õpetaja: Ei pane siia kuskile muutujasse vaid see meetod see. On nagu see koht. Vaata, mis ma ütlen, kui sa kutsud välja mingi meetodi. Mis midagi muutujasse, et Noh, see on see koht, kus ei ole mõtet muutujasse panna. Ma saan teha. Näe, palun väga Control altv. Ma teen sellest tekstist mitte meetodi ekstraktina, vaid kohaliku muutuja.
Õpetaja: Ee, see sama. Need näited Refaktor.
Õpetaja: Ekstrakt. Meetod. Siin on niuke asi. Introduce variable.
Õpetaja: Ma teen niimoodi. Niimoodi saaks ka teha, Aga see oleks, ee, esimeses Sammus Võib isegi niimoodi teha kui tahaks. Aga Ma ei näe põhimõtteliselt miks. Vaata,
Õpetaja: mis ta ühe tegi siia,
Õpetaja: Noh, et me otsustame ära vaata, Kui sa kutsud välja meetodid, mis midagi tagastab ja sa soovid sellega midagi edasi teha? Noh, Soovin edasi teha. Siis pane su muuta pikk Protsess võib isegi niimoodi olla.
Õpetaja: Lühike protsess on nagu. See, et mul on siin üks muutuja mida on ainult koodis ainult ühe korra veel kasutanud, et. Noh, milleks siis see muutuja? Kohe järgmisel real. Kasutan siis see oleks vähemalt loogiline etapp. Vaata, et. Oot, oot, oot, ma panen selle otse sinna.
Õpetaja: Aga mu mõte on loomulikult teie kui õppija. Ta oleks ikka alati, kui sa kutsud välja mingi meetodi, mis midagi tagastab Ja soovid selle infoga edasi teha midagi? Siis pane see muutujasse,
Õpetaja: et lihtsalt siis teil on kuskilt edasi minna. Vaata, onju, et see alati klapib. No see ei tähenda, et lõpptulemus jääb niisuguseks.
Õpetaja: Mitte kunagi. Alguses paneme muuta. Pärast Teeme koodi veits. Korda Make it work Make. It Briti.
Õpetaja: Noh, teeme ilusaks. Võtame mingid ühe väiksed muud ajad ära
Õpetaja: ja, noh, mingit siin ei kajasta,
Õpetaja: kus me jäime Ee, posti juurde. Jäime Kuhugi, mida ma ütlesin? Gäp I Sin. Mõtlesime, et. Aa, need blokid.
Õpetaja: Aa, me tegime selle spinneri. See Spinner Spinner. Tuli Mul ee. Final. Iga tuli põhimõtteliselt see mõte.
Õpetaja: Ee, mitu vahendaga.
Õpetaja: Aa, Paton on ka veel tegemata. Vä.
Õpetaja: Ee Shows Aa, siia. See, oli see kus tänu Aivarile läks nagu loeng, nagu kaugele. Aga aitäh sulle
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et need on asjad, mida te peate teadma ja oleks vaja teada, et, noh, mitte teha neid asju. On ju,
Õpetaja: et ee. Siin piisab sellest, kui see oli täielik träpp. Vaata, mis nüüd edasi. Mis nüüd edasi? Vaata. No kui keegi oleks, öelnud et nüüd tuled, siia alumise patani juurde ja paned vee. Else oleks olnud ka Fine, siis ma oleks olnud Okei, te pääsesite, Aga te ei pääsenud seda.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see Vaata, et see V If võimaldab seda, et järgnev elemendile praegu on, muidu Praegu on nagu see show Spinner. Kui see on true, Ma lähen korra. Panen ta truuks. Lihtsalt, et ta oleks true.
Õpetaja: Ikka näidatakse kaks tükki, aga meil on vaja seda. Vaata, et, ee. Kui üks on truu, siis seda Näita
Õpetaja: aga järgmist. Näita ainult siis, kui see on Vaata, ehk siis see Else blokk tuleb siia. V
Õpetaja: vee. Elseif. Vaid Else.
Õpetaja: Need töötavad, aga nad peavad. Keegi enam küsiks seda, kas nad Peavad olema nagu lähestikku. Pead küll jah.
Õpetaja: Kui nad peaksid üksteisest eemal olema, siis tuleb lihtsalt teha eraldi muutujad,
Õpetaja: et, ee, mis üks on Nagu välistav ei saa muuta, et saab panna vastupidi ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, sellest võib ka rääkida.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma näitan. Saaks teha nagu sellise konstruktsiooni ee inversiooniga.
Õpetaja: Kui Show Spinner on truu, siis näita seda.
Õpetaja: Kui ma tahaksin teha, et oleks apart nagu ka koodi mõttes, mitte, lihtsalt, ee, uute Ridade mõttes, ma saaksin teha siia vee ifi ja öelda, et show spinner, et kui show spinner on Do Not show, Spinner,
Õpetaja: See peaks niimoodi lugema. Seda see keerab tagurpidi. Mis iganes see muutu ütleb, loe negatiivselt.
Õpetaja: Don T. Show Spinner.
Õpetaja: Noh, see töötaks ka. Vaata, ainult ühte saab korraga näidata.
Õpetaja: Kus on True?
Õpetaja: Siis näidatakse Spinnerit. Kus Spinneri väärtus on? False? Kus ta peaks olema? Siis näitab see logi sisse mõte on selge,
Õpetaja: aga siin ei ole seda vajadust. Sellepärast. Nad on ju kohe üksteise juures.
Õpetaja: Siin piisab väga hästi selle vee helsega mõte, on Selge,
Õpetaja: et me saame kasutada ühte ja sama muutujat erinevates kohtades tagurpidi.
Õpetaja: No nüüd on siis vaja hakata teha ka niukest seda, et kui hakata sisse logima.
Õpetaja: Nii pea. Kui klik. Jah, küsi.
Õpetaja: No. Ametiühingu.
Õpetaja: Ametiühingu peab saama. Mis ametiühing tahab? Ametiühingu. Ei mässata.
Õpetaja: Teeme asi.
Õpetaja: Kummed, kartid Ma teen. Ma teen komiiti ka, kui keegi tahab.
Õpetaja: Jah, me väga harva seda teeme. Aga praegu keegi hõikas selle välja, Siis, ee, teeme Ikka Jah,
Õpetaja: ma push in ka selle ära Kui keegi tahab pausi ajal järgi tulla, siis tulge.
Õpetaja: Ee, panen Jah, pausile. Aga nüüd peab meeles hoidma, eksole
Õpetaja: Ja kogemata video vaatajatele teade, et natukene aega peale pausi Ee kogemata ei olnud see recording sees
Õpetaja: see kõik on, kes Ütles, et saad paus teha.
Õpetaja: Aa, seal taga oli. Sina soovisid lihtsalt. Ee. Sina soovisid lihtsalt ametiühingu pausi. Aga keegi ütles Recording paus. Kes See oli.
Õpetaja: Aitäh Fredile videokuulajad. Ee, kui teil on mingi küsimusi. Ee, viimase viieteist minuti kohta, mis jäi puudu. Kirjutage sinna Private Slaki Fredile, Ta räägib, mis puudu jäi.
Õpetaja: Nii, väga hea,
Õpetaja: Ee, Midagi nagu taustal ei tööta Selles. Mõttes. Ee, et ee, Sõnum läheb aga vastust ei Tule
Õpetaja: ja nelisada. Neli justkui viitaks, et. Ee. Keegi ei Kuula, ma korra vaatan. Ma vahepeal näppisin seda, kui ma rääkisin teile enne midagi,
Õpetaja: See on paigas. Ee, peaks olema niimoodi. Kui tuleb api sõnum, siis see läheb appile edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, saadetakse Stoplight I, aga mul on Niuke tunne, et Stoplight I sõnum ei lähe.
Õpetaja: Mm. Sõnum läheb,
Õpetaja: aga siiski läheb Stoplight Ile.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on see, et ma tegelikult mingi aeg Recoverisin selle projekti ja ma tegin muudatusi sellest Ai abiga.
Õpetaja: Ja. Oota. Ee, mul on üks mõte. Korra võib Stop Light I ka lahti. Teha. Äkki ta on vaikimisi.
Õpetaja: Noh, ee, öelge valesti. Aga täpsemalt, mis on hea küsimus,
Õpetaja: Üritame seda kuidagi siis ee, aru, saada
Õpetaja: aitäh väga nad pärast laiali. Tegelt võib siin panna. Ringiga. Igaüks võtab ühe ja saada edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, kohe saab Cloudiga seda ka, tegelikult kui kohe mitte Kuidagi ei taha tulla. Aga ma vaataks kõigepealt siit ühe sätte üle.
Õpetaja: Äkki peaks olema hoopis selline. Nüüd Edaspidi
Õpetaja: pole seda ju mitu kuud kasutanud, Paneks siis uuesti käima ka.
Õpetaja: Oota, aga kui ma võin mingit teenust proovida. Ju Ükskord proovisime Mingi get Cities või mingi asjaga. Ma Võtsin selle otse sealt. Niiöelda. No Vaatame korra. Äkki saab praegult ikkagi käima.
Õpetaja: Okei, ee, vahepeal on muutunud see aadress, mis on siin
Õpetaja: ma annan. Kas Kas te tulete kõik järgi või ma lihtsalt copy basena. Tulete vahetate ära. Kuidas tahate?
Õpetaja: Teeme Copy Basediga kummid.
Õpetaja: No võin samal ajal kumiti ka ära teha.
Õpetaja: Aga võibolla mõni ei taha lihtsalt kohe kuidagi tulla. Nagu järgi
Õpetaja: tahab ise nagu mudida, Siis on see võimalus ka. Ma annan teile siis uue urli. Vaata, vahepeal see Url on hästi natukene muutunud.
Õpetaja: Võtan selle osa. Ma võtan terve selle rea lihtsalt Ja tulen ja panen selle.
Õpetaja: Slaki.
Õpetaja: Ja te panete Slaki mingit koodiblokki. Pange alati. Kasutage alati seda nuppu. Siin.
Õpetaja: Nii, võtke see rida, mis Ma panin ee. Sinna Generali
Õpetaja: Ja siis. Te võtsite lihtsalt projektist ülesse.
Õpetaja: Kas ma bussiga tegin ja bussi peal endiselt? Kui keegi tahab järgi tulla, siis saab seda ka varsti teha.
Õpetaja: Nüüd
Õpetaja: Kui te tulete ja otsite selle Frontend I alt on ee, siis siin all on ee, Vit Config on niiöelda See rida siin rida. Kaksteist
Õpetaja: kood on vahepeal midagi muuta.
Õpetaja: Slaki Generalis Panin kogu selle ära
Õpetaja: mitte teha niimoodi kolm Hästi, kiiret klikki
Õpetaja: läheb siniseks üle pestida koma. Kõik asjad olid seal, Mida, nagu tähtajad.
Õpetaja: Ee, igaks juhuks Tehke restart. Ma ei ole kindel, et konfig on osa.
Õpetaja: Pange korra lihtsalt server uuesti käima selle nupuga siit
Õpetaja: nii
Õpetaja: samal ajal Kui te seda teete, siis ma lihtsalt taustal Näitan, et ee. Näete. Ma panen korra, kui mul on siin mingid väljad täidetud ja ma aitan logi. Sisse läheb sõnum teele,
Õpetaja: Mis see Sõnumi staatus on, mis see tähendab,
Õpetaja: läks. Läbi ehk siis May Browserist läks sõnum teele ja ta sai vastuse nüüd, kui selle peale klikida, Siis Ta on natuke rohkem informatsiooni. Kui me alustame siit,
Õpetaja: siis näeme, et läks boss enam postkat.
Õpetaja: Batch Bood.
Õpetaja: Kogu see tee
Õpetaja: Aa, siis See Url, mis läks? Ee, läks appi. Login, aga vaadake, kuhu vastu ta läks. Ta saadetakse Front and serverile.
Õpetaja: Meie Fronten server Käib. Ju Boardil. Kaheksakümmend kaheksakümmend. Üks on I,
Õpetaja: Aga siis sellest konfist ongi niimoodi, et me ütleme, et Hei, meil on teine server,
Õpetaja: mille läbi me Tahame suhelda. Ja see on Niukene Special seadistus, et Kui Url algab apiga,
Õpetaja: siis sellisel juhul saada see sõnum siuksesse kohta
Õpetaja: ja siis sellest Sõnumist tuleb ise juurde. Vaata see ee, appi.
Õpetaja: Login. Vaata mõttest aru, et see kogusõnum läheb niimoodi. Et See on nüüd päriselt Serveri aadress on siin.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd nemad on programmeerinud ära.
Õpetaja: Kui tuleb sõnum nende infosüsteemi. Mox, vali It My projekt ja siis mingi Id, mis on Nagu minu konkreetse projektiga seotud.
Õpetaja: Siis võta see sõnum vastu. Vaata selle sõnumi sisu ja vasta nii, nagu mina Olen eksamlis pannud mingi teenuse alla. Ma olen ära progenud selle teenus
Õpetaja: Ja kui teie proovite, siis teil peaks see samamoodi töötama,
Õpetaja: kui me nüüd vaatame. Ee, mis on Pailo D. Paylo D on? Mis läks, kaasa? Kui ma panen siia Aa
Õpetaja: ja panen siia,
Õpetaja: panen siia, Tulen korra, panen selle ristis kinni Ja kustutan ära, et oleks, hea lihtne vaadata. Saadan meele sõnumi, No neid sõnumeid Ma võin saata nii palju, kui tahan
Õpetaja: seal vahel võib tulla mingisugune Clash. Kui me kõik korraga saadame mingi sõnumi. Vaata, et, ee. Ta ütleb, et ei jõudnud või mida iganes, onju
Õpetaja: aga suures pildis see nii on, kui ma vaatan selle sõnumi sisu kaasa Request Bodies Pay Loadem läheks
Õpetaja: nüüd. See on Request.
Õpetaja: See on respons mis Ta mulle vastas.
Õpetaja: User Id Üks role on admin, on nii?
Õpetaja: Printsiibis me pole midagi isegi progenud veel. Aga me näeme, et sõnum läheb Meie browserist nupu vajutusega teele on nii
Õpetaja: väga tore
Õpetaja: saada veel.
Õpetaja: No et see on natuke Stoplight i teema Vaata vahel Bad Gateway vist on, ee, vist
Õpetaja: aplaus või?
Õpetaja: Ei, Kes teab vaadata? Siis nagu vaatab ära sellele.
Õpetaja: No see, see on. Nagu see on. Jah, see on Sinu browser Sinu aken. Vaata, kui sa tahad oma kalli kaasa eest, vaata oma ee. Seda klassikalist prooli. Mis? Sul on pea igas kohas nagu varjata. Vaata, sa lihtsalt ei tee seda inspektuuli lahti ja ei lähe kooli,
Õpetaja: eks? See on, ma jään vastuse võlgu, kui lihtne seda on teha, aga ma pakuks, et see on väga suur oht. Jah,
Õpetaja: et,
Õpetaja: ee. Ma just alles hiljuti tegin. Ee, läbi ettevõtte poolt Ee, turvalisuse. Mingi test. Vaata, ennem oli mingi terve rodu mingi materjale. Ja siis olid noh, mingid küsimused, asjad ja kuskil mingi riigiportaalis, mingi niukene Asi on tehtud väga fun. Oli see
Õpetaja: ee, teadsipidi.
Õpetaja: Ee, et seal on küsimus. Nagu totakad lihtsalt ka tegelikult, Aga sealt oli ka põhimõtteliselt Niimoodi, et, ee. Ära Jumala eest. Mitte kunagi kuskil ee avalikus Wifi s olevat. Kasuta alati oma.
Õpetaja: Ära. Pane oma hiirt isegi Jumala eest kuskile Usb Sse. Ja ma ei tea, mida kõike. Vaata, oli. Aga Ma vaatasin niimoodi, et nagu, kui. Nagu selle järgi nagu elada, mis on siis Ma ei tea, Ma lihtsalt istun kodus. Vaata oma toas ja vaatan lakke. Vaata, onju, et
Õpetaja: nagu et mitte midagi ei tohi teha. Vaata kogu aeg, aga see on. See on risk, kui sa oled alati. Loomulikult. Ma ei tea, kui suured need ee, realisatsioonid, kui Lihtne on teha, et enamus kohad üritavad kah ikkagi oma nagu Wifi D ja asju kuidagi kaitsta. Vaata Onju
Õpetaja: et, ee, see oht on alati olemas,
Õpetaja: aga. Noh, nagu selles mõttes, et kujutage nüüd muidugi ette. Vaata, et ega see oleks infosüsteem ja see oleks päris veebiserveris, vaata, et. Noh, seal on kõik see, kus iganes täna sa nagu käid. Vaata onju, et need sõnumid lähevadki. Enamus süsteemid täpselt samamoodi toimivad need, Sõnumid lähevad teele, et see mingi elementaarne turvalisus peaks siin ikkagi olemas olema, et see nagu päris mingi lapsemäng ei tohiks olla, sest sa Oleks ju väga ohtne, et tahad. Pank Tähendab, päeva lõpuks. Vaata, Noh, me praegu
Õpetaja: üldse by the way üks. Asi kohe vajab disclaimer. Eit
Õpetaja: Kui teid keegi aitab. Mingisugune arendaja või kes iganes te pöördute nende poole, et Kuule, tule, räägi mulle ja aita, on ju
Õpetaja: siis öelge neile kohe Disclaimer. Ina, ära vaata, et siin ei ole tehtud logimine nagu eesmärgipäraselt. Nii nagu päriselus on. Isegi paroolid pole meil ee niiöelda krüptitud ega ära peidetud meid tegelikult niimoodi ei saadeta. Üle parole. Niimoodi saadetagi.
Õpetaja: Sellise sõnumiga ei saadeta Nagu plain tekst kujul. See on. See on Crazy. Niimoodi ei tohi teha.
Õpetaja: Ee ja ja üldse meil sisse logimine on üks suur naljanumber nagu meil back end is
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et Me Ei, hakka nagu lihtsalt. Meil pole aega vaadata, kuidas seda päriselt teha.
Õpetaja: See. See ei, ei. Siis Kui teil oma projekti on vaja teha. Siis uurige ja pole midagi keerulist Cloud, teeb teil selle ära. Vaata, kõige lihtsam. Sa logid sisse. Sa saad sessiooni vaata et nüüd Paroolid on kindlasti krüptitud.
Õpetaja: Mitte nagu niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et ee, Sest et ma olen saanud seda tagasisidet siis hiljem. Vaata, et aa, et jah, põhimõtteliselt Mingi sõber vaatas peale ja Naersis selle asja peale. Ütles, et Kuule, siin on nagu mingi
Õpetaja: niimoodi ei tehta logimist mõtlevad ma mingi viie aasta staažiga mingi arendaja ja õpetan mingi neli aastat. Pluss Juba õpetan ee progemist, et ma nagu ei tea, kuidas logimine käib, Vä,
Õpetaja: Jah, Ma Tean väga täpselt, kuidas see käib. Ma oma projektides ikkagi olen teinud seda, Aga noh, teile, ma lihtsalt ei jõua seda õpetada
Õpetaja: seal Iseenesest ei ole nagu midagi väga keerulist. Aga no ütleme niimoodi, et kui täitsa nagu ilma Ai, ta peaks õppima ja tegema, siis seal Ikkagi on keerukustaset küll üksjagu, sest setup on juba niuke.
Õpetaja: Aa, ei, okei.
Õpetaja: Kõik on oma lokaalses arvutis, nagu millest me siin räägime, Nagu
Õpetaja: et ega keegi ei saa praegu meie asjadele ligi. Vaata siin ühel või teisel viisil. No alati võimalik. Ee, kõik on võimalik. Muidugi elus vaja. Inimesest. Tuleb välja teine inimene.
Õpetaja: Stuff, Can Happen Ee, aga lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Lähme nüüd selle. Juurde. Jumal tänatud, et ta on jälle vähemalt Paigas on? Ei ole. Jälle ära hüplanud. Ei Tohiks seda ka ära tõsta.
Õpetaja: Posti pani lihtsalt sinna ühele jaole Ei, taha. Niimoodi, Ee,
Õpetaja: et Me nägime, et tegelikult me saame eduka vastuse, Tegeleb seda. See tähendab seda, et see käivitub.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on vaja hakata vaatama, et kuidas siin Den Blockis saab nüüd mingit progemist teha. Ja see suures pildis käib nii.
Õpetaja: Nüüd räägime sellest lambda asjast ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui see asi käivitub, Siis meil tegelikult on vaja kahte asja korraga teha.
Õpetaja: Siia on sisse progetud, et tegelikult see vastus kogu vastus kas sulgeda ja karvadega, mis Siis niiöelda serverist tuleb antud juhul Stop Light Is
Õpetaja: tuleb tegelikult ka siia blokki.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui ma soovin, kui ma soovin nüüd selle informatsiooniga midagi edasi teha, siis mida mul on vaja.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan programmis selle informatsiooniga midagi teha. Mis, mida mul on vaja.
Õpetaja: See respons tuleb. Ma Lihtsalt räägin. See respons tuleb siia. Aga ma nüüd saaksin edaspidi siin selle responsiga midagi teha. Mis on info? Lihtsalt mida mul on vaja.
Õpetaja: Vot väga hea, Meil on nüüd silti vaja. Meil on vaja muutujat. Siis kõige esimene asi, mis siia tuleks defineerida, on lihtsalt mingisugune nimi. Siin on. See süntaks. Jälle ei ole niimoodi, et paned lett ja mingi nimi. Aga siin on vaja ühte muutujanime.
Õpetaja: Minul meeldib selleks nimeks Response.
Õpetaja: Mida see süsteem, mida intellige pakub? Sa oleks value.
Õpetaja: Aa, mulle meeldib. Välju vaid response.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: nüüd see nüüd Nüüd järgneb sellele Landa Süntaks See tähendab Landa süntaks on niuke. Anonüümne sündaks. Kus niisuguse noolfunktsiooniga saab käivitada, et ee, tegevused tee midagi
Õpetaja: Sinna saab siis jälle kirjutada Koodi mis on niiöelda kood, et noh, koodi saab kirjutada,
Õpetaja: et, ee, mul on nagu see, et siin on see asi niimoodi ära tehtud Ja tihtipeale mujal. Ee muudes Landa niiöelda funktsioonides on samamoodi, et see see vasak pool siin praegu, enne niukest noolekest, mis on, ei ole Niimoodi noolekene
Õpetaja: vaid on siin juhul võrdusmärgiga. Noolekene
Õpetaja: toimib, niimoodi, et kui vastus tuleb. See on positiivne, käivitub Den Block siin Den Blocki sees, Nüüd käivitub niiöelda funktsiooniga. See on kirjaviis, mis on alati noolega.
Õpetaja: Niukene Nool. Noor süsteem. Ma pikalt. Jah, kes tahab? Ee, pange, sinna vaata, et mis asi on Lambda Funktsioon räägib sellest, nagu. Kuidas ta räägib sellest süntaksist tavaliselt.
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas. See toimib, saate vaadata, aga praegult on Niimoodi, et kui see asi käivitub, siis kogu niiöelda vastus läheb sellesse muutusse, mis on seal kirjas
Õpetaja: ja nüüd sellest noolest paremal pool, me Saame kirjutada Koodi ja teha Action It. Ja me saame kasutada seda objekti, mis on selle sildi taga.
Õpetaja: Siin sees ongi kogu vastus. Tähendab, Kui ma lähen, Kui ma korra praegult selle kustutan veel ära ja lähen või? Mul Vist on veel see inspektiga. Ma ei tea, kas Ta näitab mulle neid eelmiseid sõnumeid või mitte.
Õpetaja: Ei näita ma korra. Siis
Õpetaja: korra Lihtsalt veel. Tahan saada ühte sõnumit,
Õpetaja: kui ma vaatan siia peale ja kain ta nagu seda heedertabeli. Siis siin on mingisugust päris palju informatsiooni. Olete nõus,
Õpetaja: et see Stoplight ise ei vastand? Siin on Nagu mingisugused vaikimisasjad, mis on iga sõnumi puhul mingisugused osad, mis siit tuli Vastusena, mis tulid. Stop Light Ilt konkreetse vastusena.
Õpetaja: Kogu see, Staff Mida te kindel näete? Pluss veel mingi Ee. Response. Isegi Pay load.
Õpetaja: Kõik on tegelikult selles vastuses, mis internetist tuleb. Mida Brauser näeb?
Õpetaja: Näeme Meie programmis on mõte.
Õpetaja: Kõik see, mida iganes. Siin on palju Staffi, vaata. Ja nüüd ongi nagu see, et kogu see staff on nüüd selle sildiga seotud. Ja nüüd me saame temaga siit noolest edasi toimetada.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on selline asi, nagu te märkasite. Me tegelikult, ee, väga ebaharilikult Toimetame Ee, sulgude Sees.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlen seda. Me tahame koodi kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Midagi muud on vaja Aga ma ütlen seda. Vaata, et senikaua kuni me Toimetame ainult siin ühel ja samal real, et me ei taha nagu teha multi laine.
Õpetaja: Ee, pole mingit probleemi. Vaadake, kas kui siin all on Siin all Finalis on meil ka Landa funktsioon Siin Lihtsalt need tühjad sulud asendavad muutuja nime. Meil ei ole ühtegi. Meil ei ole Finalis ei kuku mingeid andmeid, millega saaks midagi teha.
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt käivita midagi. See on nagu anonüümne käivitus. See on koos objektiga Käivitus siin lihtsalt Näed, kõik ühel real oli. Vaata, on ju kenasti.
Õpetaja: Kui me tahame kirjutada üle mitme rea teksti
Õpetaja: ja lõpptulemus. See kindlasti nii ei ole. Nii ma ei tahaks teha.
Õpetaja: Siis Kuidas saab nii teha, kuidas programmeerimises järsku saab üle mitme rea mingisuguseid asju teha?
Õpetaja: Noh, vihjaks on ju Jälle ju Skoop, onju? Kus ta.
Õpetaja: Ja et nüüd on meie valikud. See, et kui me saame ühe real hakkama, käivitad mingi meetodi või asja. Siis on väga chillipilli. Siin kirjutad Selle meetodi, on kõik.
Õpetaja: Kui tahad. Üle mitme rea kirjutada, siis nii lugu enam ei ole.
Õpetaja: Davai Ee, nüüd mul on. Ma mõtlen seda. Vaata, ma ütlen kohe ära. Et lõpptulemus on see, et me Jumala eest ei taha kirjutada tegelikult siin mingisugust asja. Miljon rida siin. Kirjutada mingisuguseid asju. Miljon rida? Miks Sest et see, koodi loetavust rämedalt kannatab
Õpetaja: et lõpptulemus saab olema niikuinii Selline, et kõik on ühel real. Mida me. Siin ühel real teeksime? Siis on küsimus.
Õpetaja: Noh, nagu siingi oleks mõistlik lihtsalt käivitada mingisugune meetod
Õpetaja: Ma küsin teilt, kas Me hakkame siin kirjutama üle mitme rea ja lõpuks ekstraktime ja teeme sellest eraldi meetodi. Või me läheme seda teed pidi, et me nüüd praegult teeme ühe meetodi, mida me saame välja kutsuda ja
Õpetaja: jääb see üherealiseks, sest ma ütlen, et need kuramuse loogilised, Sulud on see, mis teeb selle asja veidi tüütuks.
Õpetaja: Kuidas teeme?
Õpetaja: Kas teeme niimoodi? Nagu Aa, nagu väiksed. Ütleme mingi kerge kogemusega arendaja või Või pigem me teeme niimoodi, et üritame midagi
Õpetaja: teha nagu vanakooli, et kirjutad siia väga mustalt ja siis hakkame seda lõhkuma
Õpetaja: terve meetodi Ma Pakun ka. Vaata sellepärast, et see on kole. Ja ma tahan, et te mõtleksite niikuinii sellise
Õpetaja: kui see asi siin on. Ee,
Õpetaja: ee, niiöelda Vaata, see. See tegevus, mis nüüd toimuma hakkab, ei ole enam selles mõttes väga ühekülgne. Üks tegevus
Õpetaja: taskis on tegelikult Räägitud. Päris palju asju. Me peame selle sõnumi kinni püüdma.
Õpetaja: Me peame sealt sõnumist võtma. Mingisugused väärtused. Me peame need väärtused. Kuhugi Ee ära salvestama Mäletad, et Session Storage Veits. Vaatasime Browser I sees. Niukene. Ütleme siis salajane koht.
Õpetaja: Ta ei ole salajane. Ta on hästi dokumenteeritud koht lausa ee, selles mõttes Ta ei ole kuidagi salajane. Aga nagu enamus inimest ei teagi, et mingi asi on.
Õpetaja: Me peame sinna andmeid panema ja me peame lõpuks Navigeerima uuele lehele. Point on see, mis ma üritan. Nagu öelda, on see, et siin ei saa olla niukest meetodit, nime, Vaata, mis, nagu Ütleks, et tee nüüd kuradi kolm miljonit asja
Õpetaja: Vaid nüüd. Me peame ütlema midagi hägusat. Clean Code ütleb seda, et ee, meetod peaks olema Võimalikult ee, täpne ja ütlema, mida ta teeb. On ju
Õpetaja: Aga meetod ütleb ka seda. Meetodi nime kohas ütleb Clean Code ka seda, et See meetodi nimi ei saa olla mingi kuradi viis kilomeetrit pikk ja lohiseb, et tee seda and too tooda and ja nii edasi. Vaata, on ju Seda Me ei saa teha.
Õpetaja: Et siin on nagu mingid reeglid, mis lähevad nagu vastu. Vaata, aga siin on ee mingid mõnusad nii öelda. Sõnad, mis tegelikult aitavad meil nagu seda asja ära. Ee, aitab sellest olukorrast nagu üle saada, et mi, mida me saaksime öelda, Ee, mis oleks? Aga ta otseselt ei ütle nagu päriselt, et mis toimub.
Õpetaja: Kui see tegevus on siin, login see sõnum on see, et Me Saadame Log in Requesti, Näete, mäletate? See objekt? Vaata, koos selle sisuga läheb ju kaasa. Kus? No vaata, see Payload Kust see tuli? See Pay load.
Õpetaja: See tuli sellest objektist. Ju on ju postsõnum Sellele rajale.
Õpetaja: Selle objektiga Siin on nii.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd me teeme põhimõtteliselt me Handleme. Hakkame seda probleemi Handlima.
Õpetaja: Siis siin me nüüd võiksimegi kirjutada. Kahtepidi. Kas me kirjuta? See on mul. Mulle meeldib seda ka. Ja me Võime teha niimoodi, et me kirjutame praegu siia meetodi, mida me justkui kutsume välja.
Õpetaja: Aga me veel ei ole isegi seda meetodit defineerimisel kirjutanud, Aga me anname intelligenile võimaluse natukene siis meie eest asju ära teha. Javas me teeme seda all. The Time, aga mul õudsalt mõnus on niimoodi läheneda. Ma küsin, kas siin all on kuskil praegult juba olemas. Niuke sõnum. Respons
Õpetaja: ei ole, onju.
Õpetaja: Ometi. Nüüd me just seda kavatseme teha.
Õpetaja: Me kavatseme kirjutada koodi, et me kutsume välja meetodid, mida tegelikult ei ole veel isegi kirjutatud eesmärgiga, et aitab meile selle põhja pärast ise teha. Saate mõttest aru. Seda ei ole olemas. See saab olema olemas. See on lihtsalt töövõte.
Õpetaja: Me saame seda igat pidi. Teha, Vaata ma saan tulla praegu siia alla kirjutada? Login, login, response Tulud
Õpetaja: võtab sisse, võtab sisse objekti
Õpetaja: ja sellist asja, nagu Ei ole. Hetkel aga Mina ei viitsi seda teha. Ühtepidi, Ma ei viitsi ka siia koodi teha. Extract Ida. See üldse on hästi probleemne. Nende loogiliste sulgude pärast Ma lihtsalt siin ütlen, kuidas ma kutsuksin. Mis selle meetodi nimi oli? Kujutame ette, et see meetod on siin. Kuidas ma seda välja kutsun?
Õpetaja: Bingo.
Õpetaja: Just this punkt. Nüüd ma kirjutan Handle, Login
Õpetaja: response ja me edaspidi jälgime täpi pealt seda sama mustrit. Sellepärast täpselt seda see teeb. Me Ei, soovi et see. Me ei soovi, et kogu see stahv läheb siin nagu jõle pikaks ära Õudsalt. Ee, kole asi oleks ei soovi,
Õpetaja: on nii?
Õpetaja: Okei, ee. Siis on see, et nüüd tulevad sulud ja nüüd on. Niimoodi, Vaadake
Õpetaja: kõik, mis toimub. Ma polegi sellest veel üldse Nagu rääkinud kogu info, mis meil siin kuskil ühel või teisel hetkel mingi muutuja mõttes tekib tema eluiga, miks ma jätsin teile see Objektide Life Cycle. Tema eluiga on siin selles meetodis
Õpetaja: sellest hetkest, kui ta tekib, kuidas responsiga Midagi viga, vä, aga seda pole kasutatud, Ee, Et, ee, praegult kogu see info elab meil siin. Aga meil hakkab toimima. Koodilõik, mis asub siin all.
Õpetaja: See koodilõik on täiesti eraldiseisev meetod, mis Ei tea oma välisest elust mitte ööd ega mütsi.
Õpetaja: See tähendab seda, et see info, mis meil siin selles sulgude vahel hetkel on, Selles muutujas selle selle niiöelda. Ee, selle niiöelda sildi ja muutuja eluiga koos. Objektiga, on alates sellest hetkest siin,
Õpetaja: kuni ta jõuab selle teise Suluni, siis ta on kutu.
Õpetaja: Välja arvatud loomulikult, kui sa käivitad mingisuguse tegevuse see käivitub, aga siis ongi see asi, et see meetod ei tea sellest asjast Mitte ööd ega mütsi. Juhul, kui me ei anna seda sama responsi objekti talle väljakutsumisel kaasa. Saate mõttes aru
Õpetaja: See tuleb Eraldi koodilõik, kus on ära kirjeldatud, mis peab toimuma. Jälle klassikaline ee meetod. Sisend väljund.
Õpetaja: Ma Tahan käivitada mingisuguse tegevuse aga sellel tegevusel on vaja infot. Lõppkokkuvõttes on meil vaja teada, mis on, su user Id. Ja mis on su
Õpetaja: seda meil on vaja teada. Vaata, see on See responsi sees.
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd, kui me tuleme siia, siis ta on jooninud meile praegu. Nüüd on. Ta on selle jooninud alla kollane joon Ja vasakule tekkis Kollane pirn on nii?
Õpetaja: Kui ma kuskilt teen mingisuguse reakati korra.
Õpetaja: Siin on punane joon.
Õpetaja: Kui ta oskaks midagi pakkuda, tuleb Punane pirn Praegu ta on vales kohas. Kollane joon kollane pirn. Kui ma tuleks praegu selle pirni peale ja klikiks,
Õpetaja: ja siin ta näitab Ka mis on? Vaata, siin ta ütleb. Vaata, Unresold. Sõnad selles kontekstis Tähendab, et ei leia. Ei, ei saa aru, millele sa viitad,
Õpetaja: Millele Sa viitad Tööd Pole olemas.
Õpetaja: Vaata, mis ta siin pakub. Nupuna juba. Great Function Property Loo uus Funktsioone Actions. Veel rohkem Action Eid on veel ka siin all. Aga põhiline asi on see, et see More Actions tegelikult ongi juba see, Mis see tähtede kombinatsioon siin on
Õpetaja: see Pirn, mida? Ma võin tulla siit niimoodi näppima lahti.
Õpetaja: Ma lähen selle pirikese peale. See on alt Enter.
Õpetaja: Me ei tule. Kes see on
Õpetaja: vaenlane. Praegult on ta meil vaenlane. Meil just käpad. Olid mõnusad siin peal. Me just kirjutasime selle koodilõigu alt. Enter Vahet pole, kas kollane Piir
Õpetaja: Ee, punane pirn. Rohelist pirni. Ma pole veel kunagi näinud. Ee, ei tea, kas siin on või ei. Ole nüüd, ta küsib Põhimõtteliselt Me iga kord teeme selle pirni ja selle selle ee, probleemi niiöelda lahti ja vaatame, mida pakub. Mis? Ta ütleb, et loon sellise funktsiooni,
Õpetaja: Vajutad entrit
Õpetaja: peale Nelikümmend kaks. Ta toppis selle siia kõige alla. Tuli teile ka kuskile, no Kuhu iganes ta toppis Tegin niukse meetodi
Õpetaja: pani siia sisse, muutuja. Ee respons.
Õpetaja: Ja hetkel ta return. Ib on. Ta ei osanud midagi rohkem edasi teha, Vaata, sest et, noh,
Õpetaja: kus ta peaks teadma, mis me tahame Teha Vajate mentorit. Võite mentorit. Te võite selle Return I ära. See on ka fine. Meil ei ole midagi returnida. Siin meetodis Me niikuinii tõmbame dieetselt varsti. Kui kõik asjad on olemas, läheme ära siit.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on meil olemas see meetod
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt Ja seda oli lihtsam teha niimoodi, et niikuinii sa pead selle koodi kirjutama. Noh, oleks niipidi alustada, aga tegelikult on lihtsam niimoodi seda teha, Sest Siin me programmeerime. Me oleme mõttelõngaga. Vaata, seo kaasas. Nagu, mida me tahame teha.
Õpetaja: Me tahame hakata seda responsi niiöelda ära handlida, et Mis peab kõik soi toimuma Aga loomulikult me ei tee seda siin virrvarris. Kogu see asi peab jääma nii lühikeseks kui vähegi võimalik, mida Lühem seda parem
Õpetaja: Okei, nii see Aa. Siin segab, onju? Ee. Siis võime toimetada edasi.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd võiks natukene. Vaadata. Nüüd hakkab see asi veits Lappesse minema, et meil on see peamine menüü,
Õpetaja: mitte peamine. Peamine meetod, login.
Õpetaja: Ee, esimene meetod, mis siit välja kutsutakse, on reset message Siis idee järgi võiks justkui olla niimoodi, et esimene meetod, mis siin selles järjekorras on? Võiks olla reset message. Aga ma ütlen kohe ära Reset message võiks nagu nii paljudes kohtades olla, et ta võiks ka tihtipeale olla. Mitmed erinevad funktsionaalsused võivad seda kasutada, on ju
Õpetaja: mina, nagu Vaatan, et tegelik asi, mis siin esimene meetod on, mis? Nagu on nii,
Õpetaja: siis ma teeks niimoodi. Vaadake, mul üks peale seda nagu mingi rämedaid ee, reavahetusi, et vaata, et ta oleks alla poole.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd mina hakkaks tegema niimoodi, et ma hakkaks siit vaatama, et paneks nad Natukene viisakamalt siia alla. Järjekorda. Nüüd ma leian ülesse selle Allfields Have Input on vist esimene meetod, Mis on abimeetod, Mäletate? Kohvi Machiin
Õpetaja: Ee Getwater ja mingi Milk. Ja mis iganes, onju, see on ka enda sestav,
Õpetaja: et siis võiks teha niimoodi et nüüd hoiad kontrollil peal ja Vaatad, et klikid sinna, kohta Et kus see meetod on?
Õpetaja: See meetod on siin, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma tuleks ja teeks niimoodi, et ma Võtan ta lihtsalt Cutiga siit ära
Õpetaja: ja tuleks siia ülesse ja Paneks. Selle meetodi järgi. No jätad mingi reavahetuse ka? Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Me Tahame nüüd nagu see raamatu lugemine, et see nüüd natukene. Võibolla mõni mõtleb, et see on mingi. Ocd. No, mingil määral ühest hetkest, ta võib natukene ajuvabaks minna ka, et sa üritad. Ma ei tea nii ilusti kõik järjekorda panna, et palju seal siis väga vahet on, aga tegelikult. Päris Production koodis. Ikka mingisugune elementaarne ee järjestus võiks asjadel olla.
Õpetaja: No siin on jälle. Vaata start. Spinners. Topspinner on minu minu jaoks Niisugused meetodid, mis võib mitmes kohas mitu korda küsida? Ma jätaks nad lihtsalt lõppu.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleb alles päris asi. Vaata, mis on mingi järgmine Meetod, mis võiks olla nagu kuskil siin all, on Nii
Õpetaja: see võiks tulla siis siia. Sellest alla. On ju, et oleks umbes samas järjekorras.
Õpetaja: Selle asjaga ei pea nüüd nii tohutult anaalne olema. Vaata aga, nagu lihtsalt suures pildis. Asjad võiksid ikkagi olla. Enamvähem tasub siia see koma ka panna. Ära vaata, ta on ta viimaseks toppinud ja koma pole, et me topime ta kuhugi ülesse. Nüüd
Õpetaja: samamoodi. Võtame lihtsalt kapiga ära ja tuleme. Paneme lihtsalt siia järtsu.
Õpetaja: Põmm.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd ta sõi ära. Kõik muud read oli nii?
Õpetaja: Ma Ei, Ole nõus sellega. Aa, esmaspäevaks Kodutöö kellelegi.
Õpetaja: Ee, nuputada Välja kuidas settingutest saab selle jama maha panna?
Õpetaja: Ta kogu aeg sööb ridu ära vaatad. Ma just tegin meelega Need Read ju ennem. Oli Niimoodi oli Jah,
Õpetaja: mööda.
Õpetaja: Jah, et, ee, et see on. Midagi See on nagu mingi uus ee, mille tahaks maha keerata,
Õpetaja: aga okei. Ee, suures pildis. Ülejäänud asjad, mis tulevadki. Startspinner, Stopspinner reset. Nad võivadki kuskil seal all. Olla. Ee, Mis taas. Järjekorras et Praegult on nüüd järjekorras. Kus te mõttest saite aru viisakas on? Nagu enamvähem, nagu No ma arvan, paljud on teist nagu kes panevad oma
Õpetaja: Riidekapi värvide või suuruste järgi. Asjad või kombinatsioon nendest käsi püsti.
Õpetaja: Okei, poole. Riidega appi. Noh, vot see on lihtsam variant, Ee, ma viskan, Kuidas
Õpetaja: võib olla võib olla. Ee. Nüüd me teame, et Triin lihtsalt viskab oma asjad lihtsalt kuidagi võssa. Lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Jah. Võibolla peaks See ei ole Tegelikult, ee. Eelduseks, et muidugi Ocd ju, et sa oled nagu mingi see tegelt ei ole. Ka Mõned inimesed lähevad hulluks mingisuguste asjadega, et kuskil on see piir. Ka Ma niuke ei ole. By the way ma, Olen tegelikult ikka suht notsu. Mingid. Taldrikud asjad
Õpetaja: mulle. Meeldib ka mingid mingid.
Õpetaja: Kõik peab olema süsteemne. Järjestatud.
Õpetaja: Jah, aga
Õpetaja: ma. Ma võin olla näiteks. Ma võin olla nagu mingi perfektsionist, näiteks selle aiamaja ehitusega, et ma jään mingeid millimeetreid taga.
Õpetaja: Aga kui kedagi kodus pole? Isegi kui on kodus, et ma söön ära ja mingi taldrik kahvel jäävad sinna laua peale. Ma lähen lihtsalt kuhugi teleka taha. Siis nagu I Dont Care,
Õpetaja: et ee, mul naine on muidugi nende kuradi kapi ustega. Vaata, kapiuksed ei tohi kuskilt köögist või midagi lahti olla, et teda mingi. Ta läheb hulluks,
Õpetaja: Aga siis ma tean ka muidugi, mis teha. Vaatad, et kuluks ajada et vaid, on niisama meelega ka.
Õpetaja: Ee, mis me nüüd tahame selle responsiga teha, on see, et hetkel ta Niimoodi kasutult. Ee Segab
Õpetaja: mida segab või seisab
Õpetaja: Aa, aega. Natuke kraami võrra vähe. Aga võibolla ma arvan, et oleks vahepeal aeg teepuuk teha ka, et natukene nagu seda Flow D vaadata. Ainult teie jaoks.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma tulen siia loo kinni. Juurde.
Õpetaja: Kirjutan siia loog.
Õpetaja: Ma Võibolla teen ka praegu komiiti ära. Kas keegi tahab järgi tulla või mitte?
Õpetaja: Ee, ma teen üksteist. Tulge sama kaua järgi. Ma panen ta push ima ära.
Õpetaja: Ee, panen ta push ima Ja siis ma panen. Ee, samal ajal hakkan tee pugima.
Õpetaja: Pushing pushing. Ma kirjutan siia lihtsalt ühe rea juurde loog Malli loog templiga konsol. Loog.
Õpetaja: Jällegi mõtled, et tee pugida? Lihtsalt ma saaks hästi lihtsalt nagu minna niuksesse kohta kus ma saan Klikkida neid Break Point E, Siis see on lihtsalt nagu kõige lihtsam viis.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma tavaliselt lihtsalt panengi. Kirjutan siia,
Õpetaja: Olen siin ja rohkem Mul Ei olegi vaja.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis ma tulen Ee. Serverisse. See peabki lahti olema. Ee, võtan konsooli siit ülevalt Teen võibolla Clear lihtsalt,
Õpetaja: ee, Väike Refresh taustal.
Õpetaja: Aa Aa, mida iganes vaid ta on. Loogin sisse. Tuli See olen si, Olen siin. Ma lihtsalt tahan seda. Login View Real Kümme
Õpetaja: Tõmban. Natukene kokku võibolla. Et, siin saaks mõlemal pool veits toimetada mis. See watcher, Mine,
Õpetaja: Niimoodi umbes. On see sama vähemalt, Sama Klass on on ju Kus ta on Siin
Õpetaja: konsol Loog ongi kümme ma. Panen siia break Point E Niimoodi järjest
Õpetaja: ee saab ka teistsuguseid nuppe vajutada, et ma ei peaks nii palju panema neid Break Point E, Aga ma praegult ka enda. Tahan seda teha.
Õpetaja: Ah Ee, ennem, Kui pole millelegi seisma jääda,
Õpetaja: pole millelgi seisma jääda, Siis ma lihtsalt korra teen seda. Ma panen. Midagi Peab siia kirjutama, et ma saaks panna. Ma panen alert.
Õpetaja: Panen. Ee, yes, mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Ee, yes. Ja saan siia ka break point I panna. Nii, nüüd ma olen selleks Põhimõtteliselt valmis. Ma panen siia. Aa Paneme siia. Pbb. Siis on nad erinevad Dbb ja panen logi. Sisse. Nüüd, kui ma vajutan, seda, siis Teepuger jääb seal seisma.
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt on see, et message. No ma nii pikalt ei viitsi. Ma lähen sellest mööda. Mind Ei, huvita, kõik väljad on korrektsed ja. Ja ma võin korra panna Break Point I näidata, et ta kukub siia. Kui ma vajutan, Me oleme praegu. Seisame siin, Kui ma vajutan play. Ta jääb lihtsalt siin seisma. Kuna siin on see breakpoint, onju?
Õpetaja: Mõtlen, mine edasi, Nüüd on sõnumi saatmine.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ei tea, kas ma siia saan. Break Point I panna. Aa, ta on ühel real. Me näeme kohe Seda Ma panen. Play
Õpetaja: jääb siia seisma. See tähendab seda, et Sten Block käivitus.
Õpetaja: Me saime ee stop lightilt mingi vastuse ja nüüd kutsutakse Siis välja. Aga enne kui ma Kutsun välja, siis vaatame. Ee, aa, vot. Kui hea oleks üle rea, see rida veel ei ole käivitunud. Ma ei saa seda responsi siin näidata, mis siin sees juba on.
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma panen nüüd Next? Mul ei ole õrna. Kuhu ta läheb? Ta ikkagi läheb praegu sinna sisse. Vaatame nüüd seda responsi. Nüüd ma saan näha.
Õpetaja: See on nüüd kogu see vastus koos sulgede ja karvadega. Mis? Ee, mulle siis nagu Ee, server vastas Siin on mingi konfig, mäletad? Me vaatasime, vaata et sealt. Mingi mingisugust. Igasugused andmed olid. Mis oli seal näha
Õpetaja: headerid, asjad, Mida iganes, onju, Mis meid näete, Status kakssada. Näete status kakssada status tekst. Vaata, sellel on ka tekstiline vastend. Okei,
Õpetaja: nüüd, mis meid huvitab Sellest responsist ei ole, kogu see respons vaid meid huvitab see Respons Data, meid huvitab andmed, mis ta meile anna vastab.
Õpetaja: Näete, siin on Niukene blokk. Data,
Õpetaja: Kui kogu see asi on Responsi objekt ja ma tahaks tulla siia sügavamale. Kuidas ma programmiliselt seda saan teha?
Õpetaja: Tegin loogilise Request. Iga tegime username Ja kuidas saab sügavamale minna?
Õpetaja: Punkt? Ee, see oleks Kand Ainult läks minema. Ma pean hooerdama uuesti. Siin on kandja Selle lahti tegemine on punkt.
Õpetaja: Siin sees on väljad Role, name, admin ja user Id üks. See on. Mis Toplight saatus mulle
Õpetaja: nüüd see ongi. See. Meid ei huvita see ülejäänud mudru. Meid maksimaalselt huvitab see data siin kontekstis Ja kui on Error olukord, siis huvitab ka võibolla Staatuse kood, onju See kogu objekt läheb sinna response.
Õpetaja: Nii, ma nüüd panen selle kinni
Õpetaja: ja Tulen tagasi koodi. Nende kaasategemise kohta
Õpetaja: otsib ülesse. Põhimõtteliselt siis selle handel. Ee, Wifi vale projekt.
Õpetaja: Ee, Tahan võtta pank. Nelikümmend. Üks on ju. Me tuleme siia.
Õpetaja: Kui me nüüd tuleme siia, Siis me saame vaadata ka
Õpetaja: lihtsalt esialgu. Esialgu Alert. Lihtsalt alert.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen response. Miks ma siin ei ütle this punkt response,
Õpetaja: sest et See on kohalik muuta. Mille poole ma pöördun? Ma lihtsalt viitan sellele nimele.
Õpetaja: Data blokis. Mul ei ole mingisugust Ee. Responset ei ole ju Maint. Login Request ja siis need asjad siin vastab tõele.
Õpetaja: Nii Ja kui mina tahaks lihtsalt praegult user Id D välja printida, siis mis Ma peaksin tegema.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate? Just nägime, et kuhu Ma pean edasi minema.
Õpetaja: Mind ei huvita konflik. Mind ei huvita staatus. Mind ei huvita staatust, eks? Mind ei huvita request. Mind huvitab.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis see vastus ise.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see vastus ise koos oma sulgede ja karvadega on praegult hetkel objekt
Õpetaja: siin. Ee, vastus tuli Jasonina. Aga nüüd on ta juba objektiks, et seda asja korra näha. Ma võtan, see on võibolla korra vaatamise koht. Ma ütlen, et Kuule, Jason, klass. Siin on meetod Stringify, mis suudab teha mistahes objekti. Lihtsalt stringi kujuks.
Õpetaja: Vot siia, sisse, Ma panen selle respons data ja vaatame, mis nüüd Alerti tuleb.
Õpetaja: Nii mina tulen, bla, bla, bla, bla, blabla. Panen logi sisse. Alerti Tuli
Õpetaja: Jason User Id. Üks rollname. Admin on nii
Õpetaja: Kui Nopad Is lööks selle kuidagi ilusaks.
Õpetaja: No nuppad on mul siin. Teisel ekraanil
Õpetaja: on selline sõnum See on see näidi näi. Üks näidistest, mis sealt on võimalik, mis tuleb praegu vaikimisi, saadab selle, mis on vaikimisi usein.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis Me praegu just põhimõtteliselt siis nagu veendusime, et, ee, meil on olemas kõik. See informatsioon,
Õpetaja: mida meile Back end saadab, Response data sees, on ta olemas.
Õpetaja: Niimoodi saame kätte andmed.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on siis selline asi, et
Õpetaja: kui ma programmiliselt peale vaatan, kui. Kui kujutage ette, et te tulete Lihtsalt nagu nüüd Ee, arendaja, kes pole päevi seda koodi niiöelda, näinud
Õpetaja: et kui te näeksite seda respons. Data T,
Õpetaja: kas te teaksite praegult, Et mis sealt? Tuli Ma mõtlen ideeliselt. User Id ja role
Õpetaja: siit failist seda kuidagi välja ei loe.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on nüüd siis selline mõte Mis Ee, nüüd Teistes kohtades hakkab lausa mitut probleemi korraga lahendama, on see, et
Õpetaja: kui hea oleks see, et meil oleks sellest asjast mingisugune Mudel ja arusaam. Isegi lihtsalt siit sellest koodifailist vaadates
Õpetaja: oleks aru saanud, et mis sealt tuli?
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mis meil oleks vaja? Mis te arvate, Mida oleks vaja,
Õpetaja: kui ma ütlen? Mudel andmemudel, mida võiks teha,
Õpetaja: ei ole kellelgi mitte mõtet.
Õpetaja: No aivar. Sul on igast häid mõtteid, aga Kogu aeg ei ole.
Õpetaja: Teil on palju vaikselt. Jah, siin on see, koht kus võiks teha siia ühe uue muutuja.
Õpetaja: Kui see on Login Request Username ja Password. Siis mis meie võiksime teha?
Õpetaja: Meie võiks teha täpselt samasuguse asja.
Õpetaja: Ainult et login.
Õpetaja: Ee, sponsor.
Õpetaja: Kool on nüüd tema on objekt Kus sees on? Väljad, user, Id ja Rolname user. Id.
Õpetaja: Kool on nüüd. Siin on väike väärtused. Vaata, see. See peaks lihtsalt andma meile arusaama, et mis tüüpi info siin käib? Mis tüüpi info Käib? Siin numbri all.
Õpetaja: Numbri all. User Id all Ilmselt number. Siis Kuidas me saaksime seda hästi neutraalselt väljendada, et siin selles objektis käivad numbrid. Aga me ei pane nagu mingit kindlat väärtust
Õpetaja: null, kui siin on tühistring.
Õpetaja: Siis siin võiks olla mingi number. Aga vaata, Mingi niuke asi oleks väga arusaamatu et mis mis siin mõeldud on lihtsalt null
Õpetaja: oma teine väli on role. Name
Õpetaja: Siin võiks samamoodi anda indikatsiooni, Et mis tüüpi info siin käib? Mis? Tüüpi info siin käib?
Õpetaja: String, onju? Aga mingit kindlat väärtust ei pane. Siis tuleb lihtsalt tühist ring, on ju
Õpetaja: nii? Nüüd on meil mingisugune mängumaa ja ma ütlen, et praegult on Lihtsalt see, et ee. Ma ütlen, et meil kuskil kuvada ja seda infot ei oleks vaja. Oleks vaja kuskil kuvada infot.
Õpetaja: Jällegi, mis on meie. Vaata, nende kahe maailma vahel. On ju? Saadame sõnumi. Saame andmeid. Kui tahad kuvada, siis oleks olnud möödapääsmatu. Ma oleks pean mingi mingi muutuja niikuinii tegema.
Õpetaja: Aga siin on nagu päris Mitu head asja, et edaspidi tulebki olukordi, kus me peame siis ka mingi andmetega midagi toimetama. Noh, anna mulle linnade nagu need. Ee. Jason, vaata, kus on kõik linnad. Nagu siis sa pead kuhugi panema. Miks mul on seda Dropdown is vaja Kuvada. Aga siin on nagu nüüd see hea asi, et
Õpetaja: me nüüd saame põhimõtteliselt teha niimoodi, et kui vastab tõele see Tegelikult idee järgi võiks täiesti tühi olla
Õpetaja: lihtsalt objekt. Vahet pole, sest, et see sisu ei tule programmiliselt. See sisu tuleb väljastpoolt,
Õpetaja: mis siia tegelikult tuleb, Ongi see, mis siia tegelikult tuleb. Siin on üks probleem sellega. Pugid võivad väga lihtsalt tulla.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis meie. Nüüd, kus me Oleme nagu selles koodilõigus, kus me saime selle sõnumi kätte?
Õpetaja: Siin Meie võiksime nüüd teha niimoodi, et kõige esimese sammuna, kui me saame selle responsi,
Õpetaja: siis selle vaata niiöelda selle. Jason I. Me püüame kinni sellesse muutujasse,
Õpetaja: sest et siis on meil tegelikult olemas ka kooditasandil viide, Vaata, et mis see responsepunkt Data endast hõlmab.
Õpetaja: Ta hõlmab user Id D ja Role Name I
Õpetaja: Ehk me tuleme siia koodi reale ja ütleme, Kui ma tahan mingit uut väärtust anda sellele, mis ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Just, kes?
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab talle mingit väärtust anda?
Õpetaja: See on kõige sildikene, onju Noh, kuidas saab anda väärtust? Talle võrdub
Õpetaja: nii. Ja me nüüd just vaatasime, kust saab kätte põhimõtteliselt selle, Jason, I mis ma nüüd siia Kirjutan,
Õpetaja: mis tuli. Näed, sõnum läks teele. Post tuli õnnelik juhus Saadi vastus
Õpetaja: ja pandi see kenasti siia meetodisse kaasa. Kogu vastus. Asub, siin Kogu vastus ka sulgeda ja karvadega,
Õpetaja: mis ma siia kirjutan. Ma ei taha kogu vastust. Ma tahan ainult ühte osa sealt.
Õpetaja: Kui sa ütled, siis praegu Vaadake, Mängumaa on väga lühikene. Sellest ma hakkan ka rääkima. Korra. Ma korra räägin sellest.
Õpetaja: Vaadake Kui te asute kuskil meetodis kuskil Koodireal siis on niimoodi,
Õpetaja: et selleks hetkeks, kus teie praegult olete, Oma niiöelda selle ee. Koodi kirjutamisel
Õpetaja: siis teie kogu mängumaa on kõik, mis on olnud enne seda koodirida. No, kui ma hakkan siit pihta. Vaata, onju.
Õpetaja: Kõik, mis on minu mängumaa.
Õpetaja: Isegi lausa siit on praegu see
Õpetaja: Kõik, mis on siin meetodis olemas, näiteks. No ütleme siis pigem nagu niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Kõik, mis on nagu siin olemas, pluss välised asjad millele saab igalt poolt ligi See on minu mängumaa.
Õpetaja: Noh, ma lihtsalt praegu siin olen. Vaata, Meil on küsimus et kus ma saan nagu selle vastuse, Keegi ütles loogiline respons, Aga loogiline respons. Selle me anname. Sisu.
Õpetaja: See on lihtsalt. See on silt. See on lihtsalt sildile viitamine.
Õpetaja: Siis mängumaa on meil praegu väga lühikene respons.
Õpetaja: Punkt, Data. Sellepärast, et me tegelikult tahame saada kätte ainult seda datat. Ennast
Õpetaja: juba Praegult saame katsetada, et Kas see asi töötab?
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen ka, et tegelikult poleks vahet. Nagu ma mõtlen, nagu. Tehniliselt ma võin sealt data blokist üldse kustutada. Ära selle mudeli osa.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et programmist ta oma sisu saab niikuinii ainult väljapoolt,
Õpetaja: et et vahet pole, mida ma siia kirjutan, ma võin isegi panna. Talle on väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Jah, lehte laadides on loogi. See on Java Jaavascript Onju? Läbumaa
Õpetaja: lehte laadides on loogiline spons I väärtus truu,
Õpetaja: niipea Kui ta jõuab Aa oma koodireal. Aa, siia. Reale, kus sa oled?
Õpetaja: Kurat, ma teen. Nagu, Loodan, et ta jälle ei tee niimoodi nii pea. Kui ma jään siia reale, siis ta saab niikuinii uue sisu siiamaani. Lehte laadides on ta truu väärtus, aga järsku ta saab hoopis Mingisuguse objekti Vaata, onju?
Õpetaja: Objekti saab ja seotakse see, sellega, et lõppkokkuvõttes sisu tuleb siit. Aga palju parem on ikkagi. See,
Õpetaja: No kus Ee Datablokk on. Kas ta nüüd Ee Control Z, Control, Z, control, Z, Control Z.
Õpetaja: Palju parem on loomulikult see, kui ta ei ole truu, Vaid ta peegeldab meile mudelit, mis sealt teoreetiliselt tuleb. Aga siin on üks väike oht ka.
Õpetaja: Kui see on back end, tuleb see kui Back end Is on? Niukene struktuur, user, Id ja Role. Name siis praegu selle plaaniga. Me kõik, mis me siin progeme, töötab hästi, kui Seal Back end is. Näiteks user. Id on hoopis nüüd väikse täiega
Õpetaja: päriselt mis sisse, tuleb. Aga siin mudelis on ta valesti.
Õpetaja: Mis sina, Programmeerid. Kõik oma sammud. Nagu selle info kohaselt, siis ta ei tööta.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult ei ole seal sees. User Id väikse täega vaid on suure tähega. Pigem on see, et backend Id. Noh, see oli nagu mingi. Nagu Taipo näide. Nagu. Aga pigem on see niimoodi, et te progete, Teete asjad ära, aga ühel hetkel otsustate, et teeme backendis mingi teenuse natukene ringi.
Õpetaja: See peab Alati hoidma meeles, vaata, et nüüd te peate mõtlema Frontendile, et kui te juba Frontend is seda teenust kasutasite, siis te peate üles otsima kõik need kohad
Õpetaja: ja vaatame üle tegema siin Samasugused parandused. Tavaliselt on see nime muutused eelkõige. Ja see on see pugikoht
Õpetaja: Alguses panete kuidagi natuke pikemalt ja pärast otsustate, et tegelikult teeks Natuke lühemat, aga vastupidi alguses teete väga, väga lühidalt. Pane mingi nime hiljem, saate aru. Vaata, et hästi. Parem on ikkagi natukene pikemalt seda nime panna.
Õpetaja: Kui te teete alguses back end I ja te pole veel Frontend I teinud, siis on kama. Kaks Vaata, saate seal tuhat korda mõelda. Vaata, kuidas nagu teete. Vaata, on ju? Aga kui te olete juba implementatsiooni teinud ja teenust kasutanud kuskil frontend is
Õpetaja: see kipub tulema ka niimoodi. Nagu Vaata, et inimesed töötavad tiimis. Keegi tegi. Keegi tegi. Mingid asjad lähevad edasi. Mingil hetkel. Keegi hakkab midagi korrastama. Teeb korda ja unustab. Vaata, ära vaata,
Õpetaja: ma toimetan hästi palju siin Back end Is aga unustab ära, et frondis. On see võibolla kasutatud üks Viga Muidugi ei tohiks juhtuda. Kui sa hakkad mingisugust teenust muutma, siis sa pead kindlasti sellele mõtlema. Kas Sellel on juba mingit kasutust, kuskil programm leidnud. Noh, lähed teed Frondi kataloogi lahti ja lähed Vaatad või kontrolli F Ja mis iganes onju, et seda peab jälgima,
Õpetaja: juba praegu saab kontrollida ka, et kas selline asi tõesti siis töötab? Vaata, et. Et meie. Meil, see. Ee, samune. Ee päriselt saab siis ee, sellest Ee, stoplight Ist selle sisu kätte. Kuidas ma saaksin juba praegu vaadata ja testida? Kas see tõesti toimib,
Õpetaja: Et kas login? Respons Is on See info user Id, üks ja browserist. Okei, õige, Ja Fresh.
Õpetaja: Jaa, pole vahet pole, mida ma siia kirjutan. Stoplight vast saab alati samamoodi Okei, aga kuidas? Brauserist Aitäh, inspekt.
Õpetaja: Konsoolist ei saa teada.
Õpetaja: Voeäpp, Mul on muidugi mingid break point Id, mis? Nad hakkavad kohe siin jamama Niikuinii onju? Aga voe vajutan. Aa, ma teen kavalalt. Ma panen selle korra kinni. Panen loovi. Sisse
Õpetaja: Midagi ei toimunud. Justkui, onju?
Õpetaja: Tead, inspekt, teed. Poe, tuled. Log in view.
Õpetaja: Näete, siin Ee, datablokk.
Õpetaja: Data blokis on login. Request. Aa on respons.
Õpetaja: Teeme responsi lahti.
Õpetaja: On user Id Üks head meel tuli.
Õpetaja: Noh, okei, kui nüüd. Ee. Taas põhimõtteliselt ütleb meile. Lähme korra, vaatame taaski ka üle. Triljon aasta, onju? Ee, räägib, et kui kõik väljad on täidetud, saadetakse sõnum koos Requestiga. Saadetud, saadetud, saadetud backhand tagastab selle järgnevates formaatide ees. Noh, see on sama formaat Onju? Näited on erinevad
Õpetaja: ja error ka. Nüüd räägib edukast päringust. Vastusest saadud User. Id salvestatakse Session Storage faili võtmega User Id ehk põhimõtteliselt See väärtus peab nüüd jääma meile kuhugi, et kui me siit vaatelt tõmbame, otse tuli ka.
Õpetaja: Aa, et, ee, Kui me läheme siit nagu minema. Vaata, on ju siis meil. Kaovad kõik need asjad ära.
Õpetaja: Aga me ei saa seda lubada.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see koht on siin. See programmeerimise Koht
Õpetaja: Control V. Kõik on naljakas nagu. No mul on nii hea meel, nagu see oli väärt seda.
Õpetaja: Nii See on meie too vastuses Saadud user Id väärtust salvestatakse session storage faili alla võtmega User Id
Õpetaja: Session Storage.
Õpetaja: Pakkuge sõna. Mis ma siia kirjutan.
Õpetaja: No võiks olla küll. Nii, Session Storage.
Õpetaja: No Tom. On ka siin jälle platsis näha. Kuidagi tema ka siin toimetab
Õpetaja: keegi, kes saab näpid ja asja väike Tom Mapivation Ee
Õpetaja: on nüüd tegelikult objekt. Objektil on meetodid. Kuidas saab meetodeid välja kutsuda?
Õpetaja: Tegi niimoodi punkt. Jah,
Õpetaja: siin mingid meetodid paistavad. Ee, mis võiks kõnetada, kui räägitakse, et user Id väärtust salvestatakse. Session Store faili võtmega User Id
Õpetaja: kett. Aitem Mm,
Õpetaja: väärtus salvestatakse
Õpetaja: set item kett aitam On see, kui sul juba on seal midagi ja sa võtme järgi. Tahad seda kätte saada? Väärtust.
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, siis, Clear, Pakkuge, mis see teeb Session Storage. Clear
Õpetaja: tühjendab kogu ära kätteaitamist. Rääkisime Remove item, mis võtab sisse Key Stringi kujul. Mida see võiks teha,
Õpetaja: eemaldab konkreetse ühe Niiöelda võtme sealt sellest Sessionstory ist koos oma väärtusega. Mitu parameetrit võtab sisse?
Õpetaja: Kaks tükki, mis ta võtab. Sisse Ideeliselt mitte nagu tüübid
Õpetaja: võtme Ja väärtuse. Me saame ise defineerida mingisuguse võtme ja väärtuse. Nüüd pange tähele. Mis need tüübid mõlemal on?
Õpetaja: Nii see tähendab seda vaata. Et, Noh, eesmärk on loomulikult, et me tahame siis siia. Session Storage is Ee application I alt. Jätate selle ülesse et plaan on siia midagi salvestada
Õpetaja: Sa võid panna siia q User
Õpetaja: Id Ja Panna siia väärtuse numbri kümme
Õpetaja: aga see. Siin on puhas tekstifail
Õpetaja: key ja. Value mõlemad on. See Isegi kui me paneme sinna numbri, siis arvestage, et tegelikult taustal saab ikkagi olema.
Õpetaja: String, See avaldub sellel hetkel, kui me võtame siit andmeid Sa võid võtta. Siit true.
Õpetaja: Sa võid võtta siit kümme sa. Võid võtta siit
Õpetaja: ma. Ei tea admin, On kõik tekst
Õpetaja: kui, Sa tahad nüüd edasi toimetada normaalselt nende asjadega, Siis sa pead nad teisendama vastavasse tüüpi.
Õpetaja: Nii saime aru, et on set item
Õpetaja: Noh, kontroll B toob jälle välja. Vaata, mida ta siia ootab. Sisse
Õpetaja: võti, mis meil võti peab olema?
Õpetaja: No tõstame korra selle siia alla, Vaata et Nad on nagu selles. Järjekordselt Me toimetame praegu sellega. Siin on ju
Õpetaja: User Id. Nii, mis ma nüüd siia kirjutan
Õpetaja: Ja kuidas ma seda kirjutan, on pigem see, küsimus, mis ma üritan suunata. Siis mis seal sisse pead minema?
Õpetaja: Kuidas this user Id?
Õpetaja: Kui ma lähen vaatan data bloki, siis ma ei näe siin kuskil. Ee, user, Id, D
Õpetaja: ja Bingo. See on see sama asi, mida me tahame. Pra. See on meie enda välja mõeldud. Vaata, see ei ole. Need ei ole andmed veel. See on võti, millega, me kavatse identifitseerida.
Õpetaja: Seda väärtust siin paneme Ma pärast korjame üles.
Õpetaja: Siin taaskis on öeldud, et see peab olema.
Õpetaja: Võti peab olema user Id. Aga nüüd on küsimus, et kuidas seda saab siia kirjutada String Ina. Järelikult mis? Ma kirjutan siia
Õpetaja: külakomad. Ja mis ma nüüd kirjutan? Siia
Õpetaja: User Id Onju viga ei tohi teha, Sest Kogu süsteem on taaski peal niimoodi üles ehitatud.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tuleb alles see teine pool. Välju.
Õpetaja: No kus mul on. See välju praegult mõnusalt Ja mugavalt
Õpetaja: meie mängumaa on praegult selline. Pluss välised asjad, kus on meie backendi poolt saadetud User Id
Õpetaja: Respons saaks ka, kui tahaks, niimoodi Aga ma pigem ei läheks seda teed pidi. Tahaks veidi mugavamalt
Õpetaja: välju. On rohkem kui null. Ei, meil on mingi kindel value, mis me vastab. Meie tahame saada kätte seda, et kui mina saadan sõnumi.
Õpetaja: Noh, võtame need Break Point Id maha võtta.
Õpetaja: Tema vastab meile, midagi, Tema Ütleb, et User Id on üks.
Õpetaja: See peab minema sinna. Seda väärtust on vaja.
Õpetaja: Seda väärtust on vaja panna. Sinna See ongi meie missioon Ja meie missioon on siin User Id Ja üks
Õpetaja: on praegu meie missioon.
Õpetaja: Aga seda siin ei ole. Ma Kleerin, Ära vaata selle sellel juba säilinud
Õpetaja: Saime kuskilt. Kust me ta saime? Kuhu me ta panime?
Õpetaja: Data, bloki, data. Bloki me teda ei pannud. Data blokist. Me saime ta kätte, aga
Õpetaja: aktsias aktsiaseltsides asju panna. Aktsiasid on teenus, kus saab käivitada sõnumite saatmist kohe.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, väga. Hea. Kas me siin samal real Võtame kõik andmed ja paneme kupatusena siia. On ju, et me just proovisime ju ka. Me vaatasime ju sealt Voest. Vaata, et seal need Andmed on login Responsis oli user. Id oli üks ja
Õpetaja: ma ei usu vä. Vaatame uuesti. Login Respons User. Id on null.
Õpetaja: Ma korra Vajutan uuesti.
Õpetaja: Siin oli vahepeal. Ee, on ju
Õpetaja: loogiline spons. I. Sees on need olemas. See on ju meie objekt Ja meie meie praegult, Meie Siis see sildikene, millega me saame suhelda programmis.
Õpetaja: Siis mina küsin. Seda Vaata, et kui see Z meetod nüüd töötab niimoodi, kus ta Nüüd on siin, onju, et siin on võti, mille me välja mõtleme. Mis taaskis on öeldud. Ja siia peab nüüd tulema. Päriselt see väärtus.
Õpetaja: Kui me teame, et see on, siis mis ma siia kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Kui hästi anaalselt küsin, mis ma siia kirjutan.
Õpetaja: This login.
Õpetaja: Response
Õpetaja: sobib
Õpetaja: liikuma,
Õpetaja: Jah, ei sobi. See on ju kogu vastus praegu seal sees, on nii? User Id kui ka roll. Name
Õpetaja: lisatalu.
Õpetaja: Jaa, täpselt, vaata kui See asi. Ma klikin selle, peale, kuhu me kukume. Vaata, tatablokid. Kui see asi on kogu see asi. No mina tahan tulla siia Grammi võrra sügavamale. Me oleme teinud seda juba ja
Õpetaja: kuidagi.
Õpetaja: Ja punkt User It ja mõnus on veel selle asja juures, see, et kui ma Panen punkti. Nüüd on tal ees mudel, mida pakkuda.
Õpetaja: Property na pakute user Id ja Role I vaatad, sest need on seal sees, vaatamata Saate aru?
Õpetaja: Vot nüüd ei saa vigu ka enam teha.
Õpetaja: Vot see on ka veel eriti hea.
Õpetaja: Nüüd see asi töötab. Vaatame, kui mina Lähen praegult siia. Application Session Stores. Isse. Kui ma teen igaks juhuks refresh
Õpetaja: ja ma tulen panen siia. Aa, pole mida ma siia panen? Stoplight vastab niikuinii, mis peaks ilmuma siia, Kui ma vajutan logi sisse.
Õpetaja: User Id ja üks ma vajutan.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd ta ootab, Okei, kõik Vajutasid vä?
Õpetaja: Tuli aega võttis. Saime oma spinnerid näha. Tuli
Õpetaja: sellepärast, et Session Storage set Key user Id value this Login Response Punkt User Id Sai selle väärtuse ja pani selle sinna kõik.
Õpetaja: Kui me nüüd läheme siitje. Enam ma ei ütle seda sõna. Võibolla ütlen hiljem, kui Me läheme Siitie minema
Õpetaja: uude kohta. Meil on koht, kus me saame selle üles pikkida, kui meil on vaja. Ja meil on seda vaja
Õpetaja: Tegelikult selles Demo rakenduses ka enda tegelt väga ei lähegi vaja. Aga päris rakenduses juba läheks Vaja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Selle saame tehtud.
Õpetaja: Vastusest saadud Roll Name väärtus salvestatakse faili võtmega. Roll name. No kuidas väga kiirelt seda ära teha.
Õpetaja: Ee, kontroll teed ja muudame ära on ju
Õpetaja: Ee, Nüüd on tasub teha see pool ennem. Vaata, ee, et sees on R tähega
Õpetaja: rollname. See nüüd on kaksisv Copy Control ja vasak Nool Kontrol, kaks isv. Noh, võite lihtsalt ka kasutada. Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on need mõlemad olemas.
Õpetaja: Nüüd See missioon on täidetud
Õpetaja: nii muina.
Õpetaja: Mis Nüüd edasi.
Õpetaja: Mis nüüd edasi. Menüüst peidetakse ära. Sisselogimise link. Ma vaatan kellaaega.
Õpetaja: Ma Teeks praegult natukene midagi lihtsamat. Saame mingid kiired võidud. Vaata, Siis tuleme tagasi nii, kui nii, peab need sammud ka ära tegema. Järjekorda lihtsalt läheks sellega. Peale edukat sisselogimist suunatakse kasutaja pangaautomaatide asukohtade vaatele,
Õpetaja: See vaade meil tegelikult on olemas.
Õpetaja: Ee, Atm s vaatele. Kui ei usu.
Õpetaja: Ee, ta on väiksel kujul ära tehtud. Tulen siia Views alla. On Adams View
Õpetaja: Kui vaadata ruuteri alt, et kas siin ka on? Olemas, on atems. Vaade on nii?
Õpetaja: Meil on siin see rooting olemas, Vaata, kuhu üldse on võimalik minna. Idee järgi
Õpetaja: meie rakenduses. Mis asi see on?
Õpetaja: Mhmh Ruut.
Õpetaja: Kui me läheme nüüd sinna, login View Sse Peale seda, kui meil on kõik need asjad olemas.
Õpetaja: Kui me kirjutame siia ruuter, aga tabiga
Õpetaja: vajutada seda miks? Sest ülesse skripti tuleb impordida.
Õpetaja: Ei usu, Lähme ülesse Tuli Ruuter router indeks.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Ruuteril on ee. Siis ka meetodid. Kuidas meetodeid saab käivitada.
Õpetaja: Noh, ja tee oma see Sõrmeliigutuse Jälle
Õpetaja: punkt.
Õpetaja: Seda te ei tea, aga siin on niukene meetod Nagu Push.
Õpetaja: Kui te mingeid meetodid välja, kutsute ta temaga varasemalt väga Tuttav ei ole. Mida võiks siia vajutada?
Õpetaja: Control B, Et vaadata, et kas ta ootab midagi sisse? Tema ütleb, et ta ootab sisse Ee, Sildi nimi on two
Õpetaja: Lükka. Kuhugi mind ruuter. Buss kuhugi vaatele
Õpetaja: kui. Siin on suurte tähtedega mingi faili nimi millele, see justkui viitab poski Ajal korra arutasime seda asja.
Õpetaja: Control B Access, Request Configy.
Õpetaja: Ta Tegelikult ootab sisse mingisugust konkreetset objekti.
Õpetaja: See Tähendab seda, et see on mingisugune objekt, kus on mingid kindlad väljad. Ta nõuab päriselt nagu Javascripti objekti selles klassis
Õpetaja: koos Võibolla mingi väljade seadistustega.
Õpetaja: Kuidas me saame teha kiirelt ühe uue objekti kõige lihtsamal kindlamal viisil. Niimoodi, et me mingid väljad täidame kohe ka ära.
Õpetaja: Noh, ei tee seda Vaata kohe. Kindlasti Sa Pead üle mitme rea tegema.
Õpetaja: Kuidas saab teha koodis ühe uue objekti literaalsel viisil otse kirjaviisis Loogilised sulud.
Õpetaja: See nüüd tekitab objekti ja meie Saame seda objekti kohe siin disainida.
Õpetaja: Ja see objekt peab vastama Root Location Ro mõtetele. Või vähemalt need väljad, mis seal on,
Õpetaja: siis me saadame, käivitame mingi tegevuse. Me anname infot kaasa, Aga me ei anna nüüd eraldi väikeste parameetritena seda infot kaasa, vaid me anname lihtsalt kogu objektina kaasa. Me anname sellele ee meetodile kaasa objekti. Kus sees on informatsioon, mille najal ta siis teab, mida ta peab tegema,
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: kui Isegi soovitan. Võib uue rea lüüa Näete. Et siin on mitu. See on? Objekte Siin on veerud ja väljad.
Õpetaja: Nüüd oleks vaja siis öelda talle, et kuhu sa võiksid või? Noh, mis on see info? Kui panna kontroll tühik, siis ta näitab meile neid. Välju
Õpetaja: Kõik need B,
Õpetaja: on mingisugused väljad. Mida siis saab sinna infona kaasa panna ja ära defineerida, mis teil läheks, ilma
Õpetaja: kui see on ruuter, oleks üks variant, küll.
Õpetaja: Kui ma paneksin selle ja kooloni
Õpetaja: ja nüüd siia saab stringi kujul panna Raja, vaata siis, mis oleks see raja rada, kuhu me tahaks minna.
Õpetaja: Oli Atm. S.
Õpetaja: Jah, meil on ju Ruuteri indeksisse ära pandud, et meil on niuke rada nagu Atm. S Onju, on, nii
Õpetaja: Me vaatame korra seda definitsiooni.
Õpetaja: Name Atms, Root Component. Atms View, on ju nii Okei,
Õpetaja: aga nüüd on üks konks, et kui ma panen selle siia Atmsi vaatame.
Õpetaja: Teeme need kõik ee igal pool ära. Meie rakendus are areneb. Elab nagu mingisugune viis aastat, või mis iganes tuleb mingi uus arhitekt ja ütleb, et teate, ühtlustame siin erinevate rakenduste vahel igasuguseid urle. Vaata, et oleks sama nagu konventsiooni ja tavaga, et, noh, Siin rakenduses on natukene nad kuidagi teistmoodi. Kui nüüd tahame, teha. Vaata
Õpetaja: kui sul on triljon kohas kuskil seda paati, siis on jälle see, Vaata, et mingi tahab väikest muudatust purlides,
Õpetaja: Aga need on pilla palla igal pool laiali.
Õpetaja: Siis on nagu see taas. Võib olla nagu päris Suur, väga pugitootlik. Midagi Jääb märkamata. Midagi jääb valesti ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Võibolla see paah ei ole nagu kõige parem lähenemine, lähenemine selle konkreetse ruudiga.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, mis võiks olla parem lähenemine, kui me vaatame uuesti, kus see meetod oli.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: ja ja mäletate, kui ma esimeses Taaskis oli ka öelda, et me ei kasuta lihtsalt siin Atmsi, vaid kasutame veel seda nimetamiskonventsiooni, et alati on ruut.
Õpetaja: Saate aru, sellele rajal on nimi.
Õpetaja: Kui me kasutame seda nime nüüd igal pool üle projekti. Tule siia, tule. Siia ja siin on meil ära defineeritud, et asub Rajal Atms.
Õpetaja: Kui nüüd tuleb ja ütleb, et. Kuulge, see see rada on. Teeme nüüd teistmoodi, et ühtlustame et kuskil mujal on, ka siis Tuled siia, muudad selle raja ära. Igal pool on viited ainult sellele kohale, mis viitab sellele rajale.
Õpetaja: No nii muidugi, väga, hea, väga hea.
Õpetaja: No kus ma jäin? Jääme siia, Push I juurde. Et mis valiku me siit siis valime?
Õpetaja: Name tema nüüd ootab Ga siia Stringi kujul Mingit infot. No mida kuradit me siis sinna kirjutame?
Õpetaja: Ma soovitan Kui te. Teete oma töid, siis copy based. Iga seda asja see pugi ei tule väga lihtsalt välja, kui midagi muud läheb.
Õpetaja: See on ju kuidagi triviaalselt lihtne, nagu, et ee, nii palju on, kuigi ma näen, et Tiina sul silm vahepeal vajab. Kinni juba. Vaata, et
Õpetaja: esimese peal kohe kohe lõpetame. Ka.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on niimoodi, et ta Push Ib meid sellele lehele, siis sellise.
Õpetaja: Ee, käsuga.
Õpetaja: Me saame seda kohe ju proovida ka.
Õpetaja: Kui ma kirjutan siia midagi. No võibolla väike refresh ja eks ju üks koodilõiguna.
Õpetaja: Viis kuhugi
Õpetaja: töötab.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui vaadata koera. Nüüd
Õpetaja: siukest asja. Vaata, et pangaautomaadid Proof of Conceptina ta tegelikult võiks ka siis näidata. User Id. See pilt on veits vale. Ma vahetan selle järgmiseks korraks ära. Ja ta peaks näitama User Id Rollname i meil seda Dropdown. I veel. Pole.
Õpetaja: Ahaa, Okei.
Õpetaja: Võibolla siis, kui me oleme praegu selles lainel, siis teeme selle asja ära.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on siis see, et Ee, hetkel nagu progemine. Nagu siin. Selles vaates saab otsa kinni panna. Praegu pange.
Õpetaja: Kuhu vaatesse läheme? Siis kui me tahame minna siia toimetama.
Õpetaja: No Jah, ega siin väga palju. Variante pole.
Õpetaja: View lahti. Hetkel. Meil ei ole siin väga palju action eit,
Õpetaja: nüüd mõte on see, No, Seal on nagu see, et kuva alerdina.
Õpetaja: Okei, võime visuaalselt ka kuvada Kui ma näiteks siia alla panna niimoodi. Jah, ee, võiks öelda nagu, et ee,
Õpetaja: user Id on ja role ei on näiteks
Õpetaja: kui teha, niimoodi. Näiteks et, ee, Teen sellest dublikaadi ja näiteks kahel real
Õpetaja: selline missioon, et me saame kätte selle info.
Õpetaja: Sest te teete, nagu ma. Siis te teete midagi taolist. Näiteks vaata, kui sa selekteerid juhuslikult hiirega, Siis ta täpselt nii teebki.
Õpetaja: Aga mõte on sama. Vaata, et ta on selekteeritud. Vaata selektsioonis. Kui sa teeksid niimoodi. Vaata, oletame, et oleks Juhuslikult niimoodi. Ja sul selektid. Vaata praegu siin Selles selektsiooni sees mõttes, et duplitseerid ei ole reavahetust.
Õpetaja: Kui Tuled, siia ja dublitseerid, vaata, siis On reavahetus ka osa sellest selektsioonist lihtsam on see. Vaata, et ärge selekteerige midagi, vaid hoidke lihtsalt see care pilku joonekene. Samal real,
Õpetaja: kui Te tahate publitseerida, et ära ärge selectige.
Õpetaja: Ee, või siis te peate selectima niimoodi. Vaata, et tuleb.
Õpetaja: Noh, veel rohkem, Vaata aga nii on tüütu. Vaata antud stsenaariumis.
Õpetaja: Plaan on see. Vaata, et paneme praegu siia. X ja Y Onju, et kui me tuleme siia pangaautomaadid vaatelehele,
Õpetaja: isegi Praegult Vaata, peaks see asi toim idee järgi saaks juba tulla see info siia. Sest miks ma teen praegu inspektiga lahti ja lähen vaatan Application Session Storage.
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, et see informatsioon on mul hetkel olemas, On ju?
Õpetaja: See ei ole ainult login. Noh, see on nüüd kogu aeg. Ma võin siin käia ringi. Niimoodi. Viu, piu, piu, piu, piu, piu, piu, piu, piu. See Session Storage It Kuidagi ei mõjuta.
Õpetaja: Nii, Missioon on siia. Saada need väärtused.
Õpetaja: No nüüd hakkad kontrollküsimused tulema, kohe. Vaata,
Õpetaja: Mida, Meil on vaja üldse, et teoreetiliselt saaks tulla siia Need väärtused, mida on, vaja
Õpetaja: et üldse teha see võimalikuks praegusel hetkel, Nagu et üldse, teha võimalikuks, et siia midagi kuvada dünaamiliselt
Õpetaja: muuta väga, Hea, Kus kohas?
Õpetaja: Data blokis.
Õpetaja: Kus see data blokk on?
Õpetaja: Pole Teeme. Kuhu? Teeme Script i alla. Täpsemalt
Õpetaja: siia, Eksport Default Ja siia name All Hetkel, onju?
Õpetaja: Data on oma olemuselt meetod.
Õpetaja: Kirjutame Data on nimi. Mis meetodil järgmisena tuleb? Peale Nime
Õpetaja: tulevad.
Õpetaja: Kuulge järgmiseks korraks Meetodi struktuuri Õpite selgeks. Igal juhul sulud
Õpetaja: et äkki mingit parameetreid asju. Vaata, sulud, mis siis järgneb?
Õpetaja: Ma küll
Õpetaja: ja keha loogiliselt surud. Kahjuks ta tegi Isegi ära vaata nii. Ee, Datablokk on oma olemuselt meetod, mis tagastab andmemudeli objekti, Mis ma järgmiseks kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Data Block on oma olemuselt meetod, mis tagastab andmemudeli objekti.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma kirjutan siia.
Õpetaja: Triin. Vahepeal peab aitama klassi hädast välja. Vaata onju. Loomulikult
Õpetaja: ta tagastab andmemudeli objekti. Kuidas ma Saan siia objekti nüüd järsku tekitada niimoodi defineeritud objekti.
Õpetaja: Mul on vaja teha ühte. Mul on vaja nagu jälle. Vaata, New Object, nagu. Vaata, Aga ma ei tee. Nii Ma teen objekti kohe, nii et seal on väärtused ka olemas. Andmemudeli objekt.
Õpetaja: Loogilised suud tekitabki objekti ja sellise objekti, nagu mina Tahan seda.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, kui me rääkisime, et oleks vaja nagu neid muutujaid, siis mis võiks olla need muutujate nimed? Alustame sellest Esimesest,
Õpetaja: mis võiks olla muutuja nimi Siin,
Õpetaja: muidugi. Mis siin ikka nuputada ju täpselt samad nimed.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on kui me klassikaliselt oleme teinud niimoodi, et anname talle algväärtuse. Mis on siis niiöelda? Niiöelda? Näiteks tühistring või? No antud juhul peaks number olema null. Ma arvan siis, onju
Õpetaja: Nüüd on, see, et me jagame. Tahame tegelikku väärtust saada.
Õpetaja: Kus on meil see väärtus, kuhu me toppisime selle väärtuse,
Õpetaja: mis ma võiks siis siia kirjutada,
Õpetaja: et seekord ei tule nagu mingi väike väärtus. Lihtsalt null või üks, mis iganes, vaid mis ma kirjutan siia
Õpetaja: noh, just, ütles Etaja, kus ta on?
Õpetaja: Kui kirjutada siia Session Storage, Mis nüüd edasi?
Õpetaja: No mingi punkt. Igal juhul on ju, et, ee, midagi saaks kutsuda välja.
Õpetaja: Ja kett. Aitam, mida kett aitam ootab sisse. No kontroll B väljastab, mida ta ootab.
Õpetaja: Stringi Noh, Stringi, me teeme kuidas ülakomad
Õpetaja: nüüd on siia vaja. Nagu mingit tühja. Stringiga vist ei leia sealt nagu midagi, mis on meie võti võtme väärtus.
Õpetaja: Mida me otsime?
Õpetaja: Võti, mille järgi. Me otsime väärtust See oli user Id.
Õpetaja: Kui ma praegu teen Refresh I ära, kuidas ma saan kohe juba testida, vaata et see Idee järgi töötab, Sest Et Refresh Ides ju kõik andmed saadakse, et. Kas seal on midagi?
Õpetaja: Ma juba saaks kontrollida, et kui Jupiti töötab, et kas see, kas nagu töötab või ei tööta.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ma saan kontrollida, et seal on üks?
Õpetaja: Noh, keegi? Ennem tegi selle Flow,
Õpetaja: onju Ja siit täpsemalt. Nii te nüüd saate aru. Kui kurjad olid head inimesed, kui nad nagu kursuse lõpus said, selle
Õpetaja: lugina lehekülje all on Ka kohe puudub
Õpetaja: Aa, ta on natuke pugina. Sa mõtled seda, on ju? Temaga On so so. Mul on nagu okei, võime seda kasutada, Aga ainult siis, kui see asi on mingi normaalse asjaga.
Õpetaja: Vot nii, siin all on ka. Näete, Niukene.
Õpetaja: Me võime seda kasutada senikaua, kuni Tundub, et vahel on parem seal. No teeme siis nii.
Õpetaja: Teeme lahti Komponendid.
Õpetaja: Kas data all on Databloki all on User Id, eks On Töötas Refresh In siin lehel ja parabiim perabuom.
Õpetaja: On.
Õpetaja: Sul on null.
Õpetaja: No, sul on koodis. Lihtsalt arvatavasti siin null. No pakuks Ei, ole Ma Refresh I tegid Efis
Õpetaja: Vahel Ta saab vahel. Ta ei saa aru, et ee. Hotellileod on vaja teha.
Õpetaja: Mm, ja praegu ei näe vastuse võlgu.
Õpetaja: Ma arvan, et sa oled mingi pugi või mis iganes. Kuulge, esiteks, kas sa vaatasid seda siit
Õpetaja: või sa vaatasid seda inspekti häält.
Õpetaja: Aga vaata korra siit poe alt ja üks ka. Vaata, kas siin on teistsugune tulemus. Siis jõuame võibolla vastusele lähemale, Võibolla mitte,
Õpetaja: kui Nad Voe peale komponents.
Õpetaja: Vaatame siia Püha
Õpetaja: Aa. Okei, Sõnaga on all siis on see, et, ee, sulle hoopis on salvestamisega probleem Application Session Storage sul ei ole user. Id siin.
Õpetaja: Sul on Sal. Ta ei ole ära salvestanud. Kas sa oled sisse proovinud? Logida
Õpetaja: Ahhaa. Näed, tee See liigutus kõigepealt ära Sisselogimine.
Õpetaja: Pane mingid väärtused. Vajuta logi sisse.
Õpetaja: Sul on ee. Tal on praegult see osa on lihtsalt tühi
Õpetaja: tal ei olegi midagi üles pikkida sellepärast, et see on tühi.
Õpetaja: Ja kui mina teen nüüd praegu Refresh I,
Õpetaja: Kui mina teen praegu refresh I ja Vaatan on minul kanne all.
Õpetaja: Näed, on all user Id.
Õpetaja: Ta lihtsalt ei ole klõbistanud nuppe.
Õpetaja: Logimine Ee.
Õpetaja: Aa. Okei siis on koodi teema Praegu ee siis sellesse rohkem ei süvene, et see ei ole mingi.
Õpetaja: Mis me nüüd siin veel teeme? Kui taas, kui oli ka roll Name kätte saada.
Õpetaja: Kontroll, tee võibolla koma enam panna. Vaata ja siis Control D
Õpetaja: siin. Selle asemel Siis on ee, role name, Mitte niimoodi Role name ja võti on samamoodi.
Õpetaja: Role Name
Õpetaja: ee viimased üheksa minutit.
Õpetaja: Mul on üks mõte veel. See on nagu ülilihe, et taskis oli öeldud, et peab tulema Alert
Õpetaja: ja nende väärtustega. Proovime siis korra seda ka Javascripti. Kust seda saab kirjutada,
Õpetaja: saab kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Seda ei saa suvaliselt kuskile kirjutada. Vaid meil peab olema Tulge seal peale, name. Pange Enter Methods.
Õpetaja: No kui ma ütlen, Methods, mis on järgmine sümbol
Õpetaja: Loogilised suud. Miks, Sest et sellel asjal peab olema mingi ulatus?
Õpetaja: Ee, koma siia lõppu ka. Vaata, et kõik iga plokk peab olema komaga eraldatud,
Õpetaja: nii
Õpetaja: Okei, saab natuke lühemalt ka. Ee, nüüd on vaja teil tutvustada ka sellist asja, et kui te kuskile lehele niiöelda saabute, on tihtipeale vaja Käivitada tegevusi. Kõige tavapärasemalt tegevus on see, et on vaja mingeid andmeid laadida.
Õpetaja: No kui sa tuled siia lehele, sul on vaja, oleks andmed olemas,
Õpetaja: siis on vaja õppida ka see asi ära. Et, ee, millist tööriista saame kasutada, niimoodi et kui leht laetakse või refreshitakse, et käivituks Mingisugune tegevus
Õpetaja: Selle jaoks on eraldi blokk. Ee, metsad. Siis jätame korra siia kõrvale. Tuleme siia alla.
Õpetaja: Siin on kaks varianti. Üks on Mounted.
Õpetaja: Kus Sees saab kohe kirjutada? See laetakse nii või naa. Sa ei pea isegi meetodit siia tegema. Meetodeid teed siia. Sa võid teha niimoodi, et sa teed siin mingi meetodi. Mis midagi. Teeb.
Õpetaja: Me panemegi show alert. Teeme siia Mehtad Show alert.
Õpetaja: Sulud Control shift enter. Ainuke asi, Mis ta teeb, hakkab alertima. Mida ta peab alertima? Ta peab alertima. User Id. Näiteks
Õpetaja: Getame Alert.
Õpetaja: Võibolla mingi väike tekst ka user Id Pool on tühik. Mis ma siia panen,
Õpetaja: Plussi. Kus ma saan selle user? Id.
Õpetaja: Noh, ja ta on ju meil Olemas Siin onju Ee, This Punkt, user. Id Show Alert on. Ee,
Õpetaja: on hall. Mis see tähendab nii? Aga vaadake, kui me oleme siia Mounted bloki, kus kohas saab ka kohe ka kirjutada. Ma võin panna praegu. Lihtsalt. Tere, siia. Paneme korra. Tere,
Õpetaja: kui ma tulen. Pangaautomaadid lehele laetakse. Tere, on nii?
Õpetaja: Nii, aga siin on võimalik käivitada ka siis neid meetodeid, mis asuvad siin.
Õpetaja: Kui ma. Mis ma kirjutan, see nüüd on nagu samamoodi Kuidas meetodid välja saab Kutsuda. Siin selles osas
Õpetaja: tuul. Jah, Ei, kas mitte midagi on puudu?
Õpetaja: Muidu sa oled õigel teel Ja
Õpetaja: kogu aeg kutsusime salammeetodeid välja, asju kogu aeg. Vaata, et seda tuleb meeles hoida Ja pane need sulud ka.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on siis see, Vaata, et niipea kui Seal see leht laetakse. Ee, siis, ee. Käivitub Meetod Show Alert. Kus sees on Alert ja peaks siis kuvama Vaatame,
Õpetaja: user Id all ma Pean sisse logima.
Õpetaja: Noh, Stoplight come on.
Õpetaja: Vau, kas kõik klõbistasid siis praegult, et login? Mis ma nüüd ootan siin.
Õpetaja: Okei, no tere, pressi
Õpetaja: tuli Userridi, eks?
Õpetaja: Ja noh, kui see ära pane, siis ta läheb. Ta. Ta arvab, et üks, kaks, kolm. Ja need on mingid idiootsed Paroolid. Vaata, Brauser ütleb meid kaitsta. Vaata, et sul on lühikesed lollakad paroolid.
Õpetaja: Ee, mida ta ka teab? Ee, aga nüüd on ainukene üks Vahe on siin sellele. Lisaks sellele Mountain on natuke Niukene Lazy. Mulle ei meeldi see. Kui tead, mida sa teed, siis tahaks kasutada hoopis Niukest asja vastavalt vajadusele on olemas Niuke Asi nagu Before
Õpetaja: on Mount ja Before. Mount.
Õpetaja: Ee on Mounted ja Before. Mount Ee Before ja Mountai erinevus on see.
Õpetaja: Kui sul on lihtsalt Mount
Õpetaja: või maunteed, siis Ta toimib ka enda, niimoodi, et ta vähemalt oma mälus renderdab selle Ee, Html i Temple Template osa renderdab ära. Või ta laeb seda
Õpetaja: ja siis käivitab need asjad, mida sa oled siia ära defineerinud,
Õpetaja: Before, Mis on tegelikult parem asi. Aga sa pead teadma, mis sa teed. On see, et ta ei hakka üldse seda osa näppima ega renderdama, vaid käivitab need asjad, mis on siin.
Õpetaja: Ta käivitab selle show Alert I ennem,
Õpetaja: kui ta teeb. See. See on parem selles mõttes et Oleneb, kuidas meil disain. Mingi spinnerite asjad on ka tehtud. Onju nagu lehekülje vahetusel,
Õpetaja: et see küsimus on see vaata, et ee, kas on Nagu parem teha niimoodi, et ta siis kandja laeb. Need asjad andmed ära ja andmed on olemas. Ja nüüd siis hakkame vaatama, mida me kokku Paneme nendest andmetest kohape,
Õpetaja: et seal on nagu selline nagu värk. Vaata aga, kus see väga nagu rämedalt kätte maksab, on see, kui hakata tegema niukest asja, et ma korra näitan seda, Aga see on ka kõik
Õpetaja: me saame. Tegelikult mäletan. Ma ütlesin, niimoodi et see siin Me saame ainult käitumist mõjutada, niimoodi et
Õpetaja: me dataga manipuleerime. Vaata, mida näidatakse. Mitte
Õpetaja: see ei tähenda seda, et mul ei ole võimalust näiteks
Õpetaja: panna sellele külge, eriti kui ta on mingi, ee, niiöelda interaktiivne element. Aga mitte isegi niisama. Ma saan panna siia referentsi,
Õpetaja: et Hei, siin Templetis. See konkreetne niiöelda element Temal. On tshow Ee, boks. Mida iganes
Õpetaja: ma saan panna referentsi külge
Õpetaja: ja nüüd tähendab seda, et ma skripti sees. Näete, siin sees. Ma kaaperdan korra selle. Ma saan teda puudutada ja midagi temaga teha. Ma saan öelda, kas on nüüd Aa, ma ei mäleta, kas peab dollarit panema või mitte.
Õpetaja: Ee, dissiga. Ikkagi hakkab see viitama. Vot nii dollar märke ette.
Õpetaja: Ma panen punkti, siis ta Näeb kõiki elemente, mis mul on siin.
Õpetaja: Näete seda Html Develement User Id Showbox. Ma saan programmiliselt viidata sellele templeidile, aga nüüd on oht
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, kui sul on before Mount, tähendab seda, et käivita kood ennem, kui sa template it hakkad üldse kokku panema
Õpetaja: ja kui ta siin praegu selles koodi osas viitab mingisugusele Htm elemendile, mida veel ei ole laetud.
Õpetaja: Siis tuleb viga Ehk Kui mul oleks siukene lähenemine, siis ma ei saa kasutada seda Before Mountai, vaid siin oleks õige Mountain. See tähendab seda, et ta kõigepealt selle template paneb kokku
Õpetaja: mälus ja nüüd Alles käivitab Show Alert I, kus nüüd viidatakse sellele asjale.
Õpetaja: Vot see oligi vanasti ka. Vaata, et pidevalt võis tulla kes pugiseid asju pidid meeles hoidma ja nii edasi. Aga kõige parem lähenemine on see, et kui vähegi saad,
Õpetaja: Kui sa vähegi saad, siis ära kasuta neid referentse üldse.
Õpetaja: Mul olid vanasti niuksed joonised. Ee, kuidas õpetused, Kuidas referentsidega sai katsuda
Õpetaja: ja elementides referentsiga isegi katsuda. Need õppematerjalid on alati lõbusad Vaata, Väga pervertne oli. Lähme, katsume nüüd seda. Child I seal Ja siis, mis me taga teeme? Kõik onju
Õpetaja: Ee. Ei, kindel. Ei Ee, meil On nagu mõned kohad, kus natukene on vaja. Näiteks see, et ma toon näitena. Vaata, et kus saab faili valida. Element on olemas input Ja fail, näiteks seal. Üks olukord on selline, Kus, ee.
Õpetaja: Sa valid mingisuguse faili ja sa saad selle andmed kätte ja nii edasi on Ju Kui sa nüüd tahad. Nagu ka enne nagu tühistada. Vaata seda, et ära vali mingit faili andmete mõttes. Sa saad teha igast lihtsalt Vaeva fookust. Fookust on ju?
Õpetaja: Aga sul jääb visuaalselt. Jääb seal ette. Vaata ikka, see vana faili nimi, mis oli varasemalt valitud ja seal Kahjuks ei ole ühtegi muud moodust programmeerida. Kui sa pead
Õpetaja: panema referentsi konkreetselt sellele nii öelda elemendile külge, ja siis saad programmeerida niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: Toimeta nüüd selle elemendiga. Ja Seeri, Vaata see faili nimi ära. Sealt midagi taolist, et selles mõttes et on kohad kus, nagu, noh, ei Jää muud üle, on ju Ja on vajalik Ja hea, et see tööriist on olemas. Meil. Aga Me ei. Kasuta seda nagu lihtsalt igapäevaselt
Õpetaja: Davai. Tõmbame joone alla. Panen kohe kõik asjad varsti kinni. Ka enne seda küsin. Ee, nüüd on esimene nädal selja taga.
Õpetaja: Nagu, mitte. Noh, Ma teen selle, panen ära ja siis vaata.
Õpetaja: Ee, seda teha siin vaikselt. Kuidas,
Õpetaja: kuidas? No ma küsin kõigepealt. Kuidas tänane päev oli.
Õpetaja: Pigem Pakun, et keeruline
Õpetaja: nagu nii palju asju Oli täna ka mingid. Tulid mingid koolonid, Loogilised sulud, Session storage, mingid bussid, navigeerimised, Ee, meetodid parameetrid, Tüübid nüüd on nagu läinud. Asi. Natukene, nagu et tuleb seda infot peale
Õpetaja: Ja, ee, ma võin lohutada, sellega et väga paljud elemendid. Mida me siin teeme. Vaata, hakkavad ikkagi nüüd ühel hetkel ka korduma,
Õpetaja: et et tuleb nagu see nagu äratundmisrõõm ja. Ja. Ja. See hetk, kus Te tegelikult hakkate vaikselt. Me praegu teeme veel esimese sõnumi saatmist. Vaata, me päris lõpuni ei jõudnudki sellegagi, onju? Natuke juba jõudsime teha, Tuleb seda asja. Meil tuleb selle rakenduse peale. Vähemalt mingi.
Õpetaja: Kas seitse, kaheksa sõnumi saatmist. Nii või naa, et siin tulevad neid elemente ja siis saab kinnistada, Kinnistada, et see läheb lihtsamaks.
Õpetaja: See läheb lihtsamaks, et varuge kannatust mitte midagi peast ei pea teadma. Me teeme neid asju oksendamiseni. Tuleb muidugi uusi asju koguaeg ka juurde.
Õpetaja: Tuvid pole veel kordagi lennanud. Kostka on ainult ühe korra alla vooland. Onju, et tegelikult me oleme nagu Alles alguses. Ikkagi. Ee, ajakavaga. Ma arvan, et suures pildis me iga kord jõuame siiamaani, kus me täna teiega oleme jõudnud.
Õpetaja: Enamvähem oleme Nagu graafikus. Võibolla. Hästi, natukene Peaks proovima tempot tõsta, aga seal aitaks väga palju juurde. Kui mina vähem jäbiksin lugusid.
Õpetaja: Ee, võibolla vaatan, siis Tõmban tagasi oma jääpimistega.
Õpetaja: Aga nende analoogiate loomine on väga hea. Ju.
Õpetaja: Ja ei kindlasti ka. Noh, eks Ma üldiselt tulebki mõelda igapäevi
Õpetaja: Aa Kahe nädala pärast ja mitte enda ülesanded, vaid esialgu tiimi ülesanded, Aga jah, jah,
Õpetaja: aga meid, ee, mingeid ülesandeid, asju, mingit väikest nokitsemist et siin midagi harjutada. Seda ei ole. Me teeme kogu rakenduse läbi. Ehitame õpetussõnad, oled saanud kätte ja siis te hakkate põrutama ja jällegi ei pea mitte midagi muretsema. Teate, meeskondades,
Õpetaja: kuidas meeskonnad moodustuvad? Räägin sellest, siis kui on aeg. Ee, seal on Niukene element sees, kus Üritad. Üritame teha nagu võrdseid meeskondi. Nagu, ee, niukest Noh Ütleme, kuidagi Kaine nagu võrdseid meeskondi. Ee Õnneelement on seal sees, aga endal on ka natukene
Õpetaja: Ee, Niukene värk saab olema kõike. Kaarte veel ei ava.
Õpetaja: Davai. Ee, kuulge, ee, minge koju,
Õpetaja: Ee. Ja ma proovin nädalavahetuse jooksul panna ka Veel need mõned üksikud. Ee, need. Ee, notebook Lem I videod. Näiteks sinna juurde. Vaadake, kas kui nii.
Õpetaja: Proovi selles mõttes võtke eesmärgiks seda. Vaata, et proovige midagigi panustada.
Õpetaja: Ee, loomulikult olete väsinud. Tahate puhata ja puhake Ka kindlasti. Aga see ei tähenda seda. Et ee, et ee, Kui teil tegelikult on nagu mingi Tv S muljutamise aega, siis tegelikult on aega midagi teha, onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, öelge oma pereliikmetele ka, et Ee, palun olge kannatlikud. Ee, jah, Ma lähen istun arvuti taha. Jah, jälle, ma olen seal.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah, ma ei ole teiega. Vaata aga nagu, Andke aega, et, ee. Saaksite vaadata neid asju seenida. Mida rohkem teete? Mida rohkem vaatate, seda rohkem õpite. Te teete kõike seda päeva lõpuks iseenda jaoks. Kas te teate,
Õpetaja: Ee, mis on teie võimalused ja tahtmised ja soovid Davai?
Õpetaja: Ee, kohtume siis juba uuel nädalal. Loodetavasti kõik on endiselt. Alles Ja polegi midagi rohkem.
Õpetaja: Tead, mitte minu. Minu. Nende koolitustega Väga ikka ei ole, et enamus ikka tulevad taga.